REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES --
THIS -- IN.
MY WELCOME EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WE ARE GOING TO BE.
THE FOCUSING ON OVERSIGHT OF
IMMIGRATION SERVICES CAO FRESH
AND CAL WORKS THE PART PROGRAMS
IN THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES THIS THERE IS NO VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR TODAY ALL ITEMS
WILL BE UP FOR DISCUSSION -- WE
ARE NOT TAKING ANY VOTES TODAY
SO ALL THE ITEMS WILL BE HELD
OPEN -- WE WILL BE TAKING PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER EACH MAJOR
PROGRAMS ITEMS HAVE BEEN HEARD --
SO WHAT WE'LL DO IS -- ACTUALLY
WILL DO THIS FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
FIRST ITEM WHICH IS THE
IMMIGRATION SERVICES BRANCH WILL
HEAR ISSUES ONE THROUGH THREE
FOR THE AGENCY AND THEN WE'LL
TRY HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THAT AND THEN WE'LL HAVE THE
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT.
AND THEN HAVE TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THAT SO.
GENERAL THAT IS -- HOW WE'RE
GOING TO ORGANIZE THIS?
AND WITH THAT LET'S GO AHEAD
BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES IMMIGRATION SERVICE
BRANCH AND WE CAN HAVE -- THE
AGENCY LA -- AND FINANCE FOLKS
PLEASE COME UP TO THE TABLE
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
SO WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH AN
OVERVIEW OF THE FARM SOCIAL
SERVICES ADMINISTRATION SERVICES
BRANCH -- WE WANT TO BEGIN WITH --
INTRODUCTIONS FOR THE RECORD --
SO WE'LL START WITH THE AGENCY.
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MARCELLA RUIZ --
CHIEF WITH THE IMMIGRATION
REFUGEE PROGRAMS BRANCH IN THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES THANK
YOU.
CAN JOHNSON DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES DEPUTY DIRECTOR THANK
YOU HELLO JENNY BELLA
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
THANK YOU FINANCE.
SYDNEY TAMAKO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT --
SO ONCE YOU GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
AND I THINK WE HAVE.
SO FOR THE OVERVIEW WE DID HAVE
THREE QUESTIONS -- FOR THAT WE
HAVE A GOOD WRITE UP SO
BASICALLY SITTING THE HIGHLIGHTS
THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN
SENATOR STONE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE THIS MORNING AND TALK
ABOUT THE IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICES -- THE THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS ASKED FOR FOR AN
OVERVIEW AS YOU PROBABLY ARE
AWARE WE ARE CURRENTLY
ADMINISTERING TO ONGOING LEGAL
SERVICES IMMIGRATION PROGRAMS
ONE CALIFORNIA OR IMMIGRATION
SERVICES FUNDING AND THE
UNACCOMPANIED UNDOCUMENTED MINOR
PROGRAM.
THE ONE CALIFORNIA PROGRAM IS A
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN THIS CURRENT YEAR
WE ARE FINDING ONE HUNDRED AND
ONE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS TO
DELIVER LEGAL SERVICES.
THE UNACCOMPANIED UNDOCUMENTED
MINOR PROGRAM WHERE YOU U. M.
PROGRAM IS IN ITS FIFTH YEAR
IT'S A THREE MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATION AND TO DATE HAS
SERVED OVER THREE THOUSAND
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS WITH.
REPRESENTATION FOR LEGAL
SERVICES WERE ALSO ADMINISTERS
ADMINISTERING SEVERAL ONE TIME --
INVESTMENTS INCLUDING DOC LEGAL
SERVICES LEGAL SERVICES FOR
BENEFICIARIES OF TEMPORARY
PROTECTED STATUS UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS AND AND OTHER MINERS A
REMOVAL DEFENSE AND AND OTHER
PROGRAMS WHICH WE WILL DISCUSS
LATER ON IN OUR COMMENTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS
PROPOSING TO MAKE ALL OF THE ONE
TIME LEGAL SERVICES INVESTMENTS
ONGOING BRINGING THE TOTAL
INVESTMENT FOR LEGAL SERVICES
TWO SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
THE COMMITTEE HAS ASKED US TO
ADDRESS THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
AND AND CHALLENGES AND
ADMINISTERING THE PROGRAM IN THE
LAST YEAR.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT CERTAINLY
AND OF GREAT SIGNIFICANCE IS
EACH INDIVIDUAL CASE THAT LEADS
TO THE NATURALIZATION.
OBTAINING A GREEN CARD RELEASE
FROM DETENTION THAT LEADS TO
FAMILY BEING YOU RE UNIFIED
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES AND
SAFETY AND SECURITY. FOR FOR
IMMIGRANTS OVER THE COURSE OF
THE PROGRAM NINETY TWO THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS HAVE RECEIVED
SERVICES FOR NATURALIZATION. TWO
TWENTY THOUSAND FOUR FOUR GREEN
CARD STATUS IN OVER SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS HAVE
RECEIVED INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
LEGAL RIGHTS AS IMMIGRANTS --
ANOTHER GREAT SUCCESS OF THE
PROGRAM ACCOMPLISHMENT HAS BEEN
THE DOC A PROGRAM -- WHICH WAS A
ONE TIME INVESTMENT MADE IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND JUST ENDED
AND AND AND MARCH OF THIS YEAR.
THROUGH THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT -- OVER TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
PERSISTED WITH THE RENEWAL
APPLICATIONS INCLUDING SIXTEEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS WHO
RECEIVED ASSISTANCE WITH --
USCIS FILING FEES.
LAST YEAR THE DEPARTMENT HAS
ALSO BEEN INVOLVED WITH A NUMBER
OF PARTNERSHIPS THAT HAVE HELPED
IMPROVE AND EXPAND THE ACCESS
FOR START IMMIGRANTS INCLUDING
VETERANS WHO ARE FACING
DEPORTATION.
OR WHO HAVE BEEN DEPORTED RATHER --
WE CONTINUE TO EXPAND SERVICES
TO UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS AND
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING -- THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND COACHELLA THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND TO THE API
COMMUNITIES BOTH IN THE BAY AREA
AND IN THE LOS ON IN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE CONTINUE CHALLENGES FOR FOR
THE PROGRAM IS OF THE LACK OF
CBO INFRASTRUCTURE MEN AND MUCH
OF ROLE CALIFORNIA AND LET
INLAND CALIFORNIA THE DEPARTMENT
IS COMMITTED TO EXPANDING
SERVICES IN THOSE REGIONS AND TO
THAT END HAS MADE TARGETED
INVESTMENTS TO EXPAND THE
SERVICES AND UNDERSERVED REGIONS.
BUT THAT IS THAT THOSE ARE
LEGACY ISSUES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT TRIES TO ADDRESS YEAR
AFTER YEAR IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S EQUITY IN IN THE
SERVICES THAT -- THAT ARE BEING
RECEIVED THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THE THE OTHER CHALLENGES -- THE
CHANGING FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAW
AND POLICY AND THE COMMITTEE HAS
ASKED US TO SPEAK TO THIS AS
WELL.
SO WHEN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN ALONE WE SAW THE FORMAL
AND TO THE TEMPORARY PROTECTED
STATUS UP PROGRAM IMPACTING OVER
FIFTY THOUSAND LONGTIME
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA.
AND A COURT INJUNCTION THAT
FOLLOWED WE SAW THE FORMAL AND
TO DHAKA IMPACT SEEING OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS.
AND VARIOUS COURT INJUNCTIONS
THAT FOLLOWED.
OF THE APPLICATION OF
IMMIGRATION POLICIES THAT HAVE
LED TO FAMILY SEPARATION OF
CHILDREN INCLUDING TODDLERS FROM
THEIR PARENTS.
AND THE COURT INJUNCTIONS THAT
FOLLOWED.
AND THE SIGNIFICANT PROPOSED
CHANGES TO ASYLUM LAW THAT HAVE
LED -- TO TO AT SOME CONFUSION
AT THE BORDER ABOUT HOW ASYLUM
SEEKER SHOULD SHOULD BE PROCESS
AND HERE AGAIN THE COURT
INJUNCTIONS THAT HAVE FOLLOWED.
WE HAVE ALSO SEEN THE PROPOSED
PUBLIC CHARGE RULE THAT COULD
IMPACT MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES AND AND AND
CHILDREN.
ALL OF THESE CHANGES HAVE
REQUIRED THE DEPARTMENT TO TRY
TO BE AS NIMBLE AND RESPONSIVE
AS POSSIBLE AND HOW WE OVERSEE
AND ADMINISTER THE CONTRACTS
WITH OUR LEGAL SERVICES
PROVIDERS WHO ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES TRYING TO CLEAR UP THE
CONFUSION ABOUT THE STATUS OF
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS.
EVERY TIME THERE'S A NEW
HEADLINE ABOUT DHAKA ANYTIME
THERE'S A NEW HEADLINE ABOUT TPS.
THAT BOTH CREATES UNCERTAINTY
AND QUESTIONS FROM FROM THE
IMMIGRANTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
WHO WHO HAVE THE STATUSES IN THE
NEED FOR EDUCATION IN THAT
REGION PERHAPS A LEGAL REVIEW OF
ALL OF THOSE CASES SO THAT IS AN
ONGOING CHALLENGE. FOR FOR BOTH
THE SERVICE PROVIDERS AND FOR
FOR THE PROGRAM.
AND AND FINALLY I WOULD ADD TO
THAT THE GREATEST CHALLENGES
PERHAPS THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A
PRETTY ROBUST IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION POLICY AGENDA.
AND BALANCING THE RESPONSIVENESS
TO THE TO THE DIRECTION THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS IS --
TAKING WITH IT WITH IMMIGRANTS
AND CALIFORNIA'S AGENDA IS THAT
IS ANOTHER AS ANOTHER CHALLENGE
WE ARE TRYING TO BE PROACTIVE IN
ENSURING THAT WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
DRIVING THE PROGRAM IN THE
DIRECTION THAT THE THE POLICIES
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS ENACTED --
ARE ASKING US TO WILL ALSO TRY
TO BE RESPONSIVE TO THE CHANGES
IN FEDERAL POLICY.
AND ALSO UP THERE TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THIS OR WE CAN ALSO SPEAK TO THE
RAPID RESERVE FUND AT THIS POINT.
SURE AND MAYBE DEAL IF WANTS TO
START.
OKAY.
THE TSN HMO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO THIS PROPOSAL FOREVER
RESPONSES REQUESTING TWENTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR A
RESERVE SIMILAR TO FUNDING
STRUCTURE FOR EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS.
AND AND TO STEP BACK A LITTLE
BIT TO GET TO THE AGENDA
QUESTION WHICH I THINK WAS
REALLY TRYING TO GET AN UPDATE
WITH THE CURRENT YEAR FUNDING.
TWO POINT TWO MILLION WAS
TRANSFERRED FROM THE RAPID
RESPONSE RESERVES IN FEBRUARY
TWO DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
WHO MY UNDERSTANDING.
ON MANTA EXISTING CONTRACT WITH
A JEWISH FAMILY SERVICES SO THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE PROVIDING.
AS SERVICES AND OPERAND MARGINS
THE SHELTER AT THE BORDER AND IF.
I'M THRILLED FOR DEFERRED MY
COLLEAGUES SPEAK MORE TO WHAT
THE ACTUAL SERVICES ARE.
THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
HAS HAD A CONTRACT IN PLACE WITH
A JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE TO
PROVIDE A RESPONSIVE SERVICES
INCLUDING CASE MANAGEMENT AND
NOW SHELTERING SERVICES THE TWO
POINT TWO MILLION IS FOR
SHELTERING SERVICES -- AND
THROUGH THAT FUNDING OF THE THE
JEWISH FAMILY SERVICES OPERATING
A SHELTER AND I BELIEVE THEY
HAVE NOW SEEN OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
COME THROUGH THAT SHELTER. FOR
FOR SERVICES THEY ARRIVE IN
CALIFORNIA AND PROCEED ON TO THE
FINAL POINT OF DESTINATION.
THANK YOU -- INCOMES FROM OHIO
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS OR FINANCE
ABOUT THE OTHER PART OF
PRESENTATIONS.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY -- QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT ODDS AND ACTUALLY JUST
IN TERMS OF SO BASICALLY IN
TERMS OF THE IMMIGRATION RAPID
RESPONSE -- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGETING -- SO YOU MENTIONED
THAT LAST FALL FOR THIS CURRENT.
YEAR PATROL AND IN JUNE
THIRTIETH OF RIGHT NOW WITH THE
USED TO A TWO POINT TWO MILLION.
ONE TIME OKAY AND WE'RE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING WAS A FIVE
MILLION.
FOR WELL COME ON THE TRIP FIVE
MILLION WAS A TWENTY MILLION A
CURRENT YEAR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IS PROPOSING TWENTY
MILLION HERE BUT OKAY.
AND I REALIZE IT'S RAPID
RESPONSE THOUGH WE DON'T ALWAYS
KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN --
BUT IN TERMS OF THE THINKING
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ABOUT
WHAT WE ANTICIPATE MORE
ACTIVISTS ARE SEE THERE'S AN
INCREASE -- THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED -- BUT CERTAINLY I ALSO
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF ACTIVITY
GOING ON INCLUDING FAMILY
SEPARATION -- WE HAVE -- YOU
KNOW THE THE **** ASYLUM
SITUATION WHICH AND SO FORTH --
SO IT'S FUNDING FOR IN TERMS OF
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WHAT THE
THE ANTICIPATED.
ISSUES MIGHT BE ABSOLUTELY AND
I'M HAPPY TO HEAR THE REFERENCE
TO THIS AS A RAPPER RESPONSE FOR
EMERGENCIES WERE WHICH REALLY
DON'T KNOW WHAT WILL COME
FORWARD AND WE WANT. TO AS THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO HAVE A MECHANISM
IN PLACE TO QUICKLY ADAPT
ESPECIALLY WHERE FEDERAL FUNDING
IS NOT AVAILABLE FOR THIS
POPULATION.
AND WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING ON
TRAVEL TO HELP CLARIFY WHEN IT
WOULD MEET THE THRESHOLD FOR
THIS FUNDING AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
SHARE ONCE WE THAT BECOMES
AVAILABLE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING THAT AND THEN IN TERMS
OF I KNOW THAT OF ONE
CALIFORNIA'S -- PROGRAM THAT WAS
SO STRONGLY SUPPORTED BY POSTS --
THE API CAUCUS IN NINETEEN OH
CAUCUS WHEN I WASN'T THE SAID
CHAIR I WOULD COME AND REPRESENT
THE API CAUCUS ON THAT HE SPEAK
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE TRYING YOU'RE
DOING WITH THE API COMMUNITY --
AND TERMS F IN TERMS OF HELPING
PROVIDE IMMIGRATION SERVICES --
YOU KNOW THAT ACTUALLY OVER HALF
OF ALL API WHO RESIDE IN
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY IMMIGRANTS
THEMSELVES.
SO IT'S CERTAINLY A A AND I
THINK IT'S THE FASTEST GROWING
IMMIGRANT POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
YES THANK YOU UP.
IT MY SALARIES FROM DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES -- THE APEC
COMMUNITY IS IN FACT THE FASTEST
GROWING UNDOCUMENTED.
IMMIGRANT POPULATION IMMIGRANT
POPULATION IN IN IN THE STATE
AND IN SOME AREAS OF IMMIGRATION
LEGAL SERVICES MY MOM THE MOST
AND REPRESENTED SO IN THE AREA
OF NATURALIZATION AFFECT THE API
COMMUNITY DOES NATURALIZER FAR
GREATER RATE THAN OTHER
COMMUNITIES BUT IN THE AREA OF
DOCTOR LEGAL SERVICES ARE TAKING.
ADVANTAGE OF OTHER FORMS OF
IMMIGRATION RELIEF THE API
COMMUNITY DOES NOT DOES NOT TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF OF THOSE --
IMMIGRATION SERVICES AS AS OTHER
COMMUNITIES TOO TO THAT END WE
HAVE ME TARGETED INVESTMENTS AND
POT IN.
IN -- ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
EXPERTISE WORKING WITH A P. I.
POPULATIONS PARTICULARLY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND ORANGE COUNTY.
AND NOW WE ARE WORKING TO
PROPOSALS FOR IT FOR THE BAY
AREA AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WE'RE HOPING TO ADDRESS THE
WRATH OF THE ISSUES THAT ARE
SURFACING FOR THE API POPULATION.
I MENTIONED -- THE NEED TO
ENCOURAGE MORE TALKAPPLICATIONS
FOR FOR THE API POPULATION BUT
WERE ALSO NOW SEEING ISSUES
AROUND REMOVAL.
NEED FOR REMOVAL DEFENSE FOR OF
REFUGEE COMMUNITY SOUTHEAST
ASIAN COMMUNITIES AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND AND AND THOSE.
IN THE SOUTH BAY.
THERE IS -- WE'RE WE'RE HOPING
TO DEVELOP MORE EXPERTISE IN THE
API SERVING OR EXPAND RATHER THE
EXPERTISE THE EXPERTISE EXISTS
BUT EXPAND THE SERVICES FOR
REMOVAL DEFENSE. TO BE ABLE TO
REPRESENT -- API POPULATIONS.
IT THAT I MEAN WE KNOW THE TEN
MILLION POPULATION HAS BEEN
TARGETED IN THERE.
FOR NO ANSWER ANY TO PORT.
AND THEN OF COURSE THERE WAS
THAN THE RULING SET THAT UP AND
IN AN AGREEMENT TOWARD THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE PORTING --
VIETNAMESE REFUGEES WHO CAME
OVER AFTER THE VIETNAM WAR AS
USE -- AND THAT THE PORTING THE
BACK TO VIETNAM AND DAY.
NO -- SO IT'S THE DESK STREAMING
CONCERNING -- AND HOPEFULLY OUR
STATE CAN HELP PROVIDE --
ASSISTANCE -- THE FACE OF OF
THESE TERRIBLE POLICY DECISIONS --
I GUESS THE AND AND IN TERMS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE RIGHT SO YOU
MENTION CENTRAL VALLEY ON AND
THE CBO AND I DON'T KNOW IF FOR
THE API COMMUNITY PARTICULARLY
LANGUAGE CAPACITY AND SO FORTH
IS.
IN ADDITION TO HELPING PROVIDE
THE SUPPORTS FOR THE CBO'S AND
AND AND AND SO FORTH -- CAPACITY
BUILDING IS THAT SOMETHING THAT
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT BECAUSE
YOU MENTIONED -- FOR EXAMPLE
LACK OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND THEN I
DON'T KNOW IN TERMS OF THE IT
GUY COMMUTERS ESPECIALLY GIVEN
THE DIVERSITY OF LANGUAGES AND
AND AND AND COMMUNITIES -- AS IT
IS IS THERE A ROLE FOR I GUESS
CAPACITY BUILDING AND AND THIS
PROGRAM THAT -- WE NEED TO BE
LOOKING MORE INTO.
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY AN ELEMENT OF
THE INVESTMENTS -- FOR FOR THE
API POPULATION -- BUILDING
CAPACITY ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ALREADY MAY HOW THE LANGUAGE
CAPACITY BUT DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE THE LEGAL EXPERTISE TO
PROVIDE THE MORE COMPLEX
SERVICES SO THAT'S ONE ELEMENT
OF CAPACITY BUILDING.
AND ALSO.
ALSO TRYING TO TO BUILD THE
CAPACITY AND IN PARTICULARLY
UNDER SERVED REGIONS TO BE ABLE
TO SERVE THE CAT POPULATION AS
IN THE SENATE AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY -- MOST OF THESE --
INVESTMENTS INCLUDE EIGHTY EIGHT
LEGAL TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDER WHO IS --
WHO IS CHARGED WITH WITH
PROVIDING THAT COULD LOSE
CAPACITY BUILDING THAT CAPACITY
BUILDING SERVICE TO THAT TO THE
ACTUAL SERVICE PROVIDER?
ALL RIGHT OUTSIDE THE FREE
SHIPPING UPDATED AND MY SAID TO
PASS THE VALUE OF COURSE THAT
AND NOT JUST EIGHTY I COMMITTEE
BUT OVERALL SO AS SOON WHEN YOU
SAID CENTRAL VALLEY WASN'T JUST
EIGHTY I COMMUNITY CAPACITY
BUILDING IN.
CORRECT WE HAVE FOURTEEN
DIFFERENCE A INVESTMENTS
CURRENTLY THAT -- THAT IT BUILD
CAPACITY AND IN DIFFERENT WAYS
REGIONAL CAPACITY CAPACITY FOR
POPULATIONS OUR CAPACITY TO
EXPAND THE AVAILABILITY OF A
VERY SPECIFIC TYPES OF OF LEGAL
SERVICES OKAY.
ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD THANK YOU
THE OTHER QUESTIONS.
ALRIGHT LET'S GO AHEAD AND MOVE
ON TO ITEMS THAT YOU NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS THE HUMAN SERVICES
TECHNICAL PC P. -- THE
DEPARTMENT RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
ADMINISTER THE LEGAL SERVICES
PROGRAM -- OUR REQUESTS INCLUDES
ONE STAFF SERVICES MANAGER TO
ONE STAFF SERVICES MANAGER ONE
THREE ANALYSTS ONE IT SPECIALIST --
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WITH THE
IMMIGRATION UNIT WAS FIRST
ESTABLISHED WITH A FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION THE
INTENT WAS FOR THE TEAM TO
ADMINISTER.
THE TEAM OF FIVE TO MINISTER
CONTRACTS FOR FOR LEGAL SERVICES
AND TO PREPARE FOR POTENTIAL
IMMIGRATION REFORM -- THE
PROGRAM HAS SINCE GROWN TO FIVE
TIMES ITS INITIAL ALLOCATION
EXPANDED SCOPE AND MISS TASKED
WITH SUPPORTING A RESPONSE TO A
BREATH OF OF ISSUES THAT WERE
UNFORESEEN AND TWENTY AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN THE STAFF SERVICES
MANAGER -- TO THE ROLE WOULD BE
TO OVERSEE -- INCREASINGLY MORE
COMPLEX OPERATIONS INCLUDING
DATA SYSTEMS FOR THE LEGAL
SERVICES PROGRAMS STAFF SERVICES
MANAGER ONE WOULD.
OVERSEE THE THE CONTRACTING WORK
AND THE ANALYSTS WOULD TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT
OVERSIGHT OF OF NEW PROGRAMS AND
TO THE I. T. POSITION WHICH
SUPPORTS A OF THE PLATFORM WHICH
IS BEING DEVELOPED TO USE TO
SUSTAIN OUR OUR DATA NEEDS AND
ALSO TO THAT IS EXTERNALLY
FACING TO IMPROVE.
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE OF THE
PROGRAM AND THE EXPERIENCE FOR
THE CONTRACTORS.
THANK YOU UC INCOMES MILIEU.
THANK YOU WE HAVE REVIEWED THE
PROPOSAL AND THE ASSOCIATED
WORKLOAD AND WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
TO RAISE.
FINANCE.
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT.
COULD CERTAINLY MAKES SENSE WE
NEED MORE STAFF WITH MORE
RESOURCES TO MANAGE OKAY --
NEXUS ISSUE NUMBER THREE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE ON CALIFORNIA
NEWCOMER EDUCATION AND WHAT AND
WELL BEING PROJECT COUNTY -- THE
CALIFORNIA NEWCOMER EDUCATION
AND WELL BEING PROGRAM FUND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES A REFUGEE
CHILDREN'S INCLUDING SOME IN A
COMPANY MINORS -- THE SERVICES
INCLUDE ACADEMIC SUPPORT AND
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL ADJUSTMENT
SERVICES.
THE STATE SIDE TEN MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT WAS MADE TO
AUGMENT EXPAND THE SERVICES THAT
ARE CURRENTLY OFFERED THROUGH A
SIMILAR FEDERAL PROGRAM THE
REFUGEE SCHOOL IMPACT THE
PROGRAM WHICH IS ALSO
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT.
HOWEVER AS DROPPED TO THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE DOES NOT ALLOW
FOR A FOR THE CONTEMPLATED
EXPANSION THAT THE STATE WAS
HOPING FOR AND EXCLUDE CERTAIN
AND ACCOMPANIED MINERS.
IN IN MAKING REFERENCE TO THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM -- UNDER FEDERAL
RULES UNACCOMPANIED MINORS ARE
NOT ELIGIBLE AND TELL THEIR
ASYLUM CASES ARE IN FACT
ADJUDICATED WHICH MEANS THAT
CURRENTLY WE HAVE A SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITH A HIGH POPULATION
OF UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
WHO ARE ENROLLED IN SCHOOL BUT
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THAT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM
BECAUSE THEY'RE ASYLUM CASES
STILL PENDING BEFORE USCIS
BEFORE IMMIGRATION?
THANK YOU -- CALMEST FAMILIAL.
REVIEW THIS IS TECHNICAL AND
HAVE NO CONCERNS I THANK YOU
FINANCE.
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH
REPRESENTATION SO WE'LL GO AHEAD
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUES
ONE TWO AND THREE RELATE TO THE
PAR SO SERVICES IMMIGRATION
SERVICE BRANCH -- BACK
BACKGROUND WITHOUT THEM MISTER
CHAIR HER A CLIFF BURKE HERE IN
BEHALF OF JEWISH FAMILY SERVICES
OF SAN DIEGO.
WE JUST WANT TO INDICATE TO US
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSAL FUND THE IMMIGRATION
RAPID RESPONSE PROGRAM IN SAN
DIEGO APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE DO WANT TO BRING TO
YOUR ATTENTION THAT -- THERE IS
ONE POTENTIAL ISSUE THAT'S ON
RESOLVE WHICH IS A SAN DIEGO
COUNTY IS INDICATED THAT THEY
MAY PULL PUBLIC HEALTH SUPPORT.
FOR THE IMMIGRATION -- SERVICES
AT THE SHELTER IF THAT HAPPENS
THEN WE MAY BE BACK -- WE ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON HOW TO DEAL
WITH THE PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE FOR
IMMIGRANTS.
DOWN THERE AND HOW TO FIND IT SO
OBVIOUS SORT OF AN OPEN ISSUE AT
THE MOMENT.
THANK YOU OKAY.
THANK YOU I CERTAINLY HOPE SO.
PUBLIC HEALTH WE CAN.
TAKE CARE OF THAT RIGHT YES
WELCOME ANOTHER AND MEMBERS OF
MANY STEVEN GUY CAN USE OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER REPRESENTING THE ONE
CALIFORNIA COALITION WHICH IS
COMPRISED OF A DIVERSE SET OF
STAKEHOLDERS THAT CAME TOGETHER
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN TO ADVOCATE
FOR THE CREATION OF THE ONE
CALIFORNIA.
PROGRAM ARE WE ONE EXPRESS
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT FOR THAT.
FOR GOVERNOR NUISANCE PUZZLE
TALLA K. A COMBINED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING --
TOWARDS IMMIGRATION SERVICES
THIS PROGRAM HAS PROVED ITSELF
AS A TRUE UNTESTED MODEL FOR
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION AT THE
STATE LEVEL BY MOVING TO AN
ONGOING FUNDING ALLOCATION.
CALIFORNIA WOULD PROVIDE THE
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES WORK
FORCE WITH THE MUCH NEEDED
STABILITY CATER. TO A IT'S OUR
POPULATIONS AND PROVIDE LEGAL
SERVICES AND COUNSEL FOR
RESIDENTS AND ESPECIALLY IN THIS
POLITICAL MOMENT THAT IS RIFE
WITH HATEFUL ANTI IMMIGRANT
RHETORIC AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL WE
THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
THAT CALIFORNIA PROVIDES ITS
LEADERSHIP IN THIS MATTER AND
CONTINUES I'M TO SERVE ITS
IMMIGRATION POPULATE IMMIGRANT
POPULATIONS THANKS SO MUCH THANK
YOU AND EVERYONE'S BEEN GOOD
DADS ARE MIND OR WHEN WE DO THAT
WE ASK PP PEOPLE COMMENTS UNDER
A MINUTE NEVER ONCE THAN THAT SO
FAR SO THANK.
YOU WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CENTER
CERAM SANTANA WITH CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION THE POLICE OF
SUPPORTIVE AND APPRECIATIVE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S ON GOING FUNDING
FOR OUR SERVICES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
NO I BOTTOM REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND APPRECIATE THE
FUNDING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
CHRIS FOR SIGNS WHICH ARE THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
AND ONE CALIFORNIA GRANTEE
SUPPORT DROUGHT VAPORS OF THE
DEPARTMENT THE PARTNERSHIP THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING -- AND ALSO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND
APPRECIATE THE FUNDING.
THANK YOU WELCOME I AM ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA LINE MY COMMENTS WITH
MY COLLEAGUES BEFORE ME IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE ON GOING
FUNDING FOR THE ONE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU WELCOME WARNING THE
SURGERIES WITH A QUALQUER GROUP
HERE ON BEHALF OF CATHOLIC
CHARITIES OF CALIFORNIA AND CAL
THE CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING BATTLE IN COOPER ON
BEHALF OF COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT OF THE IMMIGRATION RAPID
RESPONSE PROGRAM THANK YOU THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MY **** CENTRAL
IMMIGRANT AGGRESSION
COLLABORATIVE.
AND I'M ALSO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
RESEARCH ON MY FELLA OR IS THAT
ABOUT THE NEEDS IN REGIONS LIKE
A CENTRAL VALLEY.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE
THIS TYPE OF INVESTMENT.
IN SUPPORT OF IMMIGRANTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HI I'M GRAYSON CHANNEL FOR MISSY
ARE YOU SEVEN TWO ONE IN LOS
ANGELES AND WORDS SUPPORT OF
ITEM NUMBER ONE FOR THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO PROTECT.
AND AND EDUCATE.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME -- GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS ARE SOLELY ON ONE OF THE
NURSES AYE AND MEMBER OF BASS
YEAH YOU.
AND I'M IN SUPPORT ITEM -- ONE
TO AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
GRAY SUPPORT BY THAT SCA YOU
SEVEN TO ONE MEMBER FROM VENTURA
COUNTY I ALSO WORK FOR HUMAN
SERVICE AGENCY -- AND I SUPPORT
ITEM NUMBER.
ONE AND EVERY CALIFORNIA EVERY
CALIFORNIA REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS THE SERVICE
ACCESS. TO OFFER.
A FORMATION IN TRAINING.
CAMP.
SO I SUPPORT.
ITEM NUMBER.
ONE THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS NADEEM PIXLR
I'M A REGISTERED NURSE FROM LA
COUNTY PART OF ESSAY YOU.
AND I AM ALSO IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
NUMBER ONE OF MY PATIENTS WOULD
BENEFIT FROM.
FROM THIS OKAY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HEY A GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
REBECCA ALL RUN I'M ALSO PART OF
SCA USE SEVEN TWO ONE VENTURA
COUNTY I AM A CLIENT BENEFITS
SPECIALIST AND I HAVE SEEN FIRST
HAND.
HOW THESE ARE SERVICES HAVE
HELPED CLIENTS ARE MY WE'VE GONE
OUT IN OUR COMMUNITIES HELP THEM
FILL OUT THE DOC APPLICATIONS
THE RENEWALS -- AND ALSO BECOME
CITIZENS IT IS.
A IT IS IMPACTING OUR COMMUNITY
IT IS A GREAT SERVICE WERE
PROVIDING AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER ONE AND I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
WHEN I STARTED NOTICES HUMAN
THOSE HAVING LIMITS A CALIFORNIA?
YOU STAY UP WE ON THE THE
REQUESTED.
THANK YOU CRISIS.
WELCOME THAT IS MY NUMBER ONE
MINUTE CATELYN GOING TO MISS A
CALIFORNIA -- SHINGLE APPLE
YOUNG BILL [inaudible]
CRISIS.
WELCOME ONE MUST BE EVER ENOUGH
THAT IF THE NUMBER IS MUDDY SO
TELL YOU THAT ME MANGO THE MUCH
SAVING WHILE I PULL YOU.
UP HERE LEFT ASSIST [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING THREE IN A GUSTY
ANALYSTS US CENTRAL VALLEY OUT
FROM TO LARRY CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT ITEM NUMBER.
TWO THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SAM BUT
ONLY ONE AND I'M FROM FRESNO I
COME BACK.
HI AM WITH YOUR AGE THAT BEHIND
THAT SUPPORT THE BOMB GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
WHEN OF THE ANSWER EVEN GONE
THAT'LL THEY FRESNO ME NOBODY
SAID ON BACKING DAY DON'T IS SO
YEAH BUT A POLICIES ESTO YEP WE
ENDED UP IN A POLICIES YOUNG
LITTLE POINTY SINGLE ME ON A
STUDIES YOU ANALYSIS?
WHAT FOLLOWED THAT AS HIS ASSIST
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
WELL IS THERE A NUMBER OF HIS
OWN YOU GOTTA.
THE BILL UP WITH ANOTHER
PROPOSAL FROM THE MOTHER LIVING
THING COME YOUR NEXT. TO THE
LAST [inaudible]
ACCESS. ONE OF THE ONLY NUMBER A
SECOND AGO.
THE NUMBER OF BINGO FOR YOUNG
DAUGHTER THANK YOU SINGLE ME
HONEST BUT HOLD DOES HIS
POLITICAL MANILA.
GLASSES.
WE WILL OBVIOUSLY ON TOLD ME
MOMENT OF THEM YET BUT ALSO SEE.
EVEN LITTLE SUNLAND CALIFORNIA
YES WE UP WE ON THE MOVING TO
SINGLE ME ON THE OF YOU SO LET
US ALL MáS.
WHICH I DON'T FEEL BASIS.
WHEN DOES THE ASK ME NUMBER IS
BUT THREE SEVEN ESSAY THAT CONDO
THEY YODEL THEY LOOK I'M GOING
TECHIES SAY EVOLVING COUPLE%
YANDLE CERVANTES INCOMING UNISON
HE SAID I MISSED JACK ASKED
ABOUT YOU THAT ON THE SYSTEM YOU
DON'T DISCUSS THEM IN A CASUAL?
YELLOWS THE YES THE SENTINEL
SOME BAD GUYS IS THIS RESTAURANT
THEY IT THEN IT MUST GET THE
MODEL NOT SEALED YES YES.
BASIS THE COMMERCIAL IN THOUGHT
ON THIS WAS THAT WE SHOULD
COLLISON SO MOMENT THE THIS
BOTTOM ON THE NET LEVY NEED OUT
OF MY CLASSES CLASSES.
NO OF THE F. ME NUMBER IN MY TO
YEAH.
MY GOD YEAH ALSO LINGO THEY
FITTED MOP OR YELLOW.
PROPOSES C. ON ABC ARE NOT.
CLASSES PLUS IF.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN NUMBER IS
MEDI OTHER LEGO BUT MORE THAN
LOS ANGELES YOU BEING WHAT FOR
YANDLE?
A LOS VEINTICINCO ME UNITS HAVE
THESE YOU'RE NOT LIST BUT I YOU
THAT.
IRAQ GATE NOISE THAT I CAN THINK
BOY THAT THEY MADE A STOOL THESE
DOT ON GUM FROM LOS ANGELES.
I SUPPORT THE PROPOSED PHONE THE
GOVERNMENT BUT ALSO EIGHTEEN SO
WE NEED MORE MONEY IN THAT.
I SUPPORTED TWENTY BY A MILLION
DOLLAR.
BUT IF WE CAN HAVE MORE.
DOES THAT IT.
THANK YOU -- SO THE RULES ARE WE
CAN'T ALLOW DEMONSTRATIONS LIKE
CLAPPING OR BREWING ANYTHING BUT
IF YOU LIKE SOMETHING YOU CAN DO
THIS.
ALL RIGHT OKAY GOOD ABOUT
PRACTICE OR A GOOD THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI MY NAME THE UNION NAY
NOT TAKEN FROM LOS ANGELES AND I
FLEW FOR THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
ADDITIONAL FORM.
OF FOR THE BUDGET.
OKAY THANK YOU.
FROM STARVATION ROSE ANOTHER
GIRL IN LITTLE STARGAZING OPAL
YAK YOU LIVING SINGLE.
THIS CRISIS. ONE OF THE S. ME
NUMBER IS SINCERELY ON THAT
OTHER A WRANGLE LITTLE SIGNED A
LEASE CALIFORNIA.
OPERATE ON THE ARMY ECONOMY THAT.
IS THERE.
BY UP WE DON'T KNOW -- ILLNESS.
UP FOR YA DO DATA MOST SOME
LOVING SINGLE MADE ME JOHN AS
THEY THE LETTUCE.
BUT MUST OCONEE THAT GASEOUS.
CLASSES.
WHAT ARE THE AS WE KNOW REYES
JESSICA HAVING ON A LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA -- BUT A LOW SPEED
SINGLE BE OF THIS QUESTION
CRISIS.
WHEN OF THE F. ME NUMBER THAT
MANY SAID NUMBER THEY GO AHEAD
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE FAME OF
THE MUNICIPAL YOU GO TO RENT A
SINGLE YEAH [inaudible]
CLASSES. ONE OF THE YES MEN
NUMBERS OF FOUR LMA BINGO THEM
AT A FAIR.
WE ARE FOR YOUR BEEN DISSING
GOING ON MY BUT I FIFTH.
GET EXPRESS THIS.
PLEASE SOMETIME O'DONNELL
WRANGLING MEDICINE THE UP WE ARE
MOVING TO SINGLE YANIS.
PRESIDENT YES.
WHEN I WAS THE AS MY NUMBER IS
THAT THE VOTERS HAVING NAME OF
THE FRESNO IT IN THE MOST?
A BOY AND THE BUT A LINK TO
SINGLE ME O THIS MATHIS VERSUS.
WHEN I STARTED THIS SETTLES
WHO'S DAVIS HE TOLD ME MANY WILL
SUBMIT I WILL STILL GET TO A LOT
MORE DOES THAT ALSO COMES WITH A
MOTOR PERCENT DOWN ON US THE
COMPANY THAT?
IS THAT THEFORWARDED THOUGHT AS
HE DOES HE ONLY.
GET A MOST KIDS DAY THIS GET THE
AN INSULT SCHOOL THAT AT THIS IS
MY NOTHING A THAT'LL ADD NINOS.
ANCIEN KNOWLES IS WAY LESS TO
MAKE IT OUT THAT YOUR COMMITTEE
THAT I'M NOT MAYES SAY IT TOO
THATI NAY IS IT BY EASE WORK IN
ALBANY AND I'VE EITHER PUT THAT
IS GOING TO BE IN AN ELEMENT
THAT THAT IS.
COMMUNITY AND THEN WE ALSO
YOU'LL GET OKAY ALL THOSE THING
AMENABLE DAY I KEEL BINGLE BUT
GETS HE SAID BOY THE AS THE
ESCAPE WOULD ADDRESSES BUT AS WE
TRY TO MAY BRING UP WE ARE.
BUT WE DO THINK OF ME ON THIS
EXTRA ANONYMIZING CUENTA I AM
WOULD YOU THE MIDDLE.
AND A LAWYER AND ALL I SEE IS K.
I. K. I. K. APPELLEE TEMPLE IS
AGAIN ON THEY KNOWN ALSO BUT BUT
NO BUT I MEET.
BUT INFO DOT AWAY AS IT OR NOT
BUT ONE OF MY YOU KNOW THEY THAT.
THIS IT BENT THAT WHICH IT BY
YOU'LL SEE WILLIAM AS HE THAT IS
THAT WE JUST CANNOT KEEP THE
YOU'LL THINK IT THIS WAY THEY
ARE RADICAL NAY AND AND
PRESIDENT THEY MIRRORS BUT THOSE
OPPOSED SAY THIS.
YOU GET HIS BUT AS WHICH HAD A
METAL
GUYS HERE THINK.
****.
ALRIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON -- IT IS
KIND OF ASKS WILL BE HALF OF THE
IT OCCASIONALLY TO FOUNDATION
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO INCREASE --
SERVICES FOR IMMIGRANTS SPECIAL
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY ALSO TO
THE TEAM AT CVS AS WITH THAT
INCREDIBLE JOB ASSISTING -- THAT
WORKS IN CENTRAL INCREASE MARKET
BASKET FRESNO AS WELL NOT
SUPPORT.
THANKS THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
I'M A BERMAN PAR IS AN ICON
FRESNO.
I CAME HERE TO SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING EVERYONE A SAID
HONEY FROM IMMIGRATION
DEPARTMENT OF INTERNATIONAL
RESCUE COMMITTEE HIGH RC A
WORKING WITH THOUSANDS OF
EMIGRANTS EVE EVERY YEAR -- THAT
GIVES US THE ABILITY TO ASSESS
AND DETERMINE THE NEEDS FOR
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES AND
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
FUNDING AND I REALLY APPRECIATED
THANKS.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS A SOME
OF THEM -- WITH THE COUNCIL ON
AMERICAN ISLAMIC RELATIONS
CALIFORNIA -- WE HAVE AN
ORGANIZATION -- I'D LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE THE CRUCIAL.
START I LIKE THEM SAID THE
CRUCIAL IMPORTANCE OF ITEM --
ONE AND SUPPORT -- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
ARE NAY BAYARDO AS HERE YOU
CALIFORNIA OBVIOUSLY THIS ISSUE
IS IMPORTANT TO OUR MEMBERS
BECAUSE THEY LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND THEY SEE THE NEED.
AND I AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS OF
THE WOMAN EARLIER SAID MORE IS
ALWAYS BETTER SO WE WOULD ASK
FOR A LITTLE MARK THANK.
QUE THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI I'M LUCAS AND I'M
THIS I'M FROM PERRIN VOICES
FRESNO AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT.
THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR OUR
OUR IMMIGRANTS IN FRESNO THANK
YOU.
WELCOME MY NAME IS LOTUS A LOCK
ON I'M NOT GOING FROM SAN
FRANCISCO ALMOST ALL OF THEM A
MEMBER OF BY AMBUSHES SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THESE
LOW ESPECIALLY FOR THE CHILDREN
I WENT TO REGISTER MY SIGN AT
THE SAN FRANCISCO IF OTHERS
COULD DEFEAT YESTERDAY AND I'VE
LEARNED THAT.
THERE'S A LOT OF CHILDREN IN THE
LEGAL THERE'S THERE WAITING IN
COURTS AND SO THEY CANNOT
ATTENDED SCHOOL WHILE THEY'RE
WAITING FOR THEM TO BE APPROVED
SO PLEASE -- PUT THESE FUNDING
IN THE RIGHT PLACE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WELCOME ONE OF THE ES ME NUMBER
IS SORT OF SILLY BECAUSE THE I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF THAT.
THEY LET YOU IS SAID THE WITH
THE DO OVER THE EVEN LOVE FOR
YOUNG LITTLE THING TO SINGLE ME
ON THIS PART OF THE CIRCLE IN
THE A PASSES ASSISTS.
WHEN IS THE AS MY NUMBER IS BUT
ON A GLOBAL NASTY BUT THIS GUY
YOU IS THE RESULT OF YOU?
ECO MODA SIPPING THAT THE MINUTE
THEY PAY SAY BILLION IS TO SEE
THAT GUY IN A COMPANY THAT HE
SAID BUT MYSELF OKAY WHEN A
COMPANY THAT YOU FOR MY THAT IS
SO NOT ONLY THAT BUT IT EITHER
[inaudible]
THIS IS.
WHEN ALL THE ARMY NUMBER IS
DOING ALL SHE WELL WELL SO THE
CASE SACRAMENTO?
A MAN LE LET YOU IS THAT THE THE
VIEW SO YOU MISS I THINK WITH
EVA EVEN WOEFULLY UNDERLAY BUT A
CAPACITOR.
REQUEST THAT THAT BE THOUGH THEY
MEET US YOU ABOUT THE NAY ONE
OFF I MEAN ONLY THE ASSEMBLY AND
ASKING.
QUESTIONS.
A GOOD MORNING MY NAY CITED
FLORES I AM A MEMBER OF THE SCA
US I IN A STRONG SUPPORT A
PROPOSED NUMBER.
ONE AND THE TWENTY FIVE METERS
DAUGHTERS.
IN MY CASE THANKS TO THESE
BROUGHT ON A COOL GET HOPE TO
FILL OUT MY FOR FOR FREE BECOME
CITY CENTRAL CALIFORNIA REWARD
SERVICE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MY CAR
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY WE ALSO STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS AUGMENTATION FOR
FAMILY IMMIGRATION SERVICES.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS A LET ME AND THE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS DIRECTING
ATTORNEY AT CENTER LIKE THAT THE
LHASA WE'RE THE LARGEST PROVIDER
OF DETAINED AND NON DETAINED
REMOVAL DEFENSE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE STAND IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT --
OF THE OF THE FUNDING THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND ALSO FOR
MARCEL AND HER TEAM TO GET THE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THEY NEED
TO CONTINUE TO ADMINISTER THIS
PROGRAM SO EFFECTIVELY.
I DO WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU HOW
MUCH OF AN IMPACT THIS HAS HAD
ON OUR COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE
NOT ONLY TO PROVIDE SUCH A
HIGHER VOLUME OF LEGAL SERVICES.
BUT ALSO TO BE ABLE TO SAY THAT
THIS IS BEING PAID FOR BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO VALUES
ARE COMMUNITIES AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEY ACTUALLY HAVE ACCESS
TO LEGAL SERVICES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS THE
BUT THAT IS GOT SEE I AM WITH
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS
FOUNDATION OF PARTICULAR CENTRAL
VALLEY AND I'M SUPPORT OR IN
SUPPORT OF THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARY GLACIERS IN
THE STATE RIGHT ORGANIZER FOR
PAM VOICES CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF
OF THE REST OF OUR CHAPTERS WE
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
AT THE HEART OF THIS IT'S ABOUT
KEEPING FAMILIES TOGETHER AND
THAT IS WHAT WE'RE ABOUT.
AND WE WANT HISTORY TO SHOW THAT.
TO THESE CHILDREN IN THESE
FAMILIES THAT WHEN THERE WAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE ACTION IN
SUPPORT WE DID SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
DO NOT A HALL OF THE KING ONLINE.
I'M IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M SALLY KENOSHA
FROM THE IMMIGRANT LEGAL
RESOURCE CENTER WE ARE A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
EXISTED FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS
TO BUILD THE CAPACITY OF
IMMIGRATION SERVICES -- I COME
ON BEHALF OF MY ORGANIZATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AND SUPPORT FOR CSS -- WE SEE
THIS IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT IN
REALLY BUILDING THE CAPACITY IN
OUR STATE TO PROTECT IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
KEVIN IS THE COLDEST CALIFORNIA
WELL FOR ITS ORGANIZATIONS FOR
OF ALL ITEMS THINKING THANK YOU.
GIVING GO THERE MAYOR SANDY SO
YOU'RE ON THAT THE RENEWAL
YOU'VE BEEN WHAT PUT DOWN THE
LIBERTY TO GO BE HONEST BUT I
DAHLE UP WIH BUT THEY LIVE NOT
PULLING UP WHEN THEY DIE THEY
NEEDED ON DAY EACH DAY A MONTH.
US BUT I CAN YOU AND I CAN THINK
MRS HE THOUGHT.
YOU PUT ASSIST BY APPEALING TO
ADDRESS YES [inaudible]
AXIS.
OKAY THANK YOU SO WELL WE WILL
HOLD OPEN ITEMS ONE TWO AND
THREE I THINK THOSE ARE ACTUALLY
THE ITEMS SO WE'RE NOW WE'RE
GONNA DO IS WE ACTUALLY HAVE
FIRST OF ALL WE HAVE A PROPOSAL
FOR INVESTMENTS FOR IMMIGRATION
RELIEF SERVICES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA REGAINED JUSTICE
FELLOWSHIP AND THEN.
WE ALSO HAVE TO ADDITIONAL --
SIR MISCELLANEOUS PROPOSAL
INVESTMENTS WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS GOING TO HEAR.
ALL THREE AND TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE END OF THE THAT
THOSE THREE SO FIRST LET'S BRING
UP THE A CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP.
PROGRAM AND WE HAVE JACQUI
GONZALEZ POLICY DIRECTOR.
FROM THE JUSTICE IN DIVERSITY
CENTER THE BAR ASSOCIATION SAN
FRANCISCO [inaudible]
WELCOME.
AND ASK IF YOU CAN. THREE
MINUTES -- AND W..
WE HAVE QUESTIONS WILL GIVE YOU
EVEN MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO
EXPOUND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I'M MY NAME IS JACKIE
GONZALEZ AND THEN THE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE FOR IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE.
THE COLLABORATIVE IS A NETWORK
OF LEGAL SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS FOCUS ON
PROVIDING RAPID RESPONSE AND
LEGAL REPRESENTATION FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
AND AS YOU KNOW WE'VE HEARD THIS
MORNING CALIFORNIA STANDS ON THE
FRONT LINES OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S WAR ON
IMMIGRANTS.
WERE HOME TO THE MOST ACTIVE
BORDER CROSSING IN THE WORLD AND
HOME TO MORE IMMIGRANTS THAN ANY
OTHER STATE IN OUR COUNTRY.
AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
WORD TODAY FOR THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS OUR HOME.
IMMIGRANTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
NOT WITHSTANDING ARE VULNERABLE
TO ARBITRARY ARRESTS INHUMANE
DETENTION AND DEPORTATION
WITHOUT DUE PROCESS.
IMMIGRATION IS ONE OF THE MOST
COMPLEX AND INVOLVING AREAS OF
LAW BUT THOSE FACING DEPORTATION
ARE NOT GUARANTEED ACCESS TO
COUNSEL EVEN THOUGH THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR CASES CAN
BE YEARS IN DETENTION FAMILY
SEPARATION AND ULTIMATELY EXILE
FROM THIS COUNTRY.
AND AS WE'VE HEARD EARLIER TODAY
THE NEED FOR LEGAL SERVICES
INFRASTRUCTURE IS MOST URGENT IN
THE RURAL REGIONS OF OUR STATE.
THESE PLACES INCLUDE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND THE CENTRAL COAST
THESE AREAS ARE ALSO HOME TO THE
HIGHEST CONCENTRATION OF
VULNERABLE IMMIGRANTS AND SOME
OF THE MOST AGGRESSIVE
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS BY ICE.
DEFEND OUR COMMUNITIES WE MUST
RECOGNIZE THAT THE IMMIGRATION
COURT ROOMS IN OUR STATE WERE
TODAY SO MANY OF OUR RESIDENTS
STAND ALONE ARE ACTUALLY THE
FRONT LINES OF THIS BATTLE.
AND AS WE'VE HEARD AND I'M HERE
TO ALSO STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT
THE STATE HAS MADE A REMARKABLE
INVESTMENT IN LEGAL SERVICES
HOWEVER.
ONLY 20% OF THE FUNDING THAT THE
STATE HAS PROVIDED HAS GONE TO
REMOVAL DEFENSE SERVICES.
AND THOSE DOLLARS HAVE HONESTLY
BEEN LIMITED TO URBAN AREAS
WHERE THERE ARE STILL
ORGANIZATIONS WITH THE EXPERTISE
TO ACTUALLY MAKE RESPONSIBLE USE
OF THESE FUNDS.
CRITICAL SUPPORT FOR THESE
SERVICES IS JUST SIMPLY NOT
REACHING CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS IN
REMOTE AND RURAL REGIONS OF OUR
STATE.
AND THT WILL CONTINUE TO BE THE
CASE UNLESS WE MAKE AN
INVESTMENT TO GROW CAPACITY. TO
YOUR EARLIER POINT MISTER CHAIR --
ON THE SPECIFIC ISSUES AND AS
YOU KNOW -- BETTER THAN ME HOW
ABOUT THAT THE API COMMUNITY --
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS ALSO HOME
TO A VERY HIGH PERCENTAGE OF
THIS COMMUNITY SO THIS IS A
PROPOSAL FOR CAPACITY BUILDING
ON THIS ON THE ISSUE THAT YOU
WERE.
ASKING EARLIER -- SO THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
FELLOWSHIP IS A ONE TIME FOUR
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR ASKED
TO SUPPORT A PILOT PROGRAM.
IT WOULD DO SEVERAL THINGS FIRST
PROVIDE THE FIRST STATE
SPONSORED LEGAL FELLOWSHIP
TRAINING PROGRAM TO INCREASE FOR
MOBILE DEFENSE SERVICES FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS SECOND.
IT WOULD INCREASE WORKFORCE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LAW STUDENTS
AND YOUNG ATTORNEYS THAT WANT
NOTHING MORE THAN TO RETURN HOME
TO THESE AREAS OF HIGH NEED BUT
REALLY HAVE NO VIABLE OPTIONS
FOR DOING SO.
AND FINALLY IT WILL EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF REPUTABLE LEGAL
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS ELIGIBLE
TO PROVIDE THESE CRITICAL
SERVICES OUR STATE.
AND WHILE THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
BEGIN AS A PILOT IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THE SF
IMMIGRATION COURT.
IT'S NOTEWORTHY THAT THE
JURISDICTION OF THE COURT
EXTENDS AS FAR NORTH AS OREGON
BORDER AND AS FAR SOUTH AS
BAKERSFIELD.
SO THIS PROPOSAL -- WHAT THE
EXPERTISE RICHARD IT'S OUT OF
THE BAY BUT THE JURY GEOGRAPHIC
EXPANSE IT COVERS IS REALLY JUST
PHENOMENAL?
I'M A RECENT DATASTUDY LED BY
THE SAN FRANCISCO BARS SO SHOULD
ASSOCIATIONS JUSTICE AND
DIVERSITY CENTER FOUND THAT OF
THE DETAINED.
ON REPRESENTED INDIVIDUALS
SERVED 20% WERE ACTUALLY
RECENTLY ARRIVED ASYLUM SEEKERS
IN SAN FRANCISCO COURT OVER 25%
WORK RESIDENTS OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
SO -- ULTIMATELY AT AND
INVESTMENT IN THIS PILOT WILL
REALLY BE AN INVESTMENT FOR
SERVICES FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS STATEWIDE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM FROM SOCIAL SERVICES ABOUT
THIS.
HELLO JUST NOTE THAT IS
REFLECTED IN THE TARGET
INVESTMENTS THAT DEPARTMENT HAS
MADE WE RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
THE EXPANSION OF LEGAL SERVICES
AND AND ROLE IN AN WHEN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT --
ESPECIALLY FOR MORE COMPLEX
LEGAL REPRESENTATION.
THANK YOU COMMENTS FROM ILIO
FINANCE I KNOW IT'S NOT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
I KNOW THAT THE CAT.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT --
QUESTIONS OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
A CERTAIN A THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- I WANT TO THANK JACQUI
GONZALEZ FOR A PROVIDING YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY -- YOU KNOW
AS YOU KNOW I'M FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND THERE IS A LOT OF
NEED -- AND PEOPLE ARE LIVING IN
FEAR I JUST LAST YEAR WE HAD A
FAMILY THAT -- WAS ESCAPING.
AT ICE AND IN THE PROCESS THEY
GOT INTO A CAR ACCIDENT THAT.
TURNED OUT TO BE FATAL AND THE
WORD.
JUST IN FEAR OF BEING -- IN A
BEING REMOVED FROM THIS FROM
THIS COUNTRY AND YOU KNOW BEING
SEPARATED FROM THEIR FAMILIES
AND SO THERE IS A NEED IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY -- AND AND INLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS THIS
BUDGET ITEM AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY AND THANK YOU TO ALL THE
FAMILIES HERE FROM.
THAT ARE HERE FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND BEYOND -- FOR COMING
UP AND STANDING UP MUCH OF THE
REST YES A CYCLE THIS MORNING AS
A SEA BATTLE YOU'LL SORT OF I
GUESS AND FRIDAY LESS YOU THAT
THE SINK.
ALONG A POSSIBLE IS THERE IS
DOUBLE ENOUGH AMELIA DAY LESS
YOU THAT THE NOMINAL.
KIT A STOP IS TO GIVE UP BOARD --
ICE E. N. S. IN A SMALL MENTAL
LOOK AT BY SOLIS GAY -- THE BILL
NEXT INTO THE CAPITAL AND ON
INNOCENT DOES NOT NOT YOUNG
COMMITTEE ON THE LONG PRETTY MAN.
BATTLE ESTE ES A SOB -- LOOK AT
IN A SET UP AS A SO FIVE MILLION
OKAY ANY SO THE STEP BY EASE.
AND AND PROCESS ALL ENOUGH FOR
ME AND DATA SAID.
ASSIST.
SAID.
KENNETH STARR AND ON THIS LINE
IS A SEE THAT BUT I I WILL
GOGGLES AND ADVICE IN DALLAS
MARINA SAYS HE DATA.
ES DE E. MISSPELLED OR THE
COURSES BUT UP ALL THAT.
OTHER PERSON THAT ASSISTED ME
YES KATE KATE CAN ON THE SAYS HE
PANEL MáS BUCKET.
IT IS LOOKING MONTH IN ANNISTON
ACOSTA KONAMI AND A SOURCE FROM
OUR WHOLE SEE -- NOT IN MEDICINE
STEPS UP BUT I'LL SO YOUR FOR
YOUR STOP PROPOSTA HE WILL
DISCUSSES PURSUE SUPPORT FOR
MANY TO KEEP [inaudible]
ASSIST.
THANK YOU SENATOR D'AMATO. EIGHT
I THINK THAT -- THE QUESTION I
HAD ABOUT AND HOPEFULLY IS OVER --
MOVING TOWARD ME VERY VISOR
COULD BE SOME CONVERSATIONS I AM.
AS OFFER SO I WANT TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR HIS -- PROPOSAL AND
INVESTMENTS IN IN THIS AREA AS I
MENTIONED THAT.
EVEN BEFORE SEPT MAJOR I WAS
HERE -- ADVOCATING FOR THIS
AFTER RESOURCE SO I THINK
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES FOR
WHAT YOU'VE DONE SO FAR AND AND
BUT I I ALSO THINK THAT -- BEEN
THAT'S WHAT THOSE QUESTIONS
ABOUT NOW THAT IT'S A CERTAIN
POINT IF WE FINANCIALLY AND
SOMEONE SAID WHAT WE NEED MORE
MONEY AND I KNOW EVERYONE WANTS
NEEDS MORE -- BUT ALSO THE SURE
THAT -- IS IS WERE MOVING
RESOURCES WE HAVE TO ALSO BUILD
THE CAPACITY RIGHT AND AND THAT.
CAPACITY BUILDING THAT ALLOWS --
DOLLY HOUSES THE STATE BUT
OTHERS ALSO THEN.
BE ABLE TO HELP SO -- AND A
PARTICULARLY WORRIED ABOUT --
RURAL COMMUNITIES RIGHT -- BUT
IT'S DO USUALLY URBAN COMMUNES
ARE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE THAT
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE TRYS SO
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
BUILD THAT OUT HOPEFULLY WE CAN
HAVE SOME CONVERSATIONS ABOUT.
THAT THE CURRENT INVESTMENTS
WHETHER DOES SOME AUGMENTATION
AND AGAIN PARTICULARLY AND IN
THE VALLEY -- WOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT WHAT AT LIKE TO SEE SO I
APPRECIATE THAT THE PRESENTATION
THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH AN INCREASE
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
WORK OF THE DEPARTMENT.
SO WE DO HAVE TWO OTHER
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT THAT
ARE THEY DON'T THERE'S CUTS IN
THE HEAD OUR RELATED BUT NOT
NECESSARILY.
SPECIFIC TO THIS PARTICULAR --
THAT'D IMMIGRATION SERVICES BUT
WILL HEAR THEM NOW AS THE FIRST
WE HAVE THE YOUTH AND FAMILY
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE.
AND WE HAVE -- HEY WE HAVE ALL
THIS WE HAVE THE WORST WATER
HERE IT'S GONNA BE PRESENTING AS
WELL AS SWEET.
IS CHARLES YES SEE ALL MY HOPE
AND MISPRONOUNCE THAT -- AND
THEN OKAY FREEDOM CENTER.
WELL WE ARE TRULY HONORED TODAY.
THANK YOU.
I KNOW THAT -- WAS VERY.
THRILLED THAT -- THIS WATER WAS
RECOGNIZED AT TODAY EARLIER ON
THE SENATE FLOOR SO -- THANK YOU
FOR BEING THERE AND AGAIN THANK
YOU AND WELCOME TO OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING THANK YOU.
RAJ.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH SHERMAN.
YES THE ON THE LEGISLATURE TO
AND WITH THE DOORS WITH THE
FOUNDATION FOR GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZING AND THAT THIS
INITIATIVE OF FOR THE CHAPLAIN
THEM OKAY.
AND THE OF ONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE HELP WITH THIS WITH
THE PREPARATION THE PAST YEAR.
AND WE'RE HERE TODAY AGAIN TO OF
ASK ACTUALLY IT'S NOT ONLY FOR
THE APPROPRIATION WOULD ALSO
INCLUDE THE X. BUT X. DOUBLE
THAT -- BECAUSE WE BASICALLY
WHAT WE WANT TO EXPAND THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING AND TO OTHER
AREAS WERE -- YOU GUYS ARE YOUNG
PEOPLE A REALLY DEPRIVED OF MANY
OPPORTUNITIES -- LOVE ONLY
RECREATIONAL BUT THE
DEVELOPMENTAL AND LEADERSHIP AND
AND GO TO TRY TO CAN OVERCOME A
LOT OF DISCRIMINATION THAT
EXISTS IN SOME OF THESE
COMMUNITIES.
THE SULTAN OF OVER TWO EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CUT UP KAMALA CHALLENGE.
MORNING MR CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS COMEY LET
TRAVIS I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE THE LOTUS WORTH
THE FOUNDATION AND I'M JOINED BY
MY COLLEAGUE DR KERN BULKY
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
WITH THE MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR FREEDOM CENTER.
TOGETHER ARE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS SERVE OPPORTUNITY
USE FROM VULNERABLE HI POVERTY
URBAN AND RURAL COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE THANK THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR SUPPORTING THE
STATEWIDE LAUNCH OF THE YOUTH
AND FAMILY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT LAST
YEAR WHICH SERVED KERN COUNTY
FRESNO ALAMEDA AND CONTRA COSTA.
THF AN M. OKAY HAVE COMBINED
THIRTY YEARS OF YOUTH
PROGRAMMING WHICH WE ARE
ENHANCING THROUGH EVIDENCE BASED
CURRICULUM AND HANDS ON CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT PROJECTS.
LESS THAN ONE YEAR WE HAVE
EXCEEDED OUR GOALS REACHING MORE
THAN FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS FROM SAN DIEGO TO
SACRAMENTO AT CONFERENCES
CLASSES AND EVENTS.
WE HAVE DONE THIS THROUGH THE
WORK OF TWO HUNDRED AND THREE
STUDENT LEADERS WHO WERE
SELECTED AMONG MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED NOMINATIONS BY TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS.
USE LEADERS AT TEN FORTY
ATTENDED FORTY THREE SATURDAY
CLASSES TWENTY NINE EVENING
CLASSES AND SIXTY SEVEN A FULL
DAY CLASSES TO PREPARE FOR THE
TRAININGS THAT THEY IN TURN
PROVIDED TO TENS AND THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR.
A COUPLE OF THE HIGHLIGHTS
INCLUDE A SIX WEEKS EVER SINCE
THE SUMMER CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
TOWARD AND WHICH OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS LEADERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
TRAVEL TO SEVENTEEN CITIES TOWNS
AND TRIBES.
MAY ORAL AND CONGRESSIONAL
CANDIDATE FORMS WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS AND OTHERS LAST
NOVEMBER USE LEADERS ORGANIZED
EVENTS AND ASK QUESTIONS OF THE
CANDIDATES.
OVER A HUNDRED USED IN THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS PARTICIPATED IN A
WEEK LIFE LONG LONG LIFE AND
LEGACY TRAINING DURING THE
WINTER BREAK WHICH PROVIDED AN
IN DEPTH STUDY OF DR KING'S WORK
AND WRITINGS.
THF AND ENGAGED USE.
TREE PLANTING AND COMMUNITY
CLEANUP EVENTS AND KERN WHAT
THEIR ELECTED OFFICIALS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUDY SALAS AND
CONGRESSMAN TJ ****.
THE USE PROVIDED EVENT REPORTS.
PROVIDED EVENT SUPPORT MARCHED
AND SPOKE AT MULTIPLE WOMEN'S
MARCHES EVENTS ON JANUARY
NNETEENTH WITH MORE THAN FORTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN ATTENDANCE.
USE LEADERS KEYNOTED YMCAS
CONFERENCE ON USING GOVERNMENT
TO FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS.
USE LEADERS PRESENTED A WORKSHOP
ON HEALING AN EXPRESSION AT THE
DH HAVE SPONSORED LGBT Q. U.
SUMMIT AND BAKER SPILLED OVER
FORTY USER TRAIN TO ENGAGE IN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT BUDGETING
PROCESS THROUGH THE LOCAL
CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN.
IN JUST A FEW WEEKS THEY WILL
PROVIDE FORMAL RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THEIR RESPECTIVE SCHOOL
BOARDS AT EL CAP INPUT SESSIONS
IN KERN TULARE AND FRESNO
COUNTIES.
THESE COLLECTIVE EXPERIENCES ARE
PREPARING CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH TO
BECOME THE NEXT GENERATION OF
INCLUSIVE AND ETHICAL LEADERS.
OKAY I'LL TRY AND GET THIS
WRAPPED UP OKAY THE FUNDING FROM-SO DO TO EXPAND THE PROGRAM ARE
REQUESTING FOR MILLION
APPROPRIATION FOR THE NEXT THREE
YEARS.
A ONE TIME TWELVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT WHICH WOULD ACHIEVE
EXPANSION TO TWELVE COUNTIES.
SUSTAINABILITY AND STAFF
TRAINING REGIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE
AND CAPACITY CULTIVATION OF
YOUTH LEADERS WHICH WOULD BE
REACH SIX HUNDRED IN YEARS TWO
AND THREE PARTICIPATION OF
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
AND A MINIMUM OF THREE JOINT
STATEWIDE PROJECTS SENSES THE
CENSUS.
I WILL -- PASS IT TO ME OKAY.
JUST TO BE BRIEF -- THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK -- THIS MORNING JUST TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS INITIATIVE
IS TAILORED AFTER PROJECT IN THE
STATE OF WASHINGTON THAT HAS HAD
AN EIGHTEEN YEAR.
APPROPRIATION -- IN TRIBAL URBAN
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES.
IT HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND THE CURRICULUM
REALLY INTEGRATES VALUES THE
VALUES THAT ARE COMMON TO ALL OF
OUR CULTURES AND OUR PEOPLES AND
ASKS US HOW TO ALIGN OUR CONTACT.
WITH OUR CORE BELIEFS AND VALUES
BECAUSE THAT IS ALL THAT IS HOW
WE ALL LIVE TO BE THE MEN AND
WOMEN THAT WERE CAPABLE OF BEING.
THE VERY STRONG COACHING MODEL
SO IT REALLY ALTERS THE SPACE
THAT EXISTS BETWEEN THE STUDENTS
AS WE HELP ONE ANOTHER TO REALLY
TRANSFORM AND ENGAGE IN OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY PROBLEM SOLVING
INITIATIVES.
AND JUST TO LET YOU KNOW WE WILL
BE LEAVING YOU A COPY OF A
RESEARCH STUDY THAT WENT BACK
FIFTEEN YEARS AND TRACE THE
OUTCOMES OF THE WORK. 100% HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION RATES 80%
COLLEGE DEGREE CONFERRAL RATES
AS WELL AS A COPY OF OUR
CURRICULUM FOR YOUR USE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM ALEJO.
FINANCE ALL RIGHT -- QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALRIGHT SO -- NIGHT AND WHAT
THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION -- INTO IT SO AND I
KNOW YOU TOUCHED ON SOME OF THE
OUTCOMES AND REALLY APPRECIATE
THE SORT OF TAKEN ORGANIZING
COMMUNITY BUILDING ACTIVITIES
THAT YOU'RE DOING.
CAN YOU JUST PERHAPS SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT -- TOO SO.
THERE'S JUST SOME SOME WAYS --
SPOKE ABOUT THERE'S MEDIA RIGHT
A DIFFERENT LAYERS PROGRAMS YOU
SAID AND SO YOU HAVE SOME PM
WELL THIS IS A GIFT VERY STUFF
THAT THAT THE YOU THAT YOUR
TRAINING RATES ARE NOW GOING ON
TRAINING OTHERS CORRECT SO I
MEAN TEMS A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO ACTUALLY -- TOUCHED CAN YOU
JUST SPEAK.
TO THAT RIGHT BECAUSE SOMETIMES
HE'LL SAY SAY WELL LOOK YOU KNOW
WE YOU GOT WHAT.
SORRY AT FOUR HUNDRED YOU THAT
SOMETHING BUT THAT'S ONLY FOUR
HUNDRED SO HOW WOULD THAT THAT
FOUR HUNDRED BECOMES.
SO HE JUST BECAUSE THAT RIGHT
AND SO JUST AND THE FIRST YEAR
OF FUNDING WE REACHED FORTY
SEVEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ADD
TO A VERY IS -- EVENS
CONFERENCES THE TRAININGS THAT
THE YOUTH THEMSELVES HAVE
PROVIDED AND SO IS HAVING A
RIPPLE EFFECT AND WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL FOR
THE EXPANSION AND WHAT THAT WILL
LEAD WITH INCREASED FUNDING.
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
AND I DO WANT TO ADD THAT WE ARE.
PLANNING TO DO A LOT OF WORK ON
THE CENSUS AND A LOT OF THE
TRAINING THAT WE DO IS HANDS ON
US FOR THAT THAT IS NOT THIS
TALKING ABOUT IT BUT THE THE
ACTUALLY CAN BE LEARNING AND
LIKE THE THE A LOT OF WORK ON
PLANTING TREES AND YOU.
KNOW JUST A GOING.
RIGHT NOW THE ADVOCATING FOR MY
WITH IT BUT WITH THE KING OF THE
PUBLIC.
SUPPORT OF A HOLIDAY IN BECAUSE
FOR CALIFORNIA WE STILL DON'T
HAVE HARD TO BELIEVE US SO THESE
AGGRESSIVE WITH ENGAGEMENT -- IT
THINGS THAT THEY'RE WORKING ON
AND THEY WILL BE VERY INVOLVED
IN THE CENSUS AND GET OUT
INFORMATION BUT ALSO GOING
DURING THE CANVASSING GOING DOOR
TO DOOR.
A TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE AWARE
OF THE SENSES AND HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS FOR THEM TO GET BECAUSE WE
HAVE A LARGE CONTINGENT OF THE
YOUTH -- HERE WHAT THIS IS.
THE LAND OF BUTTER THE DOLLAR.
AND JUST TO CLARIFY THE COHORT
YOU WHO ARE TRAINED AS THE
FACILITATOR US AND LEADERS WILL
BE REPRESENTATIVE OF THE TWELVE
COUNTIES THAT'S MENTIONED.
IN YOUR PAPERWORK BUT THEY IN
TURN WILL BE SPEAKING AT
CONFERENCES AND PRESENTING AT
SCHOOLS STATEWIDE SO WE WILL
HAVE A STATE WIDE TRAJECTORY
WITH STUDENTS OF MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND HIGH SCHOOL AGES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IN THIS NEXT THREE
YEARS.
CLASSIC ALL RIGHT SOUNDS
FABULOUS.
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH THANK
YOU THANK YOU -- SO WE ARE GOING
TO HEAR THE WE HAVE ONE MORE
PROPOSED YOU CAN STAND IN LINE
WE HAVE ONE MORE PROPOSAL
INVESTMENT IN WE'RE GONNA HEAR
ASK -- FOR COMMENTS ON THE THREE
OF THEM YOU COULD SAY WHICH ONES --
INCLUDE THAT THAT YOU WANT SPEAK
ON SO.
NEXT UP THANK YOU AGAIN -- SORT
OF FOR BEING HERE AND SPEAING
HERE THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH.
OKAY FINALLY WE HAVE A SUPPLY
BANK DOT ORG.
AND WE HAVE SPEAKING HERE --
BENITO DELGADO OLSON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR.
WELCOME [inaudible]
EVANS. TO ASK THAT THE WE HAVE
THE USUAL THREE MINUTE.
OKAY BEGINNER STATEMENT -- SIZE
SCREEN.
OF WHAT.
THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON PAN AND
PROSPECTIVE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND ALSO STAFF AND
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
DEPARTMENTS FOR ALL OF YOUR TIME
LEADING UP TO TODAY -- I'M HERE
TO ASK YOUR CONSIDERATION IN
SUPPORT OF SOMETHING THAT I
BELIEVE OVER TIME WILL HELP
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS IN
POVERTY.
AND HELP BOOST THE WORK OF TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WE WORK
WITH THROUGH OUR FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY PARTNERING AGENCIES AROUND
THE STATE. TO PROVIDE DIRECT --
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE AND PATHWAYS
OUT OF POVERTY -- THROUGH THEIR
OWN AGENCIES.
MY NAME IS BENITO DELGADO OLSON
AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF SUPPLY BANK DOT ORG WHICH
SIMPLISTICALLY IS SIMILAR TO
WHAT YOU WOULD THINK OF IS A
REGIONAL FOOD BANK BUT FOR
EVERYTHING THAT IS NOT.
FOOD -- SOME HISTORY MIGHT BE
HELPFUL IN TERMS OF CONTEXT IN
UNDERSTANDING OUR CONCEPT FOR
THOSE OF YOU.
WHO HAVEN'T HEARD IT BEFORE?
PRIOR TO THE FOUNDING OF THE
FIRST MODERN FOOD BANK IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN THE SAME
WAY MANY OF US THINK OF CO TRIES
AND BACKPACK DRIES AND DIAPER
DRIES AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
WAS SIMILAR TO HOW HUNGER WAS
ADDRESSED THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES.
IS QUOTE UNQUOTE REDISCOVERED AT
THAT TIME NGUYEN ENDED WHEN A
GENTLEMAN IN PHOENIX ARIZONA
FOUNDED WHAT YOU WOULD CONSIDER
TO BE THE FIRST MODERN FOOD BANK
WITH THE CENTRAL HUB OF PLACE TO
CONCENTRATE RESOURCES IN KIND
GIVING.
AND PROCUREMENT TO GENERATE
TREMENDOUS ECONOMIES OF SCALE
AND HELP.
A LOT MORE PEOPLE FOR THE SAME
INVESTMENT.
WE'VE BEEN BUILDING AND
FOLLOWING THAT SAME MODEL FOR
THE PAST TEN YEARS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY AGENCIES IN EVERY COUNTY
IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT INCLUDE WICK FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTERS COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION SCHOOL DISTRICTS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTERS EVEN
FOOD BANKS -- AND MANY MANY
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS MOST
RECENTLY -- Là COOPERATIVE A
COMPASS CENA AND THEIR MEMBER
AGENCIES AND MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
BY PROVIDING THEM WITH MATERIALS
THAT THEIR CLIENTS DESPERATELY
NEED AND IN ALL LIKELIHOOD WOULD
OTHERWISE GO WITHOUT BUT BY
PROVIDING THEM THROUGH THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ALREADY FUNDED
PROVIDE DIRECT PATHWAYS OUT OF
POVERTY. TWO YEARS AGO WE
CONCLUDED OF A PRETTY LENGTHY
STUDY PROCESS WITH LEADERS IN
PHILANTHROPY COUNTY SOCIAL
SERVICE AGENCIES.
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS SOCIAL
WORKERS CAO WORKS FOCUS GROUPS
AND OTHER PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
FOCUS GROUPS IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES.
WITH A NUMBER OF TIMES USING KEY
TAKEAWAYS.
THE BIGGEST ONE WAS THE SAME
THING THE CATALYZE FOOD BANKS
SOME FIFTY YEARS AGO.
WAS A BRICK AND MORTAR FACILITY
THAT IS WHAT'S NEEDED TO
CONCENTRATE RESOURCES IN KIND
GIVING AND MANY OTHER --
EFFICIENCIES AND REDUCTIONS OF
PRIVATE WAREHOUSING LOGISTICS
COSTS THE COULD GROW A PROGRAM
LIKE A SUPPLY BANK THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
GOING BACK TO HISTORY WHEN THEY
FIRST CREATED THAT FIRST CENTRAL
HUB IN PHOENIX ARIZONA.
IT WAS ONLY TEN YEARS BEFORE THE
UNITED STATES WAS FUNDING
EIGHTEEN MORE REGIONAL FOOD
BANKS ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
BECAUSE THE SAME MODEL OF
CONCENTRATING PHILANTHROPY
VOLUNTEERISM IN BUILDING
TREMENDOUS ECONOMIES OF SCALE
CAN WORK ANYWHERE AND THAT'S OUR
SAME COLLABORATIVE GOAL HERE.
UNDERSTOOD -- I WOULD ADD THE
THERE'S JUST.
THERE'S A VERY HUMAN SIDE TO ALL
OF THIS WHICH IS THE BASIC NEEDS
ARE NOT BASIC -- THAT'S ONE OF
THE THE MANTRAS OF THE NATIONAL
DIAPER BANK NETWORK WE WERE A
PROUD PARTNER.
BUT IT'S ALSO SOMETHING THAT --
LOCALLY.
MANY OF OUR LOCAL PARTNERS THE
THE MEADOW VIEW FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTER RIVER OAKS FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTER -- ME IN --
FIRST FIVE RIVERSIDE WE'RE
STARTING -- DIAPER KID
DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THEIR COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION FOR TEN YEARS
THROUGH THE HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS.
AND THE SAME THROUGHOUT ALL OF
CALIFORNIA SO -- HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AND THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
I THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM LA --
NO FINANCE OKAY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
RIGHT.
SO -- SO BASICALLY YOU'RE
LOOKING -- FOR AT ONE TIME
ALLOCATION TO BASICALLY BUILD
THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THIS FROMTHE STATE.
I WOULD BE ONE THIRD OF THE COST
THE OTHER TWO THIRDS
PHILANTHROPY IS TAKING CARE OF
AND ONE MILLION WOULD BE FOR
COMMERCIAL GRADE FIRE RESISTANT
SHEDS FOR DISASTER RELIEF
MATERIALS AND OTHER BASIC NEEDS
MATERIALS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
OKAY.
IS THAT -- FOR THE QUESTION LA --
IS.
AN INTEREST I THINK THIS IS THIS
SERVING USUAL FOR STATE TO PLAY
THIS ROLE ARE NOT I MEAN WE
CERTAINLY GIVE WE PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR VARIETY OF NON
PROFITS WE PARTNER WITH FOR
VARIOUS ACTIVITIES STATED THAT
FURTHER THE STATE'S AIMS.
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT I THINK WE
WE'VE SOMETIMES PROVIDE A PIECE
OF THE FUNDING AND OTHER FUNDING
IS RAISED THROUGH NONPROFITS
WHETHER OR NOT -- FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE SPECIFICALLY THAT
THE QUESTION I CAN BRING BACK TO
THE FOLKS ON OUR TEAM THAT COVER
MORE INFRASTRUCTURE RELATED
ISSUES I'M NOT TOTALLY SURE
EIGHT AND EIGHT AND AND ARE YOU
PART ARE YOU'VE BEEN TAKING
CONVERSATIONS ARE PARTNERING
WITH -- WEBER STATE AGENCIES THE
PART OF SOCIAL SERVICE SOMETHING
ABOUT THE ROLE THAT.
YOUR ORGANIZATION.
IT OUT HOW THE COURT DATES YOUR
ACTIVITIES CORNET WITH THE THE
ARE CURRENTLY WE'VE COORDINATION
RELATIONSHIPS -- THAT ARE
ONGOING WITH CALLOW YES AS IT
RELATES TO DISASTER RELIEF --
PROGRAMMATIC WITH RESPECT TO THE
NINETY EIGHT TO MYSTIC VIOLENCE
SHELTER AGENCIES.
CONTRACTUAL AND COORDINATING
WITH SO I I GUESS MORE
SPECIFICALLY IN TERMS OF THIS
PARTICULAR BUDGET REQUESTS I I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE BEEN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS OF THE THE FINANCE
ARE ONE THE AGENCIES ABOUT THE
ROLE THAT PLACE.
YES OKAY DO YOU CAN YOU
ELABORATE ON THAT A LITTLE
PERHAPS THE PRICES ARE THROUGH
THE AD THAT THAT PROPOSAL THAT
YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU HAS
BEEN AT THE CONNECTED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND HAD CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THAT AND I THINK PROBABLY
THE MOST ASKED SIMILAR AT
PROGRAMMING.
PROJECT WILL BE TO OUR FOOD
BANKS IN OUR INFRASTRUCTURE AT
RESOURCES THAT WE DO THERE OKAY
ALL RIGHT SO THAT THAT'S HELPFUL
TO NOW OKAY.
ALL RIGHT AND JUST JERRY IT'S
ONLY DOING SOME GREAT THINGS I'M
JUST I FORGET HOW THIS CONNECTS
WITH THAT IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
STATE RESOURCES HOW COORDINATES
WITH THE REST OF THE STATE'S
UNDERSTANDING.
ALL RIGHT EXCELLENT OKAY ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT THE NUN SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS SO WE
HAVE -- THREE PROPOSAL
INVESTMENTS.
BEFORE US HERE AGAIN WE'RE NOT
TAKING VOTE ON ANY OF THEM TODAY
BUT YOU.
SO YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE TO TELL
US WHICH ONE WHICH OF THE THREE
REALLY LIKE ARE ALL THREE OF
THEM AND SO THANK YOU AND
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS THE TASIA YOUNG
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE YOUTH
AND FAMILY -- CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE THE LAST FEW YEARS --
HAS BEEN REALLY HARD TO MY DAD
AND I AND CIVIC ENGAGEMENT HAS
ONLY BECOME AN ACTIVE COMMUNITY
MEMBER AND A BETTER STUDENT.
BEFORE I BECAME CIVIC LEE
INVOLVED MY GRADE POINT AVERAGE
WAS A TWO POINT NO AND I WAS
BARELY PASSING ANY CLASSES.
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT HAS TAUGHT ME
DISCIPLINE AND ENCOURAGES ME TO
PARTICIPATE MORE IN CLASS AND AS
A RESULT MY GRADE POINT AVERAGE
ROSE TO A THREE POINT.
SIX IT REALLY GET IT HAS REALLY
GIVEN ME HOPE TO MY FATHER AND I
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T NOW A BETTER
CHANCE OF GETTING INTO COLLEGE
AND HAVING A BETTER FUTURE THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
HELLO.
THE WORKER IT'S WORKING -- HELLO.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS
ISABELLA AND I'M ON HAPPY THAT
EVERYONE'S HERE HOPEFULLY YOU
GUYS HAD A GOOD MORNING.
SO ALL WHEN I I'VE BEEN PART OF
THE INITIATIVE FOR A WHILE.
SO THROUGH THE INITIATIVE. TO ME
I THE ON GROWING AS A PERSON IT
HELPS ME A LOT.
BEFORE I'M THE KIND OF PERSON
THAT WOULD BE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION PEOPLE POOR SOCIAL
SKILLS.
BUT WITH THEM I AGAIN THE
CONFERENCE TO TALK WITH PEOPLE.
LIKE NOW IT NOWADAYS DURING THIS
GENERATION TEENAGERS CAN REALLY
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH ADULTS.
BUT NOW I FEEL LIKE IT HE EASILY
DO THAT.
AND I'M ACT AND I'M REALLY
EXCITED TO BE HERE SO I HOPE
EVERYONE HAS A GOOD DAY.
RIGHT.
THANK YOUNG ESSAY THAT'S IN
SUPPORT OF THE USING THE AGENT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
MY NAME IS FOR THOSE A SET.
UP I USED.
TO NEGLECT MY FAMILY VALUES TO
THE POINT IN WHICH IT HAD A HUGE
IMPACT ON MY FAMILIAL TIES.
BASICALLY ENGAGED TAUGHT ME TO
APPRECIATE MY FAMILY TIES IN
TAKE UP RESPONSIBILITY WITHIN MY
FAMILY.
I LIKE TO THINK ABOUT MY LIFE
ASSIGNMENTS.
AND THE SACRIFICES THAT BE MADE
BY MY MOTHER MY BROTHERS TO HAVE
ME GET A GOOD EDUCATION IF IT
EVEN IF IT MATT MOVING THOUSANDS
OF MILES. TO GET OUT FROM BEHIND
MY SCREEN.
AND LOOK AT THE ROCK WORLD
AROUND ME.
AND THAT IS WHY I SUPPORT THE
YOUTH AND FAMILY INITIATIVE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS KAREN FORTY I'M
SEVENTEEN AND I'M MISSING FROM
BY SELLING CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE YOUTH
AND FAMILY A CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE -- IN MY COUNTY WE IN
FACT LEAVE THE STATE AND ALSO
POVERTY 24% OF OUR CITIZENS ARE
IN POVERTY CURRENTLY AT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE IN.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHICH
INCLUDES A TULARE COUNTY -- ARE
WITHOUT ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER.
THERE ARE MANY ISSUES THAT
AFFECT MY FAMILY AND USE -- IN
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND I BELIEVE THAT NO ONE REALLY
HAS THE ABILITY TO SPEAK FOR THE
SITUATIONS MORE THAN THE YOUTH
AND FAMILY WHO ARE ARE CURRENTLY
AFFECTED BY THOSE ISSUES SO
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE IN SUPPORT.
I WITH THE DOORS FOR THE
FOUNDATION TODAY BECAUSE I'M.
TEACHING THE STUDENTS HOW TO
BECOME SUPPORT PACIFIC WE
ENGAGED HOW DO WE NICE WITH ON
WITH THEMSELVES AND OTHER YOUTH.
BUT THEY KNOW.
THAT WE CAN AS A COMMUNITY A
COME TOGETHER AND REALLY AFFECT
CHANGE WITH THESE ISSUES SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS INTEREST GONE
AND I AM A STUDENT OF YOUR
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN'S OAKLEY
MILITARY INSTITUTE.
AND I SUPPORT THE YOUTH AND
FAMILY CIVIL ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE.
BECAUSE OF THE SELF CONFIDENCE
THAT HE GAVE ME.
I WAS A OFFICE SERGEANT OF IN
HOUSE OFFICE FOR SURGEON AND
LOCAL MILITARY INSTITUTE.
AND THANKS TO THE CONFIDENCE
THAT HE GAVE ME I BECAME FOR
NEVER TELLING SERGEANT MAJOR.
THANK YOU GOOD JOB THANK YOU.
MEAN ME NUMBER IS CLOVER
TREMENDOUS.
DEALING Là UP WE ARE NOT BUT I
MOTHER IN LAW IS WHAT THAT
POTENTIAL NINO E..
YOUR WELCOME WE WENT FOR WHAT
I'M UP OF COLOSSAL SETTLE COME
BACK AS A THIS OF WHAT UPON US
SPECIALNESS.
WAS BORN IN A SILLY PIECE UP
ELEVEN ELEVEN PM TO SEVEN WAS
BORN A PLANT THAT I TO POLICE
THE ABUSE ACOSTA MOVIE IN PERSON
THE PLEA AND A LITTLE OF WHAT.
TEXAS YES PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROBERTO
RODRIGUEZ I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
THE YOUTH AND FAMILY CIVIC
ENGAGE ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE.
MY SON IS CURRENTLY IN THE
INITIATIVE.
I ENJOYED THE FACT THAT THEY GET
TO ENGAGE IN COMMUNITY CLEAN UP
HE HAS CLEAN PARKS PLANTED TREES.
AND I HAVE I AM FULL SUPPORT OF
THE INITIATIVE THANK YOU I THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
VERY CRISIS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DANIELLE
CAMPBELL AS THE YOUTH PROGRAM
DIRECTOR FOR THE YOUTH AND
FAMILY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE I'M HERE TO SHOW MY
SUPPORT.
I HAVE WITNESSED THAT SOUTH
TRANSFORMATION OF OUR YOUTH AND
THEIR FAMILIES THE COMMUNITIES.
AND THE SKILLS THAT THEY HAVE
LEARNED -- OT ONLY HAS.
IT'S GOING TO BENEFIT THEIR
ACADEMICS -- AND THE
PROFESSIONAL.
LIFE BUT ALSO THE BEAR --
CHARACTER I HAVE SEEN OF
COMPASSION.
I HAVE SEEN GRATITUDE AND I HAVE
SEEN THE UNITY THAT WE CANNOT
AFFORD TO LOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS TRINITY GARZA AND
I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE HOUSTON
FAMILY CIVIC.
EDUCATION THANK YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN SORRY -- I AM WITH THE
LAWYERS HOOKED A FOUNDATION AND
IN MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
THAT HAS HELPED ME.
BREAK OUT OF MY SHELL A LITTLE
BIT BECAUSE I SUFFER FROM.
ANXIETY IN A SOCIAL ANXIETY TO
BE SPECIFIC.
AND WITHOUT.
BACK.
HAD ON FOUNDATION I WOULDN'T BE
STANDING HERE TODAY AND IT HAS
HELPED.
ME AND MET MANY OTHERS.
DEAL WITH WHATEVER THEY HAVE
BEEN GOING THROUGH.
AND AND SELECT A THANK YOU
THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE MY NAME IS NOT NINE AND
I'M HERE TODAY -- IN SUPPORT OF
TO USE AND FAMILIES IF YOU CAN
GET HIM INTO MISCHIEF -- BEING
PART OF THE INITIATIVE FOR
SOMETIME NOW -- I PERSONALLY
DEVELOP SEVERAL LEADERSHIP
QUALITIES INCLUDING PART OF
PUBLIC SPEAKING.
CONFIDENCE AND DOES ENABLES ME
TO BE MORE CONNECTED TO MY
COMMUNITY.
IT WAS AFTER MY PARTICIPATION
DISNEY SHADY THAT I AGREE TO MY
NEIGHBORS FOR THE FIRST TIME.
AND I BELIEVE EXPANSION OF THIS
PROGRAM WILL ENABLE OTHER PEOPLE
TO GETTING WHAT DOES WHAT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS MCCARTY BED AND
I SUPPORT THE YOUTH FAMILY CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE.
BECAUSE IT HAS TAUGHT ME TO GET
OUT OF MYSELF.
AND THINK ABOUT HOW EVEN THE
LITTLE THINGS AFFECTS EVERYONE I
LEARNED TO GIVE COACHING AND
RECEIVE COACHING.
SUCH AS SMILING WITH MY AND LEAN
IN EVERY DAY EXPERIENCE I GET A
POST WITH NEW POSSIBILITIES I
WANT TO HAVE BEFORE.
BECAUSE BEFORE I NEVER USED TO
LIKE SMILING BECAUSE THE GAP
BETWEEN MY TEETH.
NOW I AM NOW I KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF A SIMPLE SMILE
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO LISTEN TO US MY NAME
IS VALERIE SANCHES AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE YOUTH AND FAMILY
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE.
THIS INITIATIVE HAS GIVEN US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET INVOLVED WITH
THE CIVIC ENGAGEMENT I NOW KNOW
MY COMMUNITY SO MUCH BETTER I
ALWAYS CARED ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD BUT
I NEVER KNEW HOW TO CONNECT WITH
OTHER PEOPLE.
AND HOW TO GROW -- TO BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THINGS THAT I NEVER EVEN
IMAGINED AND THIS PROGRAM REALLY
GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO ACHIEVE A BETTER QUALITY OF
LIFE FOR OURSELVES AND FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS DAISY
TO LEGAL THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE I'M A PART OF THE YOUTH AND
FAMILY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE.
I'M A MIDDLE SCHOOL STUDENT.
OUR INITIATIVE IS FRIENDLY TO
EVERYONE AND WE GET INVOLVED IN
THE COMMUNITY THE INITIATIVE
ALSO HELPS US IMPROVE OUR PUBLIC
SPEAKING SKILLS PUBLIC SPEAKING
IS MORE.
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE LETS US
EXPRESS OURSELVES WITH
CONFIDENCE THE INITIATIVE HAS
IMPROVE MY PUBLIC SPEAKING
SKILLS BECAUSE NOW I'M CONFIDENT
AND OUTGOING.
I AND DEDICATED TO THIS PROGRAM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS CORNY PROMISE.
I SUPPORT THE YOUTH AND FAMILY
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE
BECAUSE I WOULD NEVER HAVE
IMAGINED MYSELF STANDING HERE
TODAY TESTIFYING. FOR THE CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT.
THROUGH CIVIC ENGAGEMENT I HAVE
LEARNED TO NOT BE AFRAID OF
PUBLIC SPEAKING EXPERIENCES AND
INSTEAD OF ISOLATION IT HAS
CREATED UNITY INEQUALITY IN MY
LIFE.
I AM NO LONGER THE QUITE GIRL
THAT SITS IN THE CORNER OF A
ROOM I AM THE EMPOWER YOUNG
WOMAN SPEAKING IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS KAYLA OF THE LEASE
AND I SUPPORT THE YOUTH AND
FAMILY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE BECAUSE I HAVE
LEARNED TO HAVE COURAGE AND
MYSELF.
AND TO SEE THE VALUE IN ME.
THROUGH THIS I HAVE DEVELOPED
THE ABILITY TO SPEAK IN FRONT OF
OTHERS AND FEEL CONFIDENT ABOUT
MYSELF.
I HAVE LEARNED TO USE MY FIRST
LANGUAGE.
DALY BECAUSE NOW I SEE THE
IMPORTANCE OF REPRESENT TEEN AT
ME FOR MEDIA IN THE COULD
THOUGHT I'M WHICH ADDRESS YES
[inaudible]
BUSES.
HI MY NAME IS HEATHER CABRAL AND
I SUPPORT THE INITIATIVE BECAUSE
THE CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
HAS GIVEN ME THE VOICE POWER AND
CONFIDENCE I WOULD NOT HAVE.
I WOULD.
NOT HAVE HAD OTHERWISE CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT HAS SHOWN ME TO SPEAK
UP FOR OTHERS WHO MAY BE CANNOT
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES -- SORRY --
IS ALSO SHOWN ME THAT CHANGE
ISN'T GONNA COME FROM SITTING
BACK AND OBSERVING THAT YOU HAVE
TO BE THE ONE TO DO IT.
THE CIVIC ENGAGE MEN HAS ALSO
SHOWED ME THAT -- IT IS
IMPORTANT TO BE TO DO SOMETHING
BIGGER THAN YOURSELF AND THAT'S
WHY I SUPPORTED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME -- HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE CARILLO -- I
AM A JUNIOR IN HIGH SCHOOL AND I
AM HERE SUPPORTING THE USE AND
FAMILY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
INITIATIVE -- I HAVE LEARNED THE
VALUES IMPORTANCE OF COMMUNITY
TRUST AND ACCEPTANCE BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY I'VE LEARNED.
TO OF I LEARNED HOW POWERFUL MY
VOICE CAN BE WHEN I USE IT AND I
THINKS THAT THINGS MY COACHES IN
THE FOUNDATION I'VE.
LEARNED THAT I COULD USE IT --
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY IT'S NOT
JUST A PROGRAM IT IS A FAMILY
AND NOT JUST ANY FAMILY BUT ONE
THAT SUPPORTS YOU AND ACCEPT YOU
FOR WHO YOU ARE.
I WAS VERY SCARED OF I'M TELLING
PEOPLE ABOUT MY SEXUAL
ORIENTATION BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T REALLY ACCEPTED BUT
BECAUSE OF THEM BECAUSE I FELT
SO ACCEPTED AND I TRUSTED THEM I
OFFICIALLY CAME OUT AS BISEXUAL
THIS YEAR SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS CLEAR THE
GARCIA AND I AM HERE TO SPEAK TO
YOU IN SUPPORT OF THE YOUTH
FAMILY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE.
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT HAS TURNED ME
FROM A TIMID SPEAKER TO AND
EMBOLDENED STUDENT WHO IS ABLE
TO CONNECT WITH MY COMMUNITY.
IT HAS EVEN EMPOWER ME TO COME
BEYOND MY COMMUNITY AND BE ABLE
TO TALK TO YOU THE COMMITTEE
TODAY.
ABOUT CAUSES THAT ARE IMPORTANT
TO ME.
TO FIND MY VOICE AND BECOME A
MORE ACTIVE MEMBER OF OUR
DEMOCRACY THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS THE ITEM
ANDRE I AM HERE Vì HAVE FOR THE
USE ENGAGEMENT.
AND I BELIEVE THIS IS A GOOD
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT OPENS THE
EYES TO THE USE ABOUT THE
GOVERNMENT TOLD.
ISSUES.
THIS PROGRAM HAS REALLY HELPED
ME WITH THE PROGRAM THE POETRY
CLASSES THE THE OUR FIRST PLEASE.
A OPENS ME A HOUSE THREE DEVELOP
MY SPEAKING MY PUBLIC SPEAKING
SKILLS AND MY WRITING SKILLS
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HELLO MY NAME IS HE'S
WITH THE ONE RIGHT I'M A FROM A
SMALL CITY NAME PER YEAR WHICH
MANY PEOPLE JUST GO TO HIGH
SCHOOL GO TO COLLEGE BUT NEVER
REALLY COME BACK TO CITY WHERE
THEY WERE REYES.
BUT WITH THIS PROGRAM WE COULD
ACTUALLY CHANGE THINGS TO MAKE
PEOPLE WANT TO COME BACK.
AND RESERVE FAMILY AND HAVE
THEIR KIDS AND THIS PROGRAM ALSO
HELPS LIKE.
THE ONE THAT JUST THE GIRL THAT
JUST SPEAK WITH MY LITTLE SISTER
WHICH OFFICER BE MORE PUBLIC
SPEAKING AND MORE.
INTO CIVIC AM CIVIC.
SORRY.
MORNING TO PUBLIC SPEAKING AND
MORE INTO.
KNOWING WHAT HER COMMUNITY
PROBLEMS ARE AND TRYING TO SOLVE
THEM THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS GOOD ORDER IS
ON AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE YOUTH AND THE EMISSION
DIMINISH AGENT.
FROM.
THIS PROGRAM HAS HELPED ME A LOT
WITH MY TALKING TOM I REALLY
DON'T.
I'M NOT AS SOCIAL AS AT ALL AND
THIS.
IS THIS PROGRAM HAS REALLY
HELPED ME OUT CALM AND COME OUT
WITH A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE I
TALK A LOT MORE NOW.
THAN I EVER HAVE AND I I WILL BE
SENDING YOUR IT WAS A FOR THEM
RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME -- HELLO MY NAME'S --
VICTOR MANUEL RODRIGUEZ AND I'M
PART OF THE USED INITIATIVE.
WHILE THE DOLLARS FOR THE
FOUNDATION REALLY HELPS YOU
WOULD LIKE PUBLIC SPEAKING.
IF IT LAKE LAKE -- THE PERSON.
BEFORE ME SAID.
A LIKE REALLY OPENED STORES AND
LIKE.
IT JUST HELPS ME REALLY A LOT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS A CLEAVER THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE -- TODAY I
WILL SUPPORT THE CHILD -- THE
YOUTH AND FAMILY INITIATIVE --
THIS PROGRAM HAS CHANGED MY LIFE
SO MUCH BEFORE I JOIN THE
PROGRAM I WAS REALLY SHY AND I
WOULD LIKE TALK TO PEOPLE AND I
WOULD BE REALLY NERVOUS.
AND NOW BECAUSE I JOIN THIS
PROGRAM I LIKE I MEET NEW PEOPLE
AND I CAN SPEAK IN FRONT OF
CROWDS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
PRISCILLA AND I'M A PARENT THAT
WAS ACTUALLY MY SENT.
IN SUPPORT OF THE YOUTH AND
FAMILY -- INC CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE SORRY I'M A BIT
CHOKED UP FOR WHAT HE SAID --
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN VERY SHY THIS
PROGRAM HAS BEEN REALLY BIG.
IT'S KIND OF BY MEN OF HIS SHOWN
I THINK IT'S JUST GOING TO
CONTINUE TO TO DO THAT SO.
CIRCUIT.
THANK YOU GUYS.
NO THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JOB THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI MY NAME IS KATHERINE
FLEMING I'M THE REMOVAL DEFENSE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT THE
CALIFORNIA RULE LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION.
AND I'M HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
FELLOWSHIP -- I JUST LIKE TO
REITERATE SOMETHING THAT JACQUI
SIDE IS IN MY ROLE AS A MENTOR I
SEE MANY LAW STUDENTS.
GRADUATING FROM SCHOOL AND
HOPING TO RETURN TO THEIR HOME
COMMUNITIES AND NOT BEING ABLE
TO BECAUSE THERE'S NO NON
PROFITS THAT THEY CAN WORK OUT
THAT THEY CAN.
RECEIVE THE MENTOR SHIP THAT
THEY NEED AND DESERVE TO START
THEIR LEGAL CAREERS THIS
FELLOWSHIP IS A WAY TO DO THAT
AS WELL AS TO PROVIDE FREE LEGAL
SERVICES TO THE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NO I BOTTOM REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION ALSO ON
BEHALF OF ONE CALIFORNIAN
CHINESE FOR FOR OF ACTION WE
SUPPORT THE NEW INVESTMENT AN
ITEM -- FOR TO ACHIEVE
MEANINGFUL AND EFFECTIVE LEGAL
ASSISTANCE AND PARTNERSHIPS IN
OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES BOTH
CONTINUED AND NEW INVESTMENTS
NEED TO BE FULLY FUNDED.
PLUS WE NEED ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT FOR DSS TO MAKE THESE
PROGRAMS SUCCESSFUL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I AND I AM A FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE IMMIGRANT JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP
AS OUR STAFF AND OUR FRESNO
OFFICE NO THERE'S A DEARTH OF
LEGAL SERVICES OUT THERE AND
IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET QUALITY
LEGAL SERVICES OUT TO OUR RURAL
PARTS OF THE STATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS A SEVEN LETTER
FROM THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS SACRAMENTO
VALLEY IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS.
ON BEHALF MY ORGANIZATION I'D
LIKE TO VOICE SUPPORT AS WELL AS
EMPHASIZED THE CRUCIAL
IMPORTANCE OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM.
IN CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY IN
CENTRAL VALLEY -- IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES FACE THE LOWER END OF
OUR STATES RESOURCE ALLOCATION.
OFTENTIMES IT TAKES MASSIVE
MOBILIZATION EFFORTS LIKE THIS
ONE IN ORDER TO OBTAIN THE MOST
BASIC OF RIGHTS SUCH AS LEGAL
REPRESENTATION IMMIGRANT.
SERVICES.
AS A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
FOCUSES HEAVILY ON PROVIDING
LEGAL SERVICES TO IMMIGRANTS
ACROSS THE STATE ESTABLISHING A
PIPE A PIPELINE THROUGH WHICH
HIGHER QUALITY IMMIGRATION
ATTORNEY SPECIALIZING IN
DEPORTATION.
DEFENSE ARE PRODUCED WILL HAVE
LEAN POSITIVELY IMPACT THE WORK
THAT WE DO BY INCREASING THE
QUANTITY THE QUANTITY AND THE
QUALITY OF THE RESOURCES THAT
THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE COULD
TAP INTO.
AMONG MANY OTHER THINGS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR CHECKING JUST
PEARL QUICK PARTS HERE BECAUSE
IT LOOKS LIKE MOST THE STUDENTS
SEPARATE TESTIFIED I JUST WANT
TO QUICKLY I THANK ALL THE
STUDENTS WHO TOOK THE TIME TO
COME HERE -- AND ALSO RECOGNIZE --
APPRECIATE YOU KNOW OUT OF TELL
YOU SOMEONE IS AND ACTUALLY US
OR SO AND SEE WE HAVE TO GIVE A
LOT OF SPEECHES I HAVE TO MAY I
STILL GET EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
RIGHT I MADE A HEIGHT OF WEALTH --
I DON'T KNOW BUT YOU CENTER SO
THAT -- SO FEELING A LITTLE
NERVOUS ABOUT PUBLIC SPEAKING IS
NORMAL BUT THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
HERE YOU DID IT YOU TESTIFIED
FOR YOU SOME OF YOU MAY BE YOUR
FIRST TIME AND EXPECT MAYBE A
NOT MAYBE MORE THAN A FEW OF YOU
MAY SOMEDAY ACTUALLY SIT ON THE
SIDE OF THE DíAS.
RIGHT SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE AND REALLY APPRECIATE
IT AND CERTAINLY IT'S A GOOD
GOOD GOOD EXPRESSION THE OUTCOME
OF THE PROGRAM AS WELL.
THAT YOU'RE HERE AND SPEAKING SO
WELL SO THANK YOU ARE SO SORRY I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT BECAUSE
THEY NEED ONE TO LEAVE BEFORE HE
WENT THROUGH THE WRESTLING.
THAT THANK YOU AND WELCOME A
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CHRIS
PUT ON BY AND I'M SPEAKING.
IN FAVOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA CHANGE LAWYERS ARE
WORKING POWERS THE NEXT
GENERATION OF LEGAL CHANGE
MAKERS WE CALL THEM CHANGE
LAWYERS.
CHANGE LAWYERS ARE THE ONES
WHO'LL RIGHT HISTORICAL WRONGS
AND FIGHT FOR EQUAL JUSTICE FOR
ALL OUR COMMUNITIES.
IN THE STATE IS THE VERSUS
CALIFORNIA WE UNFORTUNATELY DO
NOT HAVE A LEGAL SYSTEM AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE STATE. 63%
OF THE STATE ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR
BUT ONLY 23% OF LAWYERS ARE WE
SUPPORT THE FELLOWSHIP BECAUSE
WE BELIEVE THAT WHEN LAWYERS
COME FROM THE COMMUNITY THEY'RE
BETTER ABLE TO SERVE THE NEEDS
OF THEIR CLIENTS AND ACHIEVE
BETTER OUTCOMES.
WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE OUR
ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN RUNNING
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAMS FOR THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS EXACTLY LIKE THE
ONE UP.
DODD DESCRIBED IN THE PROPOSAL
AND WE BELIEVE THAT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO SOURCE -- THE BEST AND
THE BRIGHTEST DIVERSE ATTORNEYS
WHO WILL BE ABLE TO SERVE THE
COMMUNITY THROUGH THIS PROGRAM.
AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO EVERYONE ARE MANY MISTRUST
RECORDER AND I'M WITH THE
CHICANO MOVEMENT ORGANIZATION
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRATION JUSTICE
FELLOWSHIP -- THE ISSUE OF
IMMIGRATION HOW THE TREMENDOUS
IMPACT ON ALL COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING -- THE PUNJABI SICK
COMMUNITY -- OUR MEMBERS OUR
FAMILY HAS BEEN YOU KNOW HERE
FOR DECADES AND YOU KNOW DOING
PROFOUND WORK AND ARE NOW BEING
BLIND SIDED AND DEPORTED -- AND
SOLD THIS PROJECT CAN.
YOU KNOW IT COULD.
TRULY BE -- THIS PROJECT A TRULY
HELP THOSE WHO CANNOT HELP
THEMSELVES AND DEFINITELY CREATE
A MORE -- TRANSFORMATIONAL
FUTURE -- FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
THE ANNALS I AM THE LOCAL OVER
RAPID RESPONSE COORDINATOR WITH
FAITH IN THE VALLEY COVERING
FROM STOCKTON ALL THE WAY DOWN
TO KERN -- AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE IMMIGRANT
FELLOWSHIP FUNDING AND ALSO THE
YOUTH AND FAMILY CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE I AM -- I
THINK THE LOTUS WHERE ARE YOU I
WAS ONE OF HER -- ORGANIZERS AND
THANKS TO ALL THE WORK THAT I
DID WITH THE FOUNDATION I THINK
THAT I REALLY STEPPED INTO MY
OWN LEADERSHIP SO THANK YOU --
AS I AM ALSO AT A DOCTOR
RECIPIENT AND ALSO I I GET TO
EXPERIENCE FIRST HAND.
HOW MUCH SUPPORT WE NEED WITH
FUNDING -- THROUGH OUR EFFORTS
WITH THE RAPID RESPONSE NETWORK
WE DO GREAT WORK REFRAIN
FAMILIES AND REALLY HELPING
OTHERS FIND GREAT RESOURCES THAT
THEY CAN TRUST IN THE COMMUNITY.
BUT SO MUCH MORE IS NEEDED MANY
FATHER MOTHERS AND CHILDREN GO
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO STAY
TOGETHER IF THEY HAD THE PROPER
REPRESENTATION.
DETENTIONS OCCUR WITHOUT ANY
NOTICE SO FAMILIES ARE NOT
PREPARED WORDS SIX TO EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO HIRE AN
ATTORNEY NOR ARE THEY READY TO
PUT UP TENER TO TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO POST BAIL.
ARE WE NEED MORE SUPPORT WITH
LEGAL ASSISTANCE THROUGHOUT OUR
VALLEY AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY
NAME IS JOBS STATION WILL AND
I'M WITH THE THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION ALSO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA A COLLABORATIVE FOR
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE -- AND I'M A
RAPID RESPONSE ATTORNEY BASED
OUT OF FRESNO -- IT'S REMARKABLE
TO ME HOW FEW PRO BONO REMOVAL
DEFENSE THE ATTORNEYS THERE ARE
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
THE NEED IS ABSOLUTELY
REMARKABLE AND I GET TO SEE
FIRSTHAND HOW SCARED AND HOW
LONG PEOPLE ARE WHEN THEY'RE PUT
IN THESE PROCEEDINGS -- IN
REMOVAL PROCEEDINGS PEOPLE ARE
ARE FIGHTING FOR THEIR LIVES
THEY'RE FIGHTING TO STAY WITH
THEIR FAMILIES.
AND FOR THOSE OF THEM.
WHO ARE DOING IT WITHOUT THE
BENEFIT OF AN ATTORNEY -- THIS
FELLOWSHIP IS NOT JUST A
PIPELINE BUT IT'S A LIFELINE
IT'S ESSENTIAL.
AND THE ANALOGY THAT I THAT I
WAS THINKING OF WAS FOR THOSE IN
REMOVAL PROCEEDINGS.
IT'S LIKE ASKING SOMEONE TO GO
INTO THE E. R. AND DO SURGERY ON
THEMSELVES AND I THINK WE SHOULD
STOP HAVING PEOPLE.
TO DO THAT AND I HOPE -- YOU
KNOW WE CAN WE CAN GET PEOPLE
THAT.
THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME. ONE KAREN FARLEY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA WITH ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE SUPPLY BANK
PROPOSAL.
AND THE LOCAL AGENCIES IT HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH
SUPPLY BANK OF A VERY POSITIVE
OUTCOME SUPPLYING DIAPERS TO
MOMS WHO ARE TRYING TO GO BACK
TO WORK.
AND I'D LIKE TO JUST CONNECT THE
DOTS HERE ON WHAT KIND OF IMPACT
THAT CAN HAVE THE USE THAT
TESTIFIED HERE OR SO PROVIDING
SO MUCH HOPE.
I'M BETTING SOME OF THOSE.
LEADER YOUNG LEADERS WERE WITH
PARTICIPANTS SO A LITTLE BIT OF
INVESTMENT IN THOSE EARLY YEARS
HAS A VERY LONG TERM TRAJECTORY
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ANOTHER ANIMAL GOES
UP FROM THE CENTRAL COAST -- ARE
YOU SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP IN
THE CENTRAL BECAUSE WE ARE LEGAL
AID I WORK FOR LEGAL AID.
I AND EVERY DAY WE NOT ONLY DO
WE GE.
CALLS FROM CLIENTS OR FROM
COMMUNITY MEMBERS SEEKING
SERVICES BUT WE ALSO GET CALLS
FROM AGENCIES WHO YOU FIND.
AND WHO YOU ARE PROVIDING
SERVICES AND ARE NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES BECAUSE
THOSE CLIENTS HAVE QUESTIONS AND
THE PROVIDERS HAVE QUESTIONS --
WE ALSO HAVE -- INTERNSHIP WHERE
EVERY YEAR WE ARE TRAINED AND
EXPOSE UNDERGRAD STUDENTS
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY UNDERGRAD
STUDENTS TO OUR LEGAL SYSTEM AND
LEGAL AID AND SOME OF THEM ARE.
OUR CURRENT ATTORNEY SOME OF
THEM ARE IN LAW SCHOOL AND SOME
OF THEM ARE APPLYING FOR LAW
SCHOOL -- SO WHAT WE SUPPORT
THIS AND WHAT THIS IS A HIGH
NEED IN OUR COMMUNITY OUR
IMMIGRANTS BUILD.
THE ECONOMY OF THIS STATE AND
THEY ALSO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
BUDGET SO THEY SHOULD ALSO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE ON BUDGET AND
SERVICES -- FOR THE BUDGET --
PROVIDES FOR THEM IT'S HIGHLY
NEEDED IN OUR AREAS AND DAYS CAN
HELP US CREATE A LITTLE BIT OF
EQUITY AND EQUALITY THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING -- MY NAME IS
DOCTOR CAITLIN TYLER I'M AN
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR OF SOCIOLOGY
AT UC DAVIS I'M HERE SUPPORT.
SKEWS ME I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
FELLOWSHIP BUT I WANT TO SAY TO
ALL THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AS A
PROFESSOR UC DAVIS I LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING YOU IN MY
CLASSROOM -- SO I HAVE A PHD IN
SOCIOLOGY IN A PUBLISHED NEARLY
TWO WITH A FOCUS ON THE TENSION.
AND MY RESEARCH TEAM HELP TO
ANALYZE THE HUNDREDS OF CASES
THAT MAKE THE BACKBONE OF THIS
PROPOSAL.
THE LEGAL JUSTIFICATION FOR THE
PROGRAM ARE CLEAR THE HUMAN
RIGHTS JUSTIFICATIONS FOR THE
PROGRAM ARE CLEAR.
SO I THOUGHT WHAT I DO TODAY IS
JUST SHARE WITH YOU TWO QUICK
THINGS -- FROM A CURRENT SOCIAL
SCIENCE RESEARCH THAT KIND OF
SAY WHAT'S AT STAKE IF YOU DON'T
SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM.
SO -- DETENTION HURTS OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY AND DIRECT AND
INDIRECT RATE WAYS MY RESEARCH
ON DETENTION IN CALIFORNIA HAS
SHOWN THE DETENTION IS
ASSOCIATED WITH LOST WAGES TO
THE TUNE OF ABOUT EIGHTY EIGHT
DOLLARS PER DAY PER PERSON. FOR
EVERY PERSON THAT WAS EMPLOYED
PRIOR TO DETENTION.
AND IF YOU EXTRAPOLATE THAT OUT --
TO IT ACT IT IT EXTRAPOLATES OUT
TO ABOUT SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER DAY.
OR TWENTY SIX TWENTY MILLION PER
YEAR JUST FOR PEOPLE DETAINED IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND ONE LAST
THING I WANT TO SAY THAT MY
COLLEAGUES -- ECONOMIST AT UC
DAVIS HAVE SHOWN THAT FOR EVERY
ONE PERSON WHO'S REMOVED FROM
THE ECONOMY TO DEPORTATION TO U.
S. CITIZENS ARE ALSO REMOVED
FROM THE ECONOMY AND SO I THINK
IT MAKES.
SENSE TO THAT IF A PROGRAM CAN
PROVIDE A MECHANISM TO INCREASE
RATES A RELEASE AND REALLY AND
RATES OF RELIEF FROM DEPORTATION
THAT WE SHOULD SUPPORT IT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE MINUTE PIECE
PLEASE THANK YOU WELCOME
EVERYONE MY NAME IS HAVING DOES
LUMPEN ON THE ADVOCACY DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE
FOR ME JUST AS YOU JUST HEARD
FROM OUR COORDINATOR AND FRESNO
OUR ATTORNEY IN FRESNO IN A
COURT IN THE CENTRAL COAST.
WE SUPPORTING COORDINATE
SERVICES IN THOSE REGIONS IN
THIS PROPOSAL IS ESSENTIALLY
COMING OUT OF THE NEED THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED IN THOSE
REGIONS OVER AND OVER AGAIN
WE'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
EMERGENCY SERVICES WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE LONG TERM
SERVICES IN THIS A PATHWAY TO DO
THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS WHAT THE
RISKS ARE EXPECTED DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IMMIGRANT
AGGRESSION COLLABORATIVE.
A YEAR AGO WE'RE HERE.
PRESENTING TO YOU A RURAL LEGAL
FELLOWS PROJECT THAT
UNFORTUNATELY NOT GET APPROVED
THE VERY END OF THE PROCESS.
BUT WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT YEARS
OF COURSE MANY FAMILIES SMALL --
WERE IMPACTED BY THE ENFORCEMENT
POLICIES OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHAT DO YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU NOTICE A PROPOSAL
THAT IS GOING TO BE ENHANCING
THE CIVIC SIGNIFICANT MATTER.
THE CONVENTIONAL CAPACITY TO
SERVE THOSE FAMILIES NOW -- IT'S
A PROJECT THAT DEVELOPS A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN CENTER ABOUT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE VERY
LIMITED.
CAPACITY WITH US IN THE BAY AREA.
AND AS THOMAS POINTED OUT IS
SOMETHING THAT -- HAS BEEN
DEVELOPED EFFECTIVELY IF IT WITH
THIS TYPE OF COLLABORATION.
NOW -- IT IN THIS LOCATION ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO DO IS OUR IN
ADDITION TO SUPPORT THIS
INITIATIVE OF COURSE.
IS ALSO SUPPORTERS PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR THOUGHT BLOWS WERE
TENTATIVE FOR YOUTH CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT.
A CENTRAL VALLEY RESIDENTS ARE
WE'LL SEE THE VALUE OF INVESTING
THE YOUNG PEOPLE SO MY SUPPORT
FOR BOTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING CHRISTINA KEVIN
WITH COMMUNITY JUSTICE ALLIANCE --
I'VE BEEN A REMOVAL DEFENSE
ATTORNEY FOR ABOUT EIGHT YEARS
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND I OFTEN AM IN SAN FRANCISCO
IMMIGRATION COURT WHERE JUDGES
WILL YELL AT PEOPLE FOR NOT
BEING ABLE TO PROCURE AN
ATTORNEY -- THEY'VE ALSO HAD ME
STAY OVER TO VOLUNTEERED TO BE
AN INFORMAL ATTORNEY OF THE DAY --
AND THE MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE
THAT I SEE THERE ARE FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THEY CANNOT
ACCESS AN ATTORNEY WHATSOEVER --
SO WE'VE BEEN DOING SOME
GRASSROOTS FUND RAISERS JUST TO
AFFORD REMOVAL DEFENSE FOR
PEOPLE.
AND I WANTED TO ELEVATE A COUPLE
OF OUR CLIENT STORIES AND WE DO
WE REPRESENT A MOTHER RIGHT NOW
THAT'S BEEN DETAINED FOR TWO
YEARS SHE'S ABOUT TO MISS HER
SON'S THIRD BIRTHDAY -- BECAUSE
SHE'S FINDING HER ASYLUM CASE
FOR THE SECOND YEAR IN A ROW.
AND IMMIGRATION JAIL.
OUT WE ALSO REPRESENTED A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO A FARM WORKER FROM
PORTER BILL WHO IS STOPPED
OUTSIDE OF WORK SITE.
AND BROUGHT IN THROUGH CUSTOMS
AND BORDER PROTECTION BECAUSE HE
COULD NOT ARTICULATE.
WHY HE WAS A CITIZEN?
I'M HE SPENT ELEVEN DAYS IN JAIL
AND WE WERE ABLE TO ADVOCATE ON
THE LOCAL AND THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
TO GET HIM RELEASED IN SO THIS
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO
CREATE THIS PIPELINE AND FOR
THAT REASON WE WE ARE HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BETTY AT
THE ACT I'M A NATIVE OF
GUATEMALA AND NOW AN INTERPRETER
WITH COMMUNITY JUSTICE SCIENCE.
A LEGAL DEFENSE TEAM THAT HAS
DEFENDED IMMIGRANTS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND AT TIMES AT THE BORDER I
HELP INTERPRET FOR CLIENTS.
AS YOUNG AS SIX YEARS OLD.
WHILE THEY ARE DEFENDED AGAINST
REMOVAL PROCEEDINGS THROUGHOUT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY SOMETIMES I
WAKE UP AT FOUR IN THE MORNING.
TO DRIVE THEM BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE A WAY TO GET ON TO THE
NEAREST IMMIGRATION COURT IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND WITHOUT HELP.
GETTING THERE THEY WILL BE
ORDERED DEPORTED FOR FAILURE TO
APPEAR.
I'VE DONE THIS FOR CHILDREN THE
DISABLED AND FAMILIES WHO CANNOT
AFFORD TRANSPORTATION.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT EVERYONE
DESERVES ACCESS TO TO THE COURT.
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE IMMIGRATION
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM.
INVESTMENT TO SUPERCHARGE
REMOVAL DEFENSE IN CENTRAL
VALLEY SO THAT THOSE.
OF US WHO ARE WORKING TO DEFINE
IMMIGRANTS HAVE STRONGER MORE
SUSTAINED A MORE SUSTAINABLE
NETWORK.
AND SO FAMILIES CAN STAY
TOGETHER AND FREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
WHEN I STARTED THIS NUMBER DOES
HAVE A LOT TO LEARN CAN WE MAKE
IT AND THEY MEMBER FROM THE
OTHER THE COMMUNITY JUSTICE
ALLIANCE?
GET UP -- YEAH LET ME SET THE
THAT IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
FELLOWSHIP ARE YOU ARE GOOD
THOSE ARE JUST A MINUTE HERE
MIGHT NOT MAKE IT OUT THIS THING
ON ACCESS OR NOT A PERSON
DOESN'T I'LL GET THEM TO TO SEE
THEM.
THANK YOU CRISIS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JASON
SIZE AND I AM HERE WITH YOU ANY
JUSTICE ALLIANCE I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR I'M AN ATTORNEY AND I AM
THE SON OF AN IMMIGRANT LIVING
HERE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
I'VE BEEN SUPPORTING MY
IMMIGRATION COLLEAGUES ATTORNEY
COLLEAGUES FOR IN REMOVED THE
FANS.
BECAUSE THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS IN
CRISIS THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
THE COURTS SOMETIMES WE USE FOR
THE FIRST SIX HOURS AWAY.
ANY ESPECIALLY DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO ATTORNEYS.
I BECAME INSPIRED TO HELP.
EVEN ON PRIVATE COUNSEL BECAUSE
I REPRESENTED A FAMILY A FATHER
AND SON WHO WERE DETAINED.
SEPARATED UPON DETENTION
EVENTUALLY WERE WERE REUNITED --
BUT ONLY AFTER WE REPRESENT THEM
IN COURT AND WERE ABLE TO GET
THEM FREE WHICH THEY WERE LET
FREE TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
ONCE THEY GOT OUT WILL BE CALLED
EVERYWHERE TRYING TO FIND AN
ATTORNEY BECAUSE WE KNEW THE
PROCESS WAS AN OVER JUST BECAUSE
THEY WERE REUNITED.
MONTHS AND MONTHS AND MONTHS WE
SEARCH WE CAN FIND ANY SO WHAT
DO WE END UP DOING WE TAKE AN IN
HOUSE PRO BONO.
FUND RAISER PRIVATELY SO THAT WE
COULD JUST HELP THIS ONE FAMILY.
AS YOU CAN SEE THAT'S NOT A
SUSTAINABLE MODEL YOU KNOW WE
CAN'T JUST KEEP.
TRYING TO DO IT SO.
OUR MILLION SUPPORT NUMBER
NUMBER FOUR AND I DO WANT TO
THANK YOU BECAUSE I KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S IS VERY STRONG IN
SUPPORT OF MAKES BAD FAMILY
STATUS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- CENTERS -- YOU
SAID IT WAS BECAUSE WITH THE
EDUCATION ITS FOUNDATION I'M
HERE SUPPORTER OF THE CALIFORNIA
JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP FELLOWS
PROGRAM -- WE ARE IN VERY NEEDY
CRISIS RIGHT NOW --
UNFORTUNATELY THE WAY OUR
ORGANIZATION THE CENTRAL VALLEY
HAVE.
DEVELOPED AS IS NOT WORKING SAYS
TO ASSIST PEOPLE WHO AND REMOVE
THE FANS THERE'S ONLY ABOUT TWO
AUDIENCES ARE PREVENTABLE THE
FENCE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
WELL THIS ORDER ONCE LIKE I WAS
THAT WE JUST HAVE.
UP.
PATRICK REPRESENT IS THAT WE WE
CANNOT GO IN REPRESENT PEOPLE
BEFORE IMMIGRATION COURTS SO
THESE PRO ON ONE WILL ALLOW.
US TO HOST.
BUT NEWLY -- GRADUATE -- LAW
STUDENTS TO COME IN WERE FOR OUR
ORGANIZATION AND PROVIDE THE
SERVICES FOR FAMILIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WOULD MAKE NO THE WE
DO HAVE MANY OTHER ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA WE HAVE YET TO HEAR SO IF
SOMEONE SAID SOMETHING THAT YOU
THAT ALREADY AHEAD OF YOU THAT
YOU JUST YOU CAN SAY DITTO I
SUPPORT WHAT THAT PERSON SAID.
I MEAN -- I GIVE YOU THE CHANCE
TO SAY WHATEVER YOU WANT TO SAY --
AND THE TIME LIMIT BUT ALSO JUST
THE PLEASE BE CONSCIOUS OF HAVE
FEARS THAT SOMEONE ELSE REYES
SAID WHAT YOU GUYS SAY.
YOU CAN YOU CAN JUST EXPRESS
YOUR SIMILAR SUPPORT CELL THANK
YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANA
WHERE TO AND I'M THE STAFF
ATTORNEY FOR THE REMOVAL DEFENSE
PROGRAM AT THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS FOUNDATION.
IN BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA -- I'D
LIKE TO SAY THAT I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THE IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
FELLOWSHIP -- I AM FROM BAKER SO
CALIFORNIA I WAS BORN AND RAISED
THERE AND I HAVE TO THESE
PARTNERSHIPS I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
RECEIVE VALUABLE LEGAL TRAINING
AND ONGOING MENTORSHIP.
IN ORDER TO DIRECTLY SERVE ARE
DETAINED IN NINETY TEN
POPULATIONS IN BAKERSFIELD AND
THROUGHOUT KERN COUNTY CURRENTLY
MYSELF FROM MY SUPERVISOR ARE
THE ONLY TWO NONPROFIT
IMMIGRATION REMOVAL DEFENSE
PROVIDERS AND ALL OF KERN COUNTY.
SO I AM EXPRESSING MY SUPPORT
FOR THIS FUNDING I HOPE THAT YOU
GRANT US THIS FUNDING AND I ALSO
LIKE TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH AND
FAMILIES.
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS KARENA MARLYS
I'M LEGAL ASSISTANT WITH THE
REMOTE DEFENSE PROJECT AND THE
F. W. FOUNDATION AS A LEGAL
SERVICE PROVIDER GET TO SEE
FIRSTHAND EVERY DAY THE GREAT
NEED IN OUR COMMUNITY FOR FREE.
LEGAL -- REMOVE DEFENSE SERVICES --
THAT IS WHY I AM HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ON BUT A LOT AND I AM BE
DIRECTED TURNING FOR THE RULE
DEFENSE PROJECT OF THE THAT
FARMER CHRIS FOUNDATION.
AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE STATED YOU
KNOW I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
FELLOWSHIP.
THE FOUNDATION IS A TESTAMENT TO
THE IMPACT THAT A SIMILAR
PARTNERSHIP WITH ONE OF THE
LEADING REMOVAL DEFENSE
ORGANIZATION HAS HAD IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
AS THE ONLY ORGANIZATION AND
KERN COUNTY PROVIDE WILL DEFEND
SERVICES WITH A STAFF OF THREE
THOSE ARE.
THREE EVERY DAY WE ARE WITNESSES
TO THE DESPERATE NEED OF
FAMILIES WERE UNABLE TAXES LEGAL
SERVICES SIMPLY BECAUSE THOSE
SERVICES ARE NOT AVAILABLE IN
THEIR AREA.
I STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THAT A PROPOSAL
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
OKAY AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN POND.
I'M HERE TO DO THE MY DAUGHTER
ON AT LEAST HIS TESTIMONY.
ANYWAY I AM A PRIVATE ATTORNEY
I'M ALSO HEARING SO -- WE HAVE
MY FAMILY AND THE LOTUS WHAT THE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT IMMIGRATION
JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP.
I JUST WANT TO SARE WITH YOU A
SHORT STORY AS A PRIVATE
ATTORNEY.
A FEW YEARS BACK ON CHRISTMAS
EVE I RECEIVED A CALL FROM A
LEGAL PERMANENT RESIDENT THAT
WAS INCARCERATED IN THE KERN
COUNTY JAIL.
HE HAD CALLED ME BECAUSE THE
IMMIGRATION COURT HAD LOST HIS
FILE HE HAD BEEN THERE FOR SIX
MONTHS.
AS A PRIVATE ATTORNEY I WAS ABLE
TO GET HIM RELEASED IN FORTY
EIGHT HOURS THERE WAS NO REASON
FOR HIM TO BE THERE.
SO THERE'S JUST A DESPERATE NEED
FOR THIS TYPE OF SUPPORT
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL CALIFORNIA
WHERE FARMWORKERS MAKE MAJORITY
OF THE POPULATION IN ARE THE
BACKBONE OF OUR AG ECONOMY.
SECONDLY I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
YOUTH AND FAMILY SIT PASSIVELY
CAN GAUGE WENT INITIATIVE.
AS THE SON OF THE LOTUS WARTIME
CLEARLY THE PRODUCT OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT IN KNOWING IN TERMS
OF PRICING WALKING ORGANIZING
GET OUT THE VOTE.
AND I CAN SEE I CANNOT THINK OF
ANY BETTER WAY TO HONOR.
THE LEGACY OF MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR AND A LOT OF SORTA.
AS YOU THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAS BONNER
RECOGNIZED HER ON EIGHTY NINTH
BIRTHDAY HERE TODAY SO WE'RE
HERE TO SUPPORT BOTH OF MODELS
INITIATIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JEREMY
THEM IN THOSE I'M A LAW STUDENT
AND I'M ALSO A BE A
REPRESENTATIVE WITH H. CHRISTIAN
LEADERSHIP FOUNDATION.
WE PROVIDE WE HAVE A SMALL --
IMMIGRATION UNIT -- BUT
DEFINITELY THE FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT JUSTICE-FELLOWSHIP WOULD DEFINITELY
BENEFIT OUR PROGRAM AND OTHER
PROGRAMS AS WELL -- I'M ALSO I
WANT ALSO ONE EXTENDED MY
SUPPORT TO THE YOUTH AND FAMILY --
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT IT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN AS FIRST GENERATION ALL
LOST IN I THINK UP PROGRAMS LIKE
THAT HELP OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR
YOUTH THANK.
YOU.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ROSA -- OR JONES I'M COMING FROM
FRESNO I ALSO WORK AT EDUCATION
LETITIA FOUNDATION.
I'M WORKING WITH THE COMMUNITY
I'M ALSO A LAW STUDENT SO I
THINK THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT IS
ESSENTIAL FOR A COMMUNITY SO WE
CAN AVOID MORE FAMILY SEPARATION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
SO YEAH Là NOT GONNA RADIO EVAN
LOW THAT BUT IT'LL CALIFORNIA --
YELLING WELL OF ALL THAT BUT I
CAN SEE ON THE LITTLE.
PHONE THOUGH BUT KNOWN ONLY SAYS
HE'LL NORMAL TRIP.
GO MORE LEVEL KNOWS YOU WHEN
THEY LOOK US SOON IN THE END OF
THE GOAL SO YOU KNOW WE'LL LET
ME PLAY A LITTLE THE LAST TIME
THEY LIVE BATASUNA CELLS BEEN SO
IN A SINGLE SENTENCE INTO A
LOTUS [inaudible]
PRESS.
ALARM -- BINGO.
UP WE ALLOW PROPUESTAS A LAMB
BUT I YOU THE LET ME ASK YOU --
ONE THING ONE TESTIMONIAL -- TO
WITH THE MODELS DIAZ CARE FOR
THE POOR THOUGHT OF THE LET ME
ASK YOU WHETHER YOU ARE NOT FROM
ACROSS -- WILL KNOW THEY USUALLY
WILL MAKE -- YELLOW THREE NO
I'LL ONE MOM ASSEMBLY THE MAD
THEY IT YET AND I'M CONSIGNA
WILL SCANDAL.
IS AND I IMAGINE.
WE HAVE PARENTS THEY HAVE TO
TRIED LIKE FORTY FIVE MINUTES TO
AN HOUR TO BRING CHILDREN TO
SCHOOL.
TOOK A CITY COLLEGE AND THEY
HAVE TO GO BACK -- TO THEIR JOBS
THEY WORK IN THE FIELD.
SO.
ARE THERE IS STUDENTS ARE THOSE
STUDENTS THEY ALWAYS AN AT THE
STATE -- I'M YOU CAN CALL AN
EMERGENCY BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS.
AND THEY CAN BE THE POTTER ANY
TIME EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE --
SOME SOME OF THEM THERE ARE
LEGAL.
BUT NOT THE PARENTS SO I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT -- THE DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES AND DOLLARS WHAT
BECAUSE I WILL I WILL THE WAR AT
THAT WORK TOGETHER SO WE NEED
THIS IS OUR FUTURE.
AND WE NEED TO SUPPORT THE
PLEASE HELP US.
OUT WE REALLY NAY -- MAJOR AND I
KNOW THIS BECAUSE THEY ARE
MEDICAL STUDENTS AND THE EARTH
OF THE GOOD STUDENT THEY HAVE.
FOUR GB EIGHT FOUR POINT ZERO
SAW PLEASE HELP US OKAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
WHEN IS THE BEST NUMBER TO SEE
LIVING OTHER PRESS NOW IF THEY
CAN'T FOR YOUR INTEREST SOMEONE
THIS YEAR ON THE PGA SEE ONLY TO
THAT AS WELL?
BUT I GUESS IT INFO ON THOSE BUT
I CERTAINLY SAYS YOU AN ESCAPE
NONE OF THAT LOOK AT THE BEST
COULD SOMEONE IMPORTANT THIS BUT
IT BUT IT'S ONE OF THE HOUSING
CRISIS [inaudible]
BUT FOR HELLO PROPUESTAS.
THEY MEET ASEAN GUEST ON ME BUT
ABOUT THIS PRODUCT BUT IT'S ONE
OF THEM HOUSING GRACELESS BUT
CRISIS.
WHEN I WAS AT THE LOS ME NUMBER
THEY HAVE A CITY BANK WITH A
CALL THE OTHER FRESNO?
A YELLOW IS THE MOST LIKELY BUT
ISN'T THIS BUT I KNOW THEY SEE
THAT BECAUSE YOU'RE MAYBE ENABLE
WAYS BUT THAT NO IS GONE THEY
HAVE NOT.
BEEN THE MOST APPLE YEAH SO ANY
SEXY ON IT'S GONNA SYSTEM BUNDLE
SUPPORT PANEL SO WHEN WE GOT THE
SENATE THAT BY EAST MANY
MOLLUSCAN OTHER UP AND THEN WENT.
WHEN I WHEN I BE THAT YOU KNOW
WHEN I ADD IT BECAUSE YOU'LL BUT
I MISSED A SINGLE SAID LOOK AT
THE MOST MUST BUNDLES BUT ALSO
IT IS A FEELING OF THE LOOK AT
THE MOSQUE IN A SUSTAINABLE
YEMEN'S BUT THEN THE SUPPORT?
BUT I CAN GENERAL TO THE BOTTOM
OF THE PORTANTINO SUPPORT AND
STUFF I MEAN YES YES YES.
THIS IS.
HI AM JESSICA DEVOS WOULD
CENTROLEGAL THE LOVE ASA I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA EVEN IT IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP -- BECAUSE WE
NEED MORE OF REMOVAL DEFENSE
LEGAL SERVICES ESPECIALLY IN A
RURAL COMMUNITIES THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ANOTHER DAY GOES WAY SENT A
LETTER THAT I SENT.
I AM HERE IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
FELLOWSHIP BECAUSE NO ONE
DESERVE TO LIVE IN FEAR AND THE
LEAST THAT WE CAN OFFER THEM AS
LEGAL RESOURCES AND REMOTE
DEFENSE -- ESPECIALLY WITH THE
TIMES THAT -- OUR DOCUMENT
COMMUTER LIVING WITH EVERY DAY
CITIES THAT WE CAN DO THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS MARY I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF CENTRAL THEY GOT THEY
LET US KNOW.
I AM ALSO A THAT GUY WAS THE
BEING WHO HAS EXPERIENCE A LACK
OF LEGAL RESOURCES AND THE
CENTRAL COAST SO I AM HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE PIPELINE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS LISA KNOCKS ON
IMMIGRATION MANAGING ATTORNEY
WITH CENTRAL ABOUT THAT I RASA.
YOU HEARD HERE TODAY THE
INCREDIBLE NEED THERE IS IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES FOR LEGAL
SERVICES AND AS AN ATTORNEY
WHO'S HAD THE EXPERIENCE OF
MENTORING AND SUPERVISING NEW
ATTORNEYS IN A DIRECT SERVICES
SETTING IT ALSO IN A LAW SCHOOL
CLINIC SETTING.
I'M HERE TO TOUCH THE IMPORTANCE
OF TRAINING AND ONGOING
MENTORSHIP AND ON GROWING THE
FIELD.
AND I'VE ALSO HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF WORKING WITH THE U. S. W.
FOUNDATION AND GETTING THEIR
REMOVAL DEFENSE PROGRAM OFF THE
GROUND.
SO I CAN SAY THAT THE SORT OF
MENTORSHIP AND TRAINING THAT THE
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP
PROJECT WILL PROVIDE WORKS
BECAUSE I'VE SEEN IT WORK.
I'M IN THE CONTEXT OF THE U. F.
W. FOUNDATION SO I'M HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THAT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS A LET ME FROM
CENTER LET A LET US THAT -- I'VE
ALREADY SPOKEN ABOUT HOW
CRITICAL THE FUNDING FOR LEGAL
SERVICES HAS BEEN FOR US AS THE
LARGEST PROVIDER OF REMOVAL
DEFENSE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE IN -- VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE PIPELINE PROJECT.
PARTICULAR I'M NOT GONNA -- I
SEE DID -- TO EVERYTHING THAT
EVERYONE ELSE SAD BUT I REALLY
WANT TO ENCOURAGE CALIFORNIA TO
CONTINUE TO BE THE LEADER THAT
IT HAS BEEN.
THERE IS NO OTHER FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM LIKE THIS IN ALL OF THE
IN THE WHOLE COUNTRY SO THIS
WOULD REALLY BE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SHOW BOTH CALIFORNIANS THAT
WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT ACCESS TO
COUNSEL AND DUE PROCESS AND ALSO
TO SHOW THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
THAT WHAT CAN BE DONE TO SERVE
RURAL COMMUNITIES WHO
DESPERATELY NEED ACCESS TO
SERVICES THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF BENITO GOGGLES
AND SUPPLY BANK DOT ORG ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE FELLOWSHIP.
DITTO TO EVERYTHING ALL THE
YOUTH AND ADVOCATES OF SAID BUT
ALSO JUST TO ADD ONE MORE
ANECDOTE.
BOTH MY PARENTS WORK FOR THE UFW
BEFORE AND AFTER I WAS BORN IN A
LOT OF THE LIFE AND PROFESSIONAL
SKILLS AT THE YOU SPOKE ABOUT
THAT THEY GAINED THROUGH THE
FELLOWSHIP THEY USED TO HAVE TO
LEARN ON THE FLY BACK THEN IT
WAS A LOT DIFFERENT AND SO.
ANY PROGRAM THEY CAN PREPARE
THEM TO BE READY ON DAY -- ONE
IS SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
INVEST IN AND TRY TO EXPAND
THANKS VERY MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ASKED THE WHITE SEA IN
HERE -- ON BEHALF OF THE MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR FREEDOM
CENTER IN SUPPORT OF THE YOUTH
AND FAMILY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE OUT WHAT THIS
INITIATIVE REPRESENTS IS AN
INTERRACIAL.
INTERGENERATIONAL APPROACH TO
ENHANCING CIVIC ENGAGEMENT -- IN
A TIME WHERE WE ARE SO DIVIDED
AS THE PEOPLE AT THIS INITIATIVE --
IS FRANKLY THE SOLUTION --
YOU'VE HEARD FOR FROM FOR MANY
OF THE YOUTH HERE AND THEY SPEAK
FOR THE YOUTH THAT ARE IN THAT
HAVE BEEN TOUCHED BY THIS
PROGRAM.
THAT COULD BE HERE -- THERE IS --
WE DEALT GENERAL MISTRUST IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OUT RURAL AND
URBAN COMMUNITIES OF GOVERNMENT.
OUT WHAT WE DO IS WE COMMUNICATE
TO THESE YOUTH.
FAMILIES COMMUNITIES THAT YOUR
VOICE MATTERS.
RIGHT AND SO WHEN THEY KNOW THAT
THEN THE SKY IS THE LIMIT FOR
THEM SO I HOPE THAT YOU WILL
SUPPORT US IN THIS INITIATIVE
THAT WE WOULD.
HAVE -- THE SUSTAINABILITY THAT
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES OF THESE
PEOPLE AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
A MISTER CHAIR MY CAROL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY -- AND WE SUPPORT --
THAT THE JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP AND
THE THE CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
PROPOSAL THAT ARE BROUGHT
BROUGHT FOR YOU ENCOURAGE YOU TO
FUND BOTH OF THEM THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS CARLOS GABER I'M A COMMUTER
ORGANIZER FAITH IN THE VALLEY SO
I'M LOOKING.
AT HIM IN SUPPORT OF THE
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP.
PROGRAM IS REALLY NEEDED IN IN A
CENTRAL VALLEY AND ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE YOU FOR FAMILY
SEVEN DAYS WE PROGRAM AT THOSE
WITH THIS ORGANIZATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SALLY
KENOSHA FROM THE IMMIGRANT LEGAL
RESOURCE CENTER -- AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER WE ICE
MISSPOKE WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
AROUND FOR ALMOST FORTY YEARS
PROVIDING IMMIGRATION CAPACITY
BUILDING SUPPORT AND WE ARE
LEGAL TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS CDSS --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRING UP
THE ISSUE OF DIVERSITY IN THE
STATE CHAIRMAN -- I SPENT I
STARTED MY CAREER TWENTY YEARS
AGO PROVIDING REMOVAL DEFENSE
SERVICES TO SOUTHEAST ASIAN
IMMIGRANTS AND IN THAT CAPACITY
SERVED LEYVA.
LAOTIAN MAULING MEN LAW WHO TIED
DOWN VIETNAMESE AND CAMBODIAN
CLIENTS FROM AS FAR SOUTH AS
BAKERSFIELD AS FAR NORTH AS
CHICO -- AND WHAT WE REALLY NEED
IS THIS KIND OF FUNDING AND WILL
DEVELOP PROPOSAL THAT INCLUDES A
STRUCTURE TO DEVELOP THE
PIPELINE SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME DOCTOR PAN NO I BOTTOM
ALL CRLA FOUNDATION.
AND AS A YOUTH FARMWORKER KIT
FROM WOULD LIKE CALIFORNIA WE
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THE FAMILY
AND YOU CIVIC INITIATIVE OF THAT
LOSS WHAT THE FOUNDATION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
KATHY THOMPSON MY SON IS -- A BI
POLAR SIGN THAT GRADUATING FROM
CHINA LIVE AND HIDE.
THIS YEAR EVEN THOUGH I KNEW
FRESNO AND I A SUPPORT ALL THAT
YOU GUYS ARE GOING FOR IT IS NOT.
AND I'M SO GRATEFUL AND BLESSED
TO LIVE IN CALIFORNIA AREN'T WE
ALL AND SO EVERYBODY CAN HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
JEFF TURNED AGUIRRE GETS THE
LAST WORD TO OFFER IS CALIFORNIA
IS ALWAYS BEEN IMMIGRANTS SO
ANYTHING WE CAN DO. TO DO WITH
TRYING TO CONVINCE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO COME UP WITH THE
IMMIGRATION POLICY.
LET'S HOPE WHAT WE CAN WHO
WEEKEND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RIGHT WELL I THANK EVERYONE WHO
SPOKE AS I THINK I HOPE I HOPE
IS REFLECTED IN.
OUR DISCUSSIONS SO THAT THESE
PROPOSALS -- CLEARLY WE TALKED
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF CAPACITY
BUILDING THE THE THE NEED
PARTICULARLY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THAT CAME OUT THE
PRESENTATION FOR DSS AS WELL AS
OUR CONVERSATION -- CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE USE BEING HERE
AND WENT AND IMPORTANCE OF SUCH
TEACHING THE CIVIC CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT -- TO TO OUR USE AND
APPRECIATE ALL THE TWO CAME AND
TESTIFIED AND HERE'S WELL AND
ALSO -- AND I DON'T FORGET THAT
WE ALSO TALK ABOUT HOW WE GET
PEOPLE ACCESS OTHER SUPPLIES AS
WELL SO -- BUT IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS WE WILL BE PRIORITISING
IN MAY BUT CERTAINLY I
APPRECIATED ONE COMING HERE AND
AND SHARING IS SPEAKING OUT.
SO THANKS VERY MUCH.
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO NOW MOVE ON
TO THE PROPER SOCIAL SERVICES
THE CAL FRESH PROGRAM SO --
BRING UP.
THANK YOU.
FOR I GUESS IT'S SOMEWHAT
APPROPRIATE THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
TALKING ABOUT CAO FRESH ABOUT
LUNCH TIME. EIGHT PEOPLE.
THAT MAY NOT HAVE LUNCH.
SO -- THANK YOU SO LET'S --
AGAIN THIS IS A NEW SECTION SO
WE ASK EVERYONE TO INTRODUCE
HIMSELF THE RECORD SO.
YES THAT'S CAL FRESH.
CAM JOHNSON SOCIAL SERVICES
HELLO ANY BELL L. L..
CHAS OUT OF A WITH THE LA A A
FAILURE WOULD SPUR OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO -- ITEM
NUMBER ONE CO OVERVIEW AND SO WE
CAN START WITH THAT AND I THINK
WE HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS HERE AND
AGAIN WE HAVE A GREAT RIGHT UP
SO WE CAN JUST.
HIT THE HIGHLIGHTS OF OF WHAT'S
GOING ON NOW WHAT YOU SEE IN THE
COMING BUDGET YEAR THANK YOU.
SURE SO THE CALPERS PROGRAM
CONTINUES TO SERVE THREE POINT
EIGHT MILLION CALIFORNIANS EACH
MONTH WITH AN EBT CARD TO HELP
THEM BUY GROCERIES CASELOAD IS
FALLING PARTLY IN RESPONSE TO
THE RECOVERING ECONOMY
UNEMPLOYMENT AND PARTLY IN
RESPONSE OF THE CLIMATE WITH HER
JUST SO MUCH ABOUT.
WITH IMMIGRANTS WE CONTINUE TO
BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH TIMELINESS
AND ACCURACY AND EXPAND OUR
ACCESS ONLINE IN PARTICULAR ON
THE PHONE. THREE HIGHLIGHTS FROM
THE LAST YEAR THREE HEADLINES WE
DID BEGIN IMPLEMENTING THE TIME
LIMITS THE ABOUT TIME LIMITS AND
THREE COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO SANTA
CLARA AND SAN MATTEO.
WE HAVE AGAIN HAD A YEAR
TREMENDOUS DISASTER RESPONSE
PARTICULARLY IN VIEW COUNTY THE
PARADISE FIRE.
AND OF COURSE WE STEPPED UP
DURING A FEDERAL SHUTDOWN THE
ISSUE BENEFITS EARLY IN AN
UNPRECEDENTED.
MANNER.
LOOKING AHEAD THE THE HIGHLIGHT
IS NO DOUBT THE EXPANSION OF
COVERAGE TO SERVE OVER --
MILLION RECIPIENTS ON SSI
BEGINNING JUNE FIRST COUNTING
THE WEEKS NOW TO GET READY FOR
THAT.
BUT THREE MAJOR THEMES FOR THE
YEAR AHEAD ONE CONTINUES TO BE
FOOD FOR ALL MAKING SURE WE HAVE
OUR LANGUAGE ACCESS DISABILITY
ACCESS AND WELCOME IMMIGRANTS.
SECOND CONTINUE TO EXPAND OUR
WORK OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH
EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING AND A
BOAT COMPLIANCE AND LASTLY --
CONTINUING TO IMPROVE THE THE
QUALITY OF OUR PROGRAM WITH THE
GETTING IT RIGHT FIRST TIME
CAMPAIGN SO WE'RE GETTING THE
BENEFITS RIGHT.
A QUICKLY AS ACCURATELY AS WE
CAN.
HE COMES FROM LA -- FINANCE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT -- SO [inaudible]
TAKE CARE.
CAN YOU ACTUALLY IN TERMS OF THE
EXPIRATION OF OF THE GOAT A WHAT
ABLE BODIED ADULTS WITHOUT THE
TENDED SO WITH THAT THE AND SO.
I GUESS WHAT HAPPENED IS IS THAT --
WELL CAN IS SO BASICALLY CAN BE
EXPANDED TO MORE COUNTIES
BECAUSE BECAUSE OF THE RECOVERY
GOING ON WITH COUNTIES WILL BE
WAIVED THAT'S OF YOUR ACCOUNT OF
AND THAT'S A FEDERAL DECISION
RIGHT.
RIGHT IT'S YES SO WE CURRENTLY
HAVE A WAIVER THAT EXPIRES -- IN
AUGUST THIRTIETH THAT THAT
PROTECTS FIFTY FIVE COUNTIES WE
HAVE A WAIVER REQUEST PENDING
FOR THE NEXT YEAR THAT WOULD
HONEST FIFTY TWO COUNTIES AND WE
SHOULD HEAR FROM LAST YEAR WE
HEARD IN JULY BUT WE ARE
REMINDING THEMTHAT WERE WAITING.
HI BUT WE'RE PROCEEDING AS IF WE
WILL HAVE THAT WAY FOR A PLACE
OKAY THE WILD CARD OF COURSE IS
THE FEDS HAVE A PROPOSED RULE
OUT THAT JUST CLOSED FOR COMMENT.
THAT WOULD REALLY RADICALLY
CHANGE THE WHOLE WAIVER
FRAMEWORK SO WE WILL WAIT AND
SEE WHAT THE FINAL RULE IS.
BUT PENDING -- NO CHANGE IN THAT
AND PENDING AT THIS YEAR'S
WAIVERS APPROVED LIKE LAST
YEAR'S WHAT WE WE WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTING THAT TIME LIMIT IN
THE SIX COUNTIES OKAY STARTING
IN SEPTEMBER [inaudible]
AND OKAY AND AND JUST SO WHAT'S
A CASE OF THE DAY THAT VERY
BRIEFLY THAT THAT FEDERAL RULE
CHANGE THAT THEY CLOSE THEM AND
WHAT EXACTLY IS THAT AND WHEN
WOULD THAT TAKE AFFECTED THEY
ACTUALLY WENT THROUGH THAT AGAIN
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FINAL
RULE IS SO.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT SPECULATION
BUT RIGHT TAKING THE LAST
QUESTION WAS PROPOSED A NOTICE
OF PROPOSED RULEMAKING WAS IN
JANUARY AND IF THAT THE PROPOSED
RULE BECAME FINAL AS PROPOSED
WOULD BE OCTOBER FIRST.
THAT SEEMS ON THAT SEEMS VERY
FAST.
GIVEN THAT WILL MAKE IT THE THE
COMMENT PERIOD JUST CLOSE THIS
WEEK BECAUSE OF THE SHUTDOWN
PARTLY BECAUSE OF AN EXTENSION
BUT NONE THE LESS IT COULD BE A
QUITE FAST OUR TIME LINE.
AND IT REALLY CHANGES ALL THE
CRITERIA FOR WAIVER CHANGES THE
ABUSE ONE APPOINTMENT DATA. TO
TO JUSTIFY A WAIVER FROM THE
TIME LIMIT YOU KNOW SUCH A WAY
THAT ALMOST ALL OF CALIFORNIA
WOULD IMMEDIATELY COME OFTEN
NEED TO IMPLEMENT TIME LIMITED
WORK REQUIREMENTS ESSENTIALLY
ESSENTIALLY MOVED INTRSTATE OFF.
YES AND THE OTHER BIG CHALLENGE
FOR US IS WE HAVE A BANK OF OF
MONTHS OF FOOD FROM YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTING THIS THAT WOULD BE
WIPED OUT.
AND SO THAT'S WERE USING NOW TO
HELP FAMILIES AFTER WE MAKE SURE
THEY QUALIFY.
WORK WITH THEM ON EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES WE ALSO HAVE THIS BANK
OF FOOD MONTHS -- THAT WE WOULD
WE WOULD HAVE MORE PEOPLE
EXPOSED TO TIME LIMITS AND FEWER
TOOLS TO HELP THEM.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SOMETHING.
PEOPLE CAN TALK TO THE CONGRESS
BEFORE ABOUT -- AND I SAID SO I
RECOGNIZE THE SSI.
I CASH OUT REVERSAL OR I THINK
WE'LL TRACK OF A DIFFERENT
EXPANSION.
RIGHT EXACTLY.
SO THIS COVERAGE EXPANSION -- I
DID AND I APPRECIATE THE HARD
WORKERS COMP FRESHEN WEARY HEARD
FROM -- FOLKS AT THAT SOCIETY
AND STAND THAT IN GENERAL --
THERE'S ALWAYS THINGS WE COULD
DO A LITTLE BETTER BUT THAT'S
BEEN GOING VERY WELL APPRECIATE
THE WORK ON THAT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT -- OKAY SO LET'S MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO THE BCP
COOPERATION PLAN AND TRAINING
PROGRAM.
SO AS I MENTIONED WE'RE
EXPANDING OUR PLACEMENT SERVICES
OF THIS B. C. P. IS A 100%
FEDERALLY FUNDED BUT IT IS TO
PROVIDE MORE OVERSIGHT OF THE
EXPANSION SERVICES AS DIRECTED
BY USDA.
OKAY ANY COMES FROM OHIO.
WE'VE REVIEWED THE PROPOSAL AND
AS DEPARTMENTS AND IT IS --
FEDERAL FUNDING WEEK WE VIEW IT
IS LARGELY TECHNICAL IN NATURE
OKAY FINANCE THE COMMENTS OKAY.
QUESTIONS I DON'T FEEL RIGHT.
LET'S MOVE ON THEN TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE HUMAN SERVICES
TECHNICAL PCP CALIFORNIA FRUIT
VEGETABLE EBT PILOT.
BUT THIS IS OUR PILOT TO TAKE
BONUS BUCKS WHICH MANY FOLKS CAN
GET AT THE FARMERS MARKET INPUT
ACTUALLY UNDER THE EBT CARD AND
THIS IS A TECHNICAL BCP TO GIVE
US MORE TIME -- TO IT'S UNDER
WAY THE STAKEHOLDERS MET IN --
FEBRUARY TO BEGIN KICK OFF IN
THE ARE OF EXPECT THE R. P. TO
BE OUT THIS SUMMER SO WE'RE ON
TRACK JUST CROSSING TO THE NEW
BUDGET YEARS OKAY ALL RIGHT
COMES FROM ILLEGAL.
FINANCE NOW ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SO BEFORE WE TAKE ON
APPROVALS OF INVESTMENTS -- ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE CAL FRESH.
PROGRAM IS THE OVERVIEW AND THE
TWO ISSUE AREAS THESE COME TO
THE MICROPHONE.
WELL JEFF TORTILLA AND I GET THE
FIRST WORD ON THIS ONE THAT
CLEAN IS A IS A YES BEEN WORKING
ON THIS AND PLEASE ANYTHING WE
CAN DO.
KIM IS BEEN AN OUTSTANDING
ASSISTING IN MAKING SURE THAT TO
UGH STAKEHOLDERS GET HURT
[inaudible]
Q. [inaudible]
IN.
YES.
CALIFORNIA POLICY ADVOCATES
TRACY PATTERSON -- ECHO
CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR THE SSI
ACCOUNT FRESH EXPANSION CAN ON
CONTINUING TO GO ON AND THEN
JUST ON ISSUE THREE ABOUT THE
FROM VEGETABLE EBT PILOT IN
SUPPORT OF THAT B. C. P. -- WE
ARE SOME OF THE MAIN PLAYERS NOT
STAKEHOLDER GROUP AND IT'S BEEN
QUITE PRODUCTIVE WE'RE EXCITED
FOR TO BE IMPLEMENTED A GOING
WELL ALL RIGHT.
ALWAYS LIKE TO HEAR THAT THANK
YOU WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU.
I'M ON NORMAN FRANKLIN AND I
REPRESENT -- OR VOLUNTEER FOR A
A RP.
AND THE FOOD AND SECURITY AMONG
OLDER ADULTS AND ESPECIALLY THE
THE ELDERLY IS IS AN IMPORTANT
SOCIAL AND HEALTH ISSUE THAT I
THINK WE CAN REMEDY IN PART.
BY SIMPLIFYING THE PROCESS FOR
APPLYING FOR IT -- OFTEN
COMPLEXITY IS WHAT IS THE ENEMY
OF THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS.
WE'VE ALSO BEEN TOLD BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
THAT IF WE SIMPLIFY THE PROGRAM
AND GET MORE PEOPLE INVOLVED WE
CAN PROBABLY.
INCREASE CALIFORNIA'S FEDERAL
DOLLARS BY SOMETHING LIKE THREE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS --
WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL FOR A
ONE TIME INVESTMENT FOR THE
DESIGN DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ELDERLY
SIMPLIFIED APPLICATION PROJECT.
THIS WILL INCLUDE IN OUR REGION
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN TO INCREASE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE SIMPLIFIED
CAO FRESH APPLICATION FOR
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. FOR THESE REASONS
AND ON BEHALF OF THE NEARLY
THREE POINT THREE MILLION A A.
R. P. CALIFORNIA MEMBERS WHO
COULD NOT BE HERE IN PERSON
TODAY.
WE STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT YOU
SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM THANK YOU
SO MUCH I THINK YOU AT THANK YOU
AND WE WILL BE HEARING AS A
PROPOSAL INVESTMENT THE S.
SIMPLIFYING SENIOR ACCESS TO
CALL FRESH BUT THE OVERALL
SUPPORT FOR COVERAGE.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
IT COULD EXPAND TEN AND A CHANGE
IN THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS -- DOESN'T WANT TO
THANK ON THE STATE IN THE
COUNTIES FOR THE EXCELLENT WORK
ON THAT COVERS EXPANSION AND YOU
WILL COME TO LEGISLATURE'S
CONTINUED -- ENGAGEMENT ON THAT
OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW IT'S GONNA
IT'S GONNA TAKE SOME TIME BUT
AGAIN EVERYTHING IS.
EVERYONE IS PULLING IN THE SAME
DIRECTION REALLY PROUD TO BE
PART AT A FIRST AND I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS ON
ON A BODY -- CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT DID THAT THE
LEGISLATURE -- DID A LETTER MOST
RECENTLY -- AND AS YOU POINT OUT
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS GOING TO BE A
FEDERAL CHANGE BUT IT WOULD BE
ADDIS THAT'S A CATASTROPHIC IF
IT WERE TO BE PUT IN LAW AS AS
PROPOSED.
SUBZERO ACCORDING TO THAT
ESPECIALLY ON THE EMERGENCY SIDE --
BUT THERE IS A PROPOSAL ALTHOUGH
ON A CHEN DICED -- TO DEVELOP A
STATE BANK -- TO TRY AND IF YOU
WERE TAKEN AWAY A STATE FUNDED
BANK AND SO JUST WANNA CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT ANY
AVAILABLE OPTIONS ON HIS WE HAVE
TO FACE THAT SCENARIO.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY BUT AS A COLUSA CALIFORNIA
WILL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT OF ALL THREE ITEMS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME MEG NATION'S PURPOSES
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
ALL THREE ITEMS.
THANK YOU EXCELLENT.
ALL RIGHT -- SO NO GO HERE
PROPOSAL INVESTMENTS SO.
THEN I GUESS UNLESS WE HAVE MORE
TO SPEAKERS AND ANYONE OF THEM
LIKE WE HAVE THIS TO CHAIR SO
WE'LL START OFF WITH THE CAL
FOOD FUNDING AND WE HAVE -- INJU
CHAINED -- THE PARK OVERSEERS
KHALFAN SOURCES OF FOOD BANKS
AND JENNIFER -- POSSIBLE WAIT
HAVE GOT THAT CORRECT -- SECULAR
FOOD BANK AND FAMILY SERVICES
SEE YOU AGAIN.
ALL RIGHT SO -- OKAY.
BUT BILL SHOP ON THE SIDE THERE
SO OF BETWEEN THE TWO YOU THREE
MINUTES AND IF YOU'VE PROP
QUESTIONS YOU MAY GET CHANCE
TALKING LONGER.
OKAY.
AN INTERCHANGE AND FROM
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS -- WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS PUT SOME SITTING IN
PROPOSALS IN ALREADY AND THE
DENTON BUDGET INCLUDING. EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FOR HEALTH FOOD
IN ADDITION TO TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FOR CAPACITY FOR ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR THE TRUCKS AND
CLOSER TO FOOD BANKS.
DESPERATELY NEED TO TO FEED
THEIR COMMUNITIES -- ARE PROP
THE PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT
TODAY THOUGH IS TO INCREASETHE
CALVET FUNDING -- FROM THE EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR LEVEL TO A TOTAL
OF TWENTY FOUR POINT FIVE SO THE
DELTA BEING SIXTEEN SIXTEEN
POINT FIVE AND ALSO TO RAISE THE
STORAGE AND DISTRIBUTION RATE
FROM 10215%.
THAT'S AND COST SEE ANYTHING
ADDITIONAL WHICH IS JUST GOING
TO BETTER CAPTURE THE REAL COSTS --
TO KEEP THAT FOOD FASHION AND
SAFE THE JEFFERSONS BETWEEN A
MOMENT.
IT IS VERY BRIEFLY ON THE NEED
TO BOLSTER THE EMERGENCY SAFETY
NET EVEN AS WE OBVIOUSLY BELIEVE
THAT CAL FRESH THE OTHER PUBLIC
NUTRITION PROGRAMS ARE BEST
DEFENSE AGAINST HUNGER.
YOU HONESTLY JUST HAD A
DISCUSSION HIT MOSTOF THOSE
THOSE HIGH POINTS IN TERMS OF
THE DISASTER OBVIOUSLY -- IT IS
THE NEW NORMAL WHETHER IT'S
FIRES OR OR FOR FLOODS -- IN IN
CENTER STONE'S DISTRICT AND AN
UNPRECEDENTED FEDERAL THREATS
PUBLIC CHARGE A BUD THE SHUT
DOWN EVEN AN AVERAGE MONTH ABOUT
A THIRD OF CALPERS CLIENTS ARE
STILL COMING TO FOOD BANKS
BECAUSE OF WHO THEN IF IT'S ONE
OUT.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT THAT IS
ONE HOSPITALIZATIONS MIKE WE
HAVE DATA FROM DOCTOR SELIGMAN
THAT SHOW THAT THAT'S THAT'S
WHEN PEOPLE CAN'T TAKE THE
MEDICATIONS AND THEY'RE RELYING
EXPENSES SERVICES SO BY CRYING
NUTRITIOUS FOODS.
SUCH AS TO THE CALVET PROGRAM
REALLY HELPS FILL THAT GAP
RENTALS BECAUSE HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND AND IT NURSES ARE
COMMUNITIES IN NEED THAT BY
GOING TO TWENTY FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION.
FOOD BANKS ON THE STATE CAN
REALLY LEVERAGE OUR ECONOMIES OF
SCALE THAT WOULD BRING A NEARLY
A HUNDRED MILLION MEALS TO THOSE
IN NEED AND WOULD BE MEANINGFUL
STEP TO CLOSE THAT ACCOUNT AND
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M JENNIFER POSTLETHWAITE ON
BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO FOOD BANK
AND FAMILY SERVICES THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME AND
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN FOR YOUR
CONTINUED DEDICATION TO
IMPROVING THE HEALTH OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
SACRAMENTO FOOD BANK AND FAMILY
SERVICES HAS THE PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING THE WIDE EXPANSE AND
DIVERSE POPULATION OF SACRAMENTO
COUNTY INCLUDING MOST OF
DISTRICTS.
SIX RIGHT NOW OVER TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
LIVING IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY ARE
UNSURE OF WHERE THEIR NEXT MEAL
IS COMING FROM.
AND THAT INCLUDES ONE OF EVERY
FOUR CHILDREN.
LAST YEAR'S SACRAMENTO FOOD BANK
AND FAMILY SERVICES PROVIDED
OVER TWENTY ONE MILLION MEALS TO
NEIGHBORS IN NEED.
NEARLY ONE POINT FIVE MILLION OF
THOSE HEALTHY MEALS WERE THANKS
TO TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM CALIPHATE.
CALVET IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT
OF OUR EFFORTS TO FIGHT HUNGER
BUT OUR NEED IS GROWING DUE TO
RISING LIVING EXPENSES POVERTY
IN HOMELESS RATES.
AND THE CLIMATE OF FEAR THAT'S
DRIVING FAMILIES AWAY FROM CAL
FOR ASH.
LAST YEAR'S FUNDS ENABLED US TO
DISTRIBUTE HIGH QUALITY FRESH
FOODS.
GROWN IN CALIFORNIA LIKE
BROCCOLI CABBAGE CARROTS
POTATOES AND SQUASH.
WE COULD TRIPLE BEST A FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION NUTRITIOUS
MEALS OF OUR CALVET REQUEST IS
FULLY FUNDED WITH AN ADDITIONAL
SIXTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
RAISING THE STORAGE AND
DISTRIBUTION RIGHT 215% IS ALSO
VITAL TO OUR FOOD BANK AS THE
CURRENT 10% DOES NOT CAPTURE OUR
COSTS TO STORE AND DISTRIBUTE
THE HEALTHY PRODUCE WHILE
MAINTAINING FRESHNESS AND FOOD
SAFETY.
DOCTOR PAN WE HOPE YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE CAN PRIORITIZE THIS
MODEST FUNDING INCREASES TO MAKE
A MEANINGFUL IMPACT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND AROUND THE STATE.
TO REDUCE HUNGER PREVENT EXPENSE
OF HEALTH CARE COSTS AND HELP
BUILD A MORE EQUITABLE FUTURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE FAR SOCIAL
SERVICES OKAY ALEJO.
FINANCE ALL RIGHT.
OF FIRST OF ALL I WANNA THANK
THE SEGMENT FOOD BANK IN A WE
WORK WE WE WE'VE WORKED TOGETHER
WE STILL WORK TOGETHER ON A LOT
OF ISSUES IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
ADDRESS HUNGER AND I NOTE THAT --
YOUR ORGANIZATION PLAYS A VERY
CENTRAL ROLE IN BE SURE THAT WE
TRY TO MEET THOSE NEEDS --
RECOGNIZING THAT THE NEED IS
VERY GREAT.
WE STILL HAVE A WAYS TO GO TO DO
THAT SO THANK YOU -- SO ACTUALLY
WITH THINGS I DO WANT TO RAMPS
THREE ACTUALLY I WORKED WITH THE
SEGMENT FOOD BANK TO TALK ABOUT
BUILDING THE STORAGE CAPACITY
RIGHT AND SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY GET MORE FRESH PRODUCE
IN FACT I DON'T UNDERSTAND
SECOND FOOD BANK ACTUALLY. TO
CERTAIN DEGREE PAYS FOR SOME OF
THAT PRODUCE TO I MEAN IT'S FOR
IT'S EASY.
TO DONATE A CAN -- IT DOESN'T GO
BAD AND AND SO FORTH IT'S A
LITTLE HARDER TO TAKE AND BUT
THAT'S ALSO THE QUALITY FOOD YOU
WANT TO GET TO THE THE PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY -- SO THAT IT
AGAIN I KNOW YOU CAN'T TAKE A
POSITION I THESE PROPOSALS BUT I
MEAN THIS THIS THOUGHT ABOUT --
BEING AT HAVING -- A HIGHER
PERCENTAGE IN TERMS OF
SUPPORTING THE STORAGE CAPACITY
SO THAT VIçT THESE ARE BECAUSE
OF FOOD BANKS CAN.
CAN ACTUALLY IT -- BUILD THAT
CAPACITY SO.
YEAH WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WE'VE
SEEN THAT INFORMATION FROM THE
SURVEYS OF OUR PROVIDERS OF THE
COST WHETHER IT'S THE COOLING
THE STORAGE RIGHT.
WE'VE SEEN THAT AND WE'RE WE'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT OKAY OUR
IS BECAUSE I THINK THAT I MEAN
THAT SOMETHING ACTUALLY I
ACTUALLY URGED THE SECOND A FOOD
BANK TO FIGURE OUT HOW THEY
COULD BUILD MORE CAPACITY SO I
CAN'T.
HAVE URGED THEM IN AND OUT
HEALTH OUT.
TRYING TO GET SAY OKAY WELL WE
NEED THAT RIGHT THIS IS THE
LEGISLATURE RIGHT SO -- AND THEN
I GUESS THE OTHER -- QUESTION I
HAVE IS NOW IT DOES COME PUBLIC
CHARGE RATE ITSELF.
AND BUT WE LOVE FOR PEOPLE AND
BUT ACTUALLY NOW WOULD WE STILL
WITHIN FORTY WERE STILL ON THE
LOW END ON COVERAGE AND ROMAN
COMPARED TO OTHER STATES RIGHT
AND WE'D LOVE TO GET MORE PEOPLE
ON CAL FRESH IDEALLY.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW SOME PEOPLE ARE
AFRAID TO DO THAT AND WHEN THEY
CAN'T DO THAT.
THEY'RE COMING OVER HERE TO THE
FOOD BANK SO I MEAN IS IS THERE
A WEEK.
AND I KNOW IT'S REALLY HARD TO
DO THIS BECAUSE FIRST OF ALL
THEY DON'T WANT TO TELL YOU THIS
RIGHT.
FIRST PLACE AT IN TERMS OF
QUANTIFYING THIS EFFECT AND AND
THINKING ABOUT -- AT FORTY A
WATER AND SAME WAY WE JUST HEARD
ABOUT IMMIGRATION AND WE NEED
SERVICES A CERTAIN DEGREE
BECAUSE WE CAN'T GET THEM I CAO
FRESH -- THE ROOF RIGHT AWAY
FROM IT THAT WE NEED TO THAN
DIRECT MORE RESOURCES TO OTHER
APPROACH LIKE FOOD BANKS.
I CAN ONLY SPEAK TO THE CAL OF
ACCOUNT FRESH SIDE LET YEAH I
CALLED RIGHT THE BANK SIDE BUT
YES -- WELL CALPERS REMAINS IT
IS NOT A PUBLIC CHARGE AT THIS
POINT AND IF AND WHEN THAT RULE
BECOMES FINAL. FIVE WHICH WAS AS
PROPOSED CAL FRESH FOR SOME
IMMIGRANTS IN SOME CIRCUMSTANCES
NONE THE LESS WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S A CHILLING EFFECT ON AND
IN OUR DATA WE CAN SEE.
THAT BEGINNING IN EARLY.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN CALPERS TRENDS
BY PEOPLE WHO REQUESTED
MATERIALS IN SPANISH CALPERS
CASELOADS ARE FALLING FASTER.
THAN CALPERS TRIMS ALIVE --
CASES OF PEOPLE WHO THEIR
LANGUAGE AND ENGLISH AS A NEW
TREND FOR US AND IT'S CONTINUED
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THROUGH PRESENT SO.
THAT WOULD SUGGEST IN THERE
AGAIN THERE MAYBE DEMOGRAPHIC
REASONS OR OTHER ISSUES AS WELL
BUT THAT DIFFERENCE BY LANGUAGE
SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN SUGGESTS
THERE HAS BEEN A CHILLING EFFECT.
OKAY INCOMES AND WOULD JUST ECHO
THE ACT WITH THE SAME ON THE
ONLY THING WE WOULD SAY IN
ADDITION OR TO IS THAT THERE'S
BEEN SORT OF WAYS AT LEAST ON
THE FOOD BANK SIDE AND SO WHEN
THE THOSE THOSE LEAKS FIRST
HAPPENED.
AND THEN WHEN THE RULES
PUBLISHED YOU KNOW WHEN THAT
SORT OF MEDIA ATTENTION HAPPENS
I THINK WE'RE SEEING IT MORE ON
OUR SIDE BUT AGAIN WE'RE TRYING
TO ASK A FEW QUESTIONS AS
POSSIBLE.
TO KEEP THE SPACE SAFE AND SO
IT'S IT'S MORE ANECDOTAL IN FOR
CENTER SIDE BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING
TO PROTECT.
ANONYMITY PRIVACY SHIRT RIGHT
OKAY.
AND I'M TO SAY IN A RACE THE US
IN TERMS OF SPANISH LANGUAGE I
MEAN DO ABOUT EIGHTY AYE
LANGUAGES.
THE TREND ISN'T QUITE AS CLEAR
WITH AND WE ARE WATCHING THAT AS
WELL WE WE CAN'T COMMUNICATE WE
CAN'T CONCLUDE ANYTHING FROM
THAT YEAH -- BUT THAT'S A
TOUGHIE ON A RADAR AS WELL OKAY
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
ALRIGHT SO NEXT -- POLLS OF
INVESTMENT IS SIMPLIFYING SENIOR
ACCESS CAL FRESH AND WE HAVE
SEIZE SPEAKING AT THAT SAID
TRACY PATTERSON FOR THE PART
DIRECTOR OF ENGAGEMENT STRATEGY
AT CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY
ADVOCATES AND I THINK WARY HEARD
A OR P. SUPPORT FOR THIS
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI SO YES THANK YOU I'M TRACY
PATTERSON OF CALIFORNIA FOOD
POLICY ADVOCATES HERE ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL -- WHICH WE ARE
SUBMITTING ALONG WITH OUR
PARTNERS AT A OR P. OF
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS MANY
LOCAL FOOD BANKS AND ANTI HUNGER
ORGANIZATIONS -- AND SO AS YOU
JUST REFERENCE WHILE CALIFORNIA
LEADS IN MANY AREAS WE HAVE
PERSISTENTLY LAGGED BEHIND THE
NATION WHEN IT COMES TO A
ROLLING.
ELIGIBLE LOW INCOME SENIORS INTO
ACCOUNT FRESH ARE ONLY 20% OF
CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE LOW INCOME
SENIORS GET CAL FRESH THAT DOES
NOT INCLUDE THE SSI CASELOAD
THAT IS THE CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE --
WE ARE CASELOADS HAVE BEEN
GROWING I WANT TO YOU KNOW
COMMEND THE EFFORTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE -- I THINK WHEN WE
LOOK AT IT THOUGH IF WE CONTINUE
AT THIS PACE WILL REACH THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE IN ABOUT TWENTY
YEARS -- AND SO I THINK IF WE
WANT CALIFORNIA TO LEAD WE NEED
TO REALLY LOOK AT THIS WHOLE
PROCESS BOTH WITH US ASIDE
EXPANSION AND FOR THE ENTIRE LOW
INCOME SENIOR POPULATION BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT.
YOU KNOW EXACTLY THE SAME GROUP --
AND SO CDSS HAS PARTICIPATED IN
SOMETHING CALLED THE ELDERLY
SIMPLIFIED APPLICATION PROJECT
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
THAT INCLUDES POLICY TO
STREAMLINE THE ENROLLMENT
RECERTIFICATION PROCESS IT HOUSE
IMMEDIATELY HELP THE SENIORS
WERE ELIGIBLE FOR THAT -- THAT
IS ONLY ELIGIBLE FOR SENIORS WHO
HAVE NO ADDITIONAL INCOME SO
THERE ARE MANY LOW INCOME
SENIORS WHO DO HAVE PART TIME OR
SEASONAL WORK TO GET BY -- AND
SO WHAT WE ARE REQUESTING IS A
ONE TIME INVESTMENT TO IMPLEMENT
A USER CENTERED APPROACH TO A
SIMPLIFIED IMPLICATE APPLICATION
PROCESS WE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF ANY OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THAT TO LOOK AT THE FULL
APPLICATION.
OF SERVE ECOSYSTEM ON BOTH THE
EAST UP SPECIFIC HOUSEHOLDS AND
HOW TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
EVERYONE BECAUSE WE WANT TO
CAPTURE AS MANY SENIORS AS
POSSIBLE.
AND WE HAVE TO GET BE AT BETTER
THAN THE LAST IN THE NATION --
AND WE ALL WANT TO BE ALL HANDS
ON DECK TO DO THAT AND SO WITH
THIS PROPOSAL WE ALSO WANT TO BE
CLEAR THE APPLICATION ITSELF IS
NOT A PANACEA.
ON THIS NEEDS TO BE PART OF A
REIMAGINING OF THE POLICY AND
PROCESS SEES THAT WORK TOGETHER
SO THAT WE CAN MAXIMIZE
ENROLLMENT FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO
REALLY NEED IT AND DESERVE TO
LIVE IN A AGE WITH DIGNITY FREE
FROM HUNGER.
THANK YOU ANY COMES FROM CITY TO
CITY.
NO USER CENTERED DESIGN IS A BIG
BIG PRIORITIES OF OURS AS WELL
AND I THINK WE HAVE -- I WILL
SAY THE DEPARTMENT HAS TAKEN
STEPS THE LAST THREE YEARS FROM
THE FEDERAL PILOT TO THE
EXPANSION OF SSI TO A NEW OUT
REACH CONTRACT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING THROUGH A
LOCAL AREA AGENCIES ON AGING SO
WE ARE.
WE HAVE TRIPLED IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS BUT TROUBLING UP A VERY
SMALL BASE IS NOT -- NOT WHERE
WE NEED TO AND UP SO WE ARE OPEN
AND HAVE BEGUN SOME OF THIS
THREE DESIGN OF OTHER FORMS AND
AGREE IT'S THE SENIORS AND THE
ECOSYSTEM THE NEEDS A FRESH OKAY.
EXCELLENT -- LA YOU.
FINANCE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL A THANK YOU
I MEAN I THINK -- THAN THAT GOOD
SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S ACTIVITY
GOING ON BUT WE NEED MORE RIGHT
YEAH THAT'S WHAT YOU SAY YEAH
AND I WOULD HOPE TO I THINK IN
ON MARCH TWENTY EIGHTH SOARING
ON OR SCIENCE SAWS WE TALKED
ABOUT THE YESGLOBAL AND THE NEW
ONLINE PORTAL.
AND THESE ARE ALL KIND OF MOVING
AND WE WANT THEM TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE INTEGRATED AND
REALLY FEED INTO EASILY.
I MEAN SO SOUNDS LIKE ALSO THE
AGES ARE YOU WORKING OUT SO IS
THERE A AND AND IN RELATION TO
THIS -- PROPOSAL -- THIS
PROPOSAL WHICH YOU KNOW ASK FOR
SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO DO
THIS I MEAN IT IS -- IS THERE
YET AND SO LIKE BECAUSE YOU TALK
ABOUT THE WHOLE ECOSYSTEM RIGHT
SO WE HAVE.
AUTOMATION BOB BLOOD CENTER.
SO ZERO OVERALL.
ECOSYSTEM PLANNER OVERALL PLAN --
YET ANOTHER THIS OR WE KIND OF
LIKE WHAT WE THINK WE HAVE THIS
THING WE'RE GONNA DO WE HAVE A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON SO I'M JUST.
YEAH THAT'S WHAT WE'RE MISSING
OKAY I THINK THE THE
APPLICATIONS HAVE NOT BEEN GIVEN
THE FRESH LOOK THAT YOU WOULD
SEE LIKE IN THE SICKNESS
SIMPLIFIED SINGLE HEALTH CARE
APPLICATION OKAY.
THE CALIBRATION HOW WORKS LOOK
LIKE THEY LOOKED.
I'VE ALWAYS OKAY RIGHT SO HOW DO
WE BRING THAT UP TO A USER
CENTERED USER FRIENDLY AND AND
NOT JUST ON PAPER BUT IN OUR NEW
AUTOMATED RIGHT THOUGHT SO THAT
ALSO IT'S USER FROM THE FOR THE
WORKER.
RIGHT AND IS WELL ON MOBILE
TOOLS SO NHà OF THAT LOOK IS IS
A IS NEEDED OKAY SO THAT'S THE
AND THAT SOUNDS LIKE IT IS
BECAUSE ALSO AS WE'RE DOING THAT
TECHNOLOGY RIGHT IT'S IT'S THE
IT'S NOT ONLY THE I GUESS I WAS
REALLY OR STE CASE WORKER.
INTERFACE IT'S ALSO THE PACE
INTERFACE OF OREGON ALLOW PEOPLE
TO ACTUALLY INPUT INFORMATION --
THINGS ONLINE THAT SAID -- OF
FOR OF OTHERS APPLICATION
RENEWALS ETCETERA WE NEED TO
HAVE.
GOOD INTERFACES AND I THINK ANY
OF US HAVE HAD EXPERIENCE WITH
THAT INTERFACES KNOW HOW
FRUSTRATING THAT CAN BE SO --
THIS SOUNDS LIKE A OVERALL
REIMAGINE LOOKING AT THAT IS
THAN TO GIVEN THE FACT WE'RE
PUTTING IN.
I MEAN THIS IS A ONE MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST THAT WE'RE
PUTTING IN HUNDREDS OF MORTON
MULTIPLE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
INTO AUTOMATION AND OTHER TYPES
OF THINGS.
WE PRICED TO TRY TO GET THAT THE
INTERFACES AND ANY PAPER FORMS
WE SAW REMAINING RIGHT WE'LL BE
TALKING ABOUT CAR CAL WORKS
LATER SO MAYBE.
IT'S ON A I DON'T MAKE IT TOO
BIG BUT NOW THE END OF THE DAY
ABOUT COMMONALITIES RIGHT
BECAUSE NOW THE SOMEONE'S
INTERFACE AND STATE THE USUALLY
A MULTIPLE SERVICES.
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- NUMBER THREE
DISASTER CALPERS AUTOMATION AND
WE HAVE -- FRANK MECCA
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANKS I LOVE HEARING AND IT'S
GETTING.
TODAY FRANK MECCA WITH C. TO BE
THE A AND AND AS YOU KNOW MISTER
CHAIR -- WHEN CALIFORNIA SUFFERS --
A TRAGIC.
DISASTER COUNTY HUMAN SERVICE
AGENCIES BY LAW.
HAVE RESPONSIBILITY FOR MASS
SHELTER IN THE PROVISION OF TO
THE DISASTER BENEFITS INCLUDING
DISASTER CAL FOR ASH.
THAT SYSTEM IS LARGELY A MANUAL
ONE AND WITH THE UNFORTUNATE.
FREQUENCY OF DISASTERS IN OUR
STATE -- THAT LABOR INTENSIVE
MANUAL PROCESS -- IS COSTLY BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY IT DELAYS THE
PROVISION OF EMERGENCY BENEFITS
TO PEOPLE WHO LITERALLY OFTEN
ARE SURVIVING AT LEAST FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME ONLY ON THOSE
DISASTER BENEFITS THAT WE CAN
GET TO THEM.
WHAT'S MORE WHEN PEOPLE AFFECTED
BY DISASTERS MOVE BECAUSE
THEY'VE LOST THEIR PLACE TO
ANOTHER COUNTY.
THAT COUNTY THAT RECEIVES THEM
DOESN'T HAVE ACCESS TO SORT OF
AUTOMATED INFORMATION MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO SERVE THE
NEEDS OF DISASTER VICTIMS ARE
ASK IS.
A ONE TIME NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND WHICH
BECOMES ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
WITH FEDERAL FUNDS ONE TIME --
BUDGET APPROPRIATION TO AUTOMATE
THE DISASTER CAL FRESH PROGRAM
INTO OUR AUTOMATED SYSTEMS OKAY.
COMMENTS FROM LA OF AGENCY FIRST.
WELL I THINK I WOULD ADD IS JUST
IT IF AND WHEN WE DO HAVE A
MAJOR SCALE DISASTER IT MIGHT.
IT'S THE PEACE WE NEED TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN A MILLION TYPE
PERSON RESPONSE LIKE WE'VE SEEN
IN TEXAS AND FLORIDA OKAY.
ALL RIGHT DELEO [inaudible]
LET'S FINANCE.
SO A TWO EIGHTY DIVERT SO.
GIVEN IN THE BACKDROP OF ALSO
WHAT WE'RE DOING SO -- THIS
WOULD BE A STANDALONE IT'S
INTEGRATED INTO THE WE WOULD
ENVISION -- AUTOMATING IT INTO
THE NEW SYSTEM THAT WILL BE OKAY
ALL THE COUNTIES OKAY RIGHT THEN
AND CERTAINLY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT BECAUSE IT WILL
NOT ONLY ARE YOU MOVING MOST
TIME PEOPLE ARE GOING ALONG AND
GRAB MY DOCTOR AND HE MAY BE THE
LUCKY THEY'RE PREPARED RIGHT.
AFTER THAT ALL WE HAD A GAS ON
THE CAMPFIRE.
THE REMARK AMOUNT OF INTER
AGENCY COLLABORATION BY THE PEW
COUNTIES NEIGHBORS TO TRY TO
HELP THEM.
THE RESIDENTS WHO'VE LOST THEIR
HOMES AND WHEN THOSE COUNTIES
THEN TRY TO THE ADJACENT
COUNTIES TRY TO SETTLE THOSE
FAMILIES AND THEY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO A LOT OF THE
INFORMATION SO IT'S IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT IDEAL AND YOU KNOW
MAYBE MAYBE THERE WAS A DAY WHEN
DOING THIS MANUALLY.
BECAUSE DISASTERS WERE FAR LESS
FREQUENT.
WHAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
TOLERABLE BUT IT SEEMS.
ANATHEMA TO WHAT WE WANT FOR OUR
STATE YEAH I THINK I THINK --
AND AND THEN A DISASTER I MEAN
YOU GET ALL THE BASIC
ASSUMPTIONS YOU ASSUME THAT
SOMEONE DOWN THE DOCUMENTATION
BALL ALL THAT MEAN THEM OUT OF
THE THE THE I MEAN THE
INFORMATION GETS DESTROYED AS
WELL AS THE PROPERTY AS WELL AS
SO FORTH SO.
OKAY.
RIGHT VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT AND NOW WE HAVE ITEM
NUMBER FOR A BLOOD INCOME
PARABLE WORK FARE AND WE HAVE --
KEVIN A SLIDING AND WILL COME UP
HERE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
HELLO MY NAME IS KEVIN AS THEY
ARE WITH THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA ROTH RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION.
THIS IS A PROPOSAL FOR A BIRDS.
AND I HAVE A HAND OUT THE
HANDOUT SHOWS A PERSON.
WHO'S HUNGRY AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
THEY BALK TO WAS THE NINETEEN
NINETY SIX WITHOUT ANY
CONSULTATION WITHOUT ANY
HEARINGS.
AND SOMETIME MID MIDNIGHT THEY
JUST BE THAT THIS HAPPENED.
WHAT THEY BOTTLE PROVIDES IS
THAT YOU COULD ONLY GET THREE
MONTHS OF FOOD STAMPS WITHIN A?
THREE YEAR PERIOD.
IN CALIFORNIA THAT WILL AFFECT A
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE.
THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS TO THIS
RULE.
WHICH IS A FEW DISABLED OR YOU
WORKING TWENTY WORK TWENTY HOURS
A WEEK.
AND ONE OF THE EXCEPTIONS IS
DOING SELF INITIATED TO WORK FOR
A IN OUR PROPOSAL.
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO GET THE FOOD STAMPS
BEYOND TWO MONTHS. TO ALLOW THEM
COULD CONDUCT SELF INITIATED
WORK FOR ITS CALL COMPARABLE
WORK FOR A AND WE HAVE A
PROPOSAL.
A PROPOSED.
FORM AND POP ALSO PROPOSED A
LANGUAGE.
HOPEFULLY WE WON'T HAVE ALL OF
THE PEOPLE SUFFERING.
SO THAT'S A PROPOSAL I THINK WE
WERE WE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
MEETING.
ON THE TWENTY THIRD OF A POOL TO
WORK ON THE LANGUAGE AND YOU GET
A HOLD THE SOFA SO WE SHOULD BE
BACK THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT S. ANY ANY COMES FROM
SOURCES SERVICES OKAY ELIA.
FINANCE OKAY YOU GUYS WORKING
TOGETHER WILL START EXCELLENT SO
WE'LL HEAR ABOUT THAT.
OKAY SO NOW WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE FOR PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENTS AND IF ANYONE HAS
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THOSE AND
EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT FOR YOUR
FAVOR ONE OR ONES YOU CAN.
CALL FOR SIGN.
OKAY WELCOME I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MY CAROL WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY OF I
DON'T WANT TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THE
FOR SO I'M GOING.
TO BE WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF ALL
FOUR PROPOSED OKAY THANK YOU
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FRANK
PANCASILA BDA DID OUT.
I THANK YOU -- TREES PATTERSON
CALIFORNIA FOOTBALL YEAH POLICY
ADVOCATES ALSO DITTO AND TO THE
EARLIER COMMENT ABOUT THE ODDS
AND STRENGTHENING THE STATE BANK
AS WELL WHICH I NEGLECTED TO
MENTION.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HI SHANTI PRASADA ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSALS -- ASO
WANTED TO SINGLE OUT TO THE
SIMPLIFIED APPLICATION -- AT
ALAMEDA COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD
BANK WE HAVE A ONE DOZEN STRONG --
CAL FRESH OUT REACH TEAM -- AND
WE ARE OUT IN THE COMMUNITY AND
ROLLING FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE A
YEAR DOING ALL THAT WE CAN AND
STILL IT IS VERY DIFFICULT --
ASPECT TO FOR PEOPLE TO IN
ROLLING HOW FRESH WITH A LONG
APPLICATION ESPECIALLY FOR
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES -- WE PARTNER
CLOSELY CLOSELY WITH SENIOR
CENTERS -- AND WE I HEAR A LOT
FROM SENIORS THAT ALTHOUGH THEY
ARE CAL FRESH ELIGIBLE THEY
DON'T WANT TO GO THROUGH THE
APPLICATION PROCESS -- SO.
WE REALLY SUPPORT THIS BILL IT
SENSIBLE WELL THOUGHT OUT -- AND
TESTED PROPOSAL TO STREAM LINE
CALIFORNIA PUBLICATIONS -- AND
WITH OUR SENIOR POPULATION
INCREASING THIS WOULD REALLY
HELP US THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MIKE
DAVIS AND I'M WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO MARIN FOOD BANK I WANT
TO ECHO ON MY COLLEAGUES NINETY
JUST SHARED ABOUT THE EXPERIENCE
THAT SENIORS HAVE WITH THE
CURRENT APPLICATION WHICH IS
ABOUT EIGHTEEN PAGES.
A SIMPLIFIED USER CENTERED
DESIGN WOULD BE.
REALLY ADVANTAGEOUS FOR THIS
POPULATION -- AND AND I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SUPPORT THE HEALTH
FOOD EXPANSION -- FUNDING AND
THAT WOULD HAVE A HUGE IMPACT ON
OUR FOOD BANK CURRENTLYWE USE
OUR CALVET FUNDING TO PURCHASE
EGGS FOR THE THIRTY THOUSAND
FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE WITH OUR
PANTRY NETWORK -- WE CAN ONLY DO
THAT ONCE EVERY OTHER WEEK AT
THIS POINT I WOULD BE GREAT IF
WE HAD ADDITIONAL FUNDING WE
COULD PROBABLY DO IT EVERY WEEK
THANKS OKAY.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF ALL FOUR MEASURES
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
CARLY SINGLE AT THE FOOD BANK OF
CONTRA COSTA AND SOLANO ECHOING
WHAT MY OTHER FOOD BANK PARTNER
SAYS AROUND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE SIMPLIFIED APPLICATION.
AND ALSO JUST HIGHLIGHTING THAT
A LOT OF SENIOR SAY THAT THE
APPLICATION IS TOO LONG AND TOO
COMPLICATED AND THEN THE ONLY
QUALIFY FOR FIFTEEN DOLLARS IN
BENEFITS.
AND SO BEING ABLE TO SAY WE NOW
HAVE MORE SIMPLIFIED APPLICATION
AND YOU CAN TAKE THOSE FIFTEEN
DOLLARS TO THE FARMERS MARKET
GET THIRTY DOLLARS WORTH OF
PRODUCE THAT BOTH OF THOSE IN
COMBINATION IS A REALLY POWERFUL
INCENTIVE FOR SENIOR SOUTH THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY JACQUI ONE WITH GRACE AND
HELP HAVING CALIFORNIANS WERE OF
ALL THESE PROPOSALS THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO YOU GET BACK YOUR
SOME OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF ALL FOUR OF THE
ITEMS IN IN PARTICULAR WITH CAL
FOR US.
WE KNOW THAT IT'S SUCH A
LIFELINE FOR MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND YOU
MENTIONED THAT THE DESIRE TO GET
MORE PEOPLE AND ROLLED WHO MIGHT
BE ELIGIBLE.
I'M IN ALL OF THESE PROPOSALS
THAT WE JUST HEARD WOULD HELP US
TO GET THERE TO EIGHTY NINETY
MAYBE A 100% ENROLLMENT SOMEDAY
SOINSTRUCTS.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME PATTY PUT IN YOUR FOR
FROM THE CHILD CARE LAWCENTER
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF ALL FOUR
PROPOSALS OKAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME. TO NOT A HALL KERN
ADVOCATE I'M IN SUPPORT OF ALL.
FOUR ESPECIALLY FOR THE ASSIST
SLY APPLICANTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY I SEE NO ONE ELSE AT THE
MICROPHONE -- WE WILL -- THANKS
SO MUCH FOR ALL THE
PRESENTATIONS -- WE WILL HOLD
OPEN.
WELL FOR SIDES OF ONE DAY OF
RENOUNCE THAT WE WERE HOLDING
FOR AND THEN THE THREE POLLS
INVESTMENTS AND WE'RE ALSO
HOLDING OPEN ISSUE TWO AND THREE
AND THEN ALSO THE FOR PROPOSALS
FOR INVESTMENTS AND CAL FRESH SO.
RIGHT THANK YOU SO -- IF THE
MIND WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A TAKE
A FIVE MINUTE STRETCH BREAK AND
SO I KNOW PEOPLE TO SIT HERE FOR
AWHILE AND THEN WE CAN.
WHICH I RESUME WITH CAL WORKS AT
ONE AT ONE O'CLOCK
RESUME HERE
OF MOVING ON TO THE FARM SOCIAL
SERVICES CAO WORKS PROGRAM.
SO -- AGAIN WHEN YOU SECTION SO
WERE EVERYONE IF YOU HAVE EVER
BEEN INTRODUCED HIMSELF TO THE
RECORD AGAIN PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR AFTERNOON ATTACHED
NIKOLAI THE NOON HOUR SOME CHILD
CARE BRANCH CHIEF IN CSS OKAY
FOR JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ARE ELLIE OF SOME OF
THE OIL.
JANIE BELL LA A A FINANCE HER
WAS A FINANCES THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH SO WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH AN OVERVIEW.
CAL WORKS AND AGAIN WE HAVE A
WONDERFUL RIGHT UP AND AT THE
MET THIS IS THE THIRD TIME I'VE
SO IT'S HIT THE HIGHLIGHTS OF
WHAT'S GOING ON NOW AND WHAT WE
SEE COMING UP IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO PAN.
OUT YES OVER THE LAST YEAR SO
WE'VE BEEN REFOCUSING OUR
EFFORTS ON CAL WORKS IN A NUMBER
OF WAYS WE HAVE HAD INCREASES TO
THE COW WORKS THAT BENEFIT
LEVELS AND GRANT INCREASES AS
WELL AS SERVICES -- A NEW DIAPER
BENEFIT HAS BEEN ADDED FOR SOME
OF THE YOUNG PARENTS WITHIN THE
PROGRAM WE HAD EXPANSION TO A
HOUSING ASSISTANCE EXPANDED
ELIGIBILITY FOR HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE AND SERVICES.
AND EVEN ADD THE ADDITION OF A
ONE TIME EDUCATIONAL INCENTIVE
INCLUDED -- WE ALSO HAVE
OBVIOUSLY REPEAL THE REQUIREMENT
FOR FINGERPRINTING -- AND MADE
SOME MODIFICATIONS TO THE
BUDGETING METHODOLOGY WITHIN THE
COW WORK SINGLE ALLOCATION ON
THE ELIGIBILITY ADMINISTRATIVE
SIDE YOU'LL HEAR AN UPDATE IN
JUST A MOMENT ON THE EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES SIDE -- WE'VE ALSO
LAUNCHED OUR TO GENERATION
APPROACH TO HOW WE'RE SERVICING
HOLISTICALLY CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES WITHIN THE PROGRAM
LAUNCHING OUR CAL WORKS HOME
VISITING INITIATIVE WHICH WILL
ALSO SPEAK TO IN JUST A MOMENT --
AND ARE SET TO LAUNCH OUR CAO
WORKS OUT COMES ACCOUNTABILITY
AND REVIEW COMING UP HERE IN
JULY SO -- QUITE A BIT OF CHANGE
IN AND POLICY AND NEW RESOURCES
TO FAMILIES THAT IN MOVING
FORWARD.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET --
INCLUDES -- AND OTHER AN
INCREASE ON TOP OF WHAT JUST
OCCURRED THIS MONTH -- THIRTEEN
POINT ONE INCREASE TO THE GRANT
LEVELS -- WE ARE SEEING A
CONTINUE TO CRIME OR CAO WORKS
CASELOAD AGAIN WILL SPEAK TO
THAT IN JUST A MOMENT.
AT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO --
INCLUDES FULL YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR HOME
VISITING INITIATIVE ALSO MAKING
IT A PERMANENT COMPONENT WITHIN
OUR CAL WORKS PROGRAM.
WE ALSO HAVE ADDITIONAL
EXPANSION TO ASK HOW WORKS
HOUSING SUPPORT SO THOSE ARE ALL
PROPOSALS AT CURRENTLY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND WE'LL GO
INTO THE DETAIL OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT CHAIR AT YOUR PLEASURE.
HE COMES FROM LA -- I FINANCE.
OKAY AND IN TERMS OF SO HE
SHOULD.
HAVE A SEPARATE SECTION.
SO I GUESS AT THE OUT ONE WE YES
I WANT TO GO ON WITH THE OTHER
QUESTIONS HERE.
SO.
THANK YOU CHAIR -- WITH REGARDS
TO THE CASE LOW DECLINES IT
WOULD NOTE THAT THE TENANT
CASELOADS ARE DECLINING
NATIONWIDE AND IN FACT
CALIFORNIA IS ON A MUCH SLOWER
DOWNWARD TREND IN OTHER STATES.
THE CALIFORNIA TEN OF POVERTY
RATE IS THE HIGHEST RATIO
NATIONWIDE BUT MORE THAN A 10%
MARGIN.
MEANING THAT CALIFORNIA HAS THE
STRONGEST DEMONSTRATION OF ANY
PROGRAM IN THE NATION OF
ENGAGEMENT IN SERVING FAMILIES
IN POVERTY.
NEARING FURTHER INTO THE CASE
THAT I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT WE
DO A GOOD JOB OF TOUCHING OF THE
MORE THAN 80% OF CHILDREN'S AND
POP.
EXCUSE ME CHILDREN IMPOVERISHED --
BUT STILL WE WE ALWAYS THINK WE
CAN DO BETTER.
SINCE THE PEAK OF THE COWARDS
CASELOAD AT ALMOST SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND IN JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN JUST AFTER THE GREAT
RECESSION THE TOTAL CASE THAT
HAS BEEN DECLINING ALONG WITH
CALIFORNIA'S IMPROVING ECONOMY.
THE GRANT INCREASES IN IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN
DID SLOW THE NATURAL CASELOAD
DECLINE IN A LOT FAMILIES WHO
EARN MORE INCOME TO STAY IN THE
PROGRAM FOR LONGER. FOR THE
NINETEEN TWENTY GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET CSS PROJECTS THE BASE
CASE LOAD FOR FISCAL YEAR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WILL DECREASE
BY ABOUT 8% [inaudible]
AND THAT.
THE CASE LOAD FOR THE NINETEEN
TWENTY WILL DECREASE BY ABOUT
SIX POINT 9% FROM THAT EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN ESTIMATES.
AS WITH REGARDS THE EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES SPECIFIC CASELOAD --
THAT'S COMPRISED OF ALL THE
ADULTS THAT ARE A CHOIR TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE OFFER TO WORK
ACTIVITIES.
AS WELL AS THOSE WITH WELFARE TO
WORK EXEMPTIONS WERE VOLUNTARILY
PARTICIPATING OF THE NINETEEN
TWENTY GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE
PROJECT -- THE BASE CASE LOAD
WILL DECREASE BY EIGHT EIGHT
POINT 9% FROM THE PREVIOUS
FISCAL YEAR AND THAT THE KIDS
LOOK FOR NINETEEN TWENTY WILL
DECREASE BY SIX POINT 2% FROM
THAT EIGHTEEN NINETEEN ASKED HIM
IN.
WITH REGARDS TO STAGE ONE CHILD
CARE CASELOAD -- WHICH IS
COMPRISED OF THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES WHO ARE WORKING OR
PARTICIPATING OFFERED WORK
ACTIVITIES THIS CASELOAD --
INCLUDES CHILDREN OF CURRENT CAL
RECIPIENTS AS WELL AS THE FORMER
RECIPIENTS AGAIN FOR THE
NINETEEN TWENTY GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET CSS PROJECTS THE BASE
CASELOAD -- WILL DECREASE BY TEN
POINT 8% FROM THE PREVIOUS
FISCAL YEAR AND THAT.
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY OF SIX POINT
2% FROM EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
ESTIMATES SO WE SEE ALL ALL
CASELOADS TRENDING DOWN.
AND JUST I MEAN -- AND DISTRICT
WEEKLY IS.
IN TERMS OF A POTENTIAL
RECESSION THIS IS BE OF THE LONG
EXPANSION.
WHILE I WAS A IN HISTORY BUT
BEEN THE STORY ALONG THIS IS
WHAT'S THE HOUSEHOLD ROBUST AS
THIS IN THE FACE OF A POTENTIAL
RECESSION.
THE CASELOAD DECREASE.
ELIO YOUR COMMENT ABOUT THAT.
SO AT THIS POINT I THINK OUR
OFFICE AND TO MYUNDERSTANDING
THE ADMINISTRATION AS WELL
BELIEVES THAT THE ECONOMY WILL
CONTINUE TO EXPAND BUT CERTAINLY
ECONOMIST AND OTHERS HAVE RAISES
CONCERN ABOUT THE LENGTH OF THE
THE EXPANSION OUR MODELS AND I
BELIEVE THE ADMINISTRATION'S AS
WELL.
ANTICIPATE THE CONTINUED
EXPANSION SO THESE DECLINES IN
THE CASE OF A REFLECTIVE OF THAT
BUT ANY CHANGE IN THE ECONOMY
HIGHER UNEMPLOYMENT RATES WOULD
LIKELY RESULT IN A SORT OF
REVERSING THAT TREND IN THE IN
THE TOWERS CASE SO AS WE SAW ON
DURING THE LAST RECESSION.
ALL RIGHT WELL I I GUESS IN
TERMS OF PARTICULARLY IN YOU
KNOW WE'LL TALK ABOUT SINGLE
APPLICATION FORM SUPPORT THIS --
I GUESS TO A LITTLE BIT OF A
THINKING ABOUT ARE THE OTHERS
LEVEL RESILIENCE WERE BUILDING
AND RIGHT IN TERMS OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE -- IT BECAUSE
AGAIN WE DON'T KNOW WHEN THE
NEXT THURSDAY -- WE CAN MODEL IT
AND WILL IT'S LIKE PREDICTING
THE WEATHER AND WE GET BETTER
AND BETTER AT IT BUT STILL
THINGS HAPPEN AND SO I JUST
WANNA BE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
RESILIENCE JUST.
KEEP IN MIND THAT YOU KNOW I SEE
THESE CONTINUE DECREASES AND I
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT HAPPENS --
BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T PEOPLE ARE
NOW LEAVING POVERTY AND NOT
NEEDING THAT TENNIS THAT THE
SUPPORT BUT AND AT THE MADAME
GET ALONG ANXIOUS ABOUT WHETHER
YOU KNOW IF IT DOESN'T FALL.
AT OUR PREPAREDNESS FOR THAT NOW
SO.
IF IF I MAY ADD A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT THINGS ONE WITHIN THE
NEW REVISION SOURCING ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY ON ELIGIBILITY
ADMINISTRATION WE DID.
BUILD IN THE CONCEPT OF HAVE
KIND OF THAT CASE LOAD AT BANDS
THAT -- IF THE CASE LOAD SHOULD
DROP AS SIGNIFICANT OR INCREASE
SIGNIFICANTLY OTHERS ONLY ONE
INCREMENTS THAT CAN BE PASSED
THROUGH WITHIN A GIVEN YEARS AS
PROVIDING SOME STABILITY FOR
COUNTY STAFF ACT THAT COULDN'T
RAMP UP IF IN IT IN THE CASE OF
A SIGNIFICANT RECESSION WITH THE
HIGHER CASELOAD IN.
THE SAME ISSUE WITH CONTINUE
DECLINED SO THAT'S THAT THAT'S
WHEN IT JUST MEANT WE MADE THAT
WOULD KIND OF BILLS AND I THINK
THAT SAFETY NET WHICH YOU'LL
HEAR MORE ABOUT JUST A MINUTE IS
ANOTHER COMPONENT OF THAT TO TRY.
TO BE PREPARED IN THE CASE OF A
FEATURE RECESSION.
ALL RIGHT SO WHAT WELL CENTURY
TOUCHING ON SINGLE APPLICATION
WHAT'S THE STATUS AT WHERE ARE
WE GREAT YEAH THE EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES SINGLE OCCASION FUNDING
METHODOLOGY REVIEW AND AND
MODIFICATION IS UNDER WAY THIS
PROCESS LIKE THE PROCESS TAKEN
ON LAST YEAR FOR ELIGIBILITY
ADMINISTRATION WILL OCCUR IN
STAGES FIRST FOCUSING.
ON THE CASE MANAGEMENT ASPECTS
AND THEN LATER ON THE SERVICES
SIDE SO THE STATE IS CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH C. B. AND OTHE
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVISE THAT
METHODOLOGY -- AND WE WANT ONE
THAT BETTER REFLECTS AND THE
DEMANDS THE COUNTIES REALLY
FACED WITH REGARDS TO PROVIDING
MEANINGFUL CASE MANAGEMENT AND
SERVICE REYES TO A BROAD
SPECTRUM OF CASE TYPES.
OF THE UPDATED METHODOLOGY WILL
REFLECT WHAT IS NEEDED TO SERVE
THAT FULL SPECTRUM OF CASE TIMES
WITH APPROPRIATE FUNDING.
HOUSE OF FOLLOWING CASE
MANAGEMENT THE DEPARTMENT IN
STAKEHOLDERS WILL REVIEW THE
SERVICES PERSONAL METHODOLOGY TO
DESERVE WHAT ADDITIONAL EXCUSE
ME TO DETERMINE WHAT ADDITIONAL
ADJUSTMENTS MIGHT BE NEEDED.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS WE'RE
HOPING TO COME TO AGREEMENT ON
FINAL AGREEMENT ON THE
METHODOLOGY SOON.
THERE WILL BE SOMETHING IN THE
MAYOR VISION OKAY WE'RE HAVING
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS IN CONTINUING.
TO WORK TOWARDS THAT OKAY I LIKE
THAT IDEA.
OKAY AND IS IT IN THIS THAT THAT
SORT OF BECAUSE WE KNOW WE TOOK
A ONE PIECE EARLIER SO THAT.
THAT KIND OF ADDRESS THE ZERO I
THINK THAT THAT SINGLE
ALLOCATION ARE ARE.
THE CHARGE WAS TO START WITH L.
G. BUT THAT'S KIND OF HOW WE
FACE DEBATE ELIGIBILITY
ADMINISTRATION WE'RE NOW AT
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AND AS MR
MAGNESS NIKOLAI POINTED OUT
WE'RE TAKING THAT AND PHASES SO
WE'RE RIGHT CAN'T CASE MANAGER
IN THE WILL TURN TO SERVICES.
I THINK THE OTHER THING THAT WE
ARE MINDFUL OF IS THAT WE ARE
ALSO MAKING SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
TO WHAT WE KNOW YIELDS THE BEST
SUCCESS FOR THE COW WORKS
PARTICIPANTS WITH OUR CAL OR
INITIATIVE WHICH YOU'LL HEAR
ABOUT IN A MOMENT SO.
AS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT WHAT IS
THAT CASE MANAGEMENT WHAT IS
THAT SERVICE TO RAY OUT WILL
NEED TO CONTINUE THINKING
THROUGH HAT WHAT THE IMPACT OF
ANY REVISION IN AT THE
METHODOLOGY IS OVER TIME.
AS WERE EVEN CHANGING AND
EVOLVING IN THE PROGRAM OKAY BUT
THAT SOUNDS LIKE TO ME.
IN TERMS OF THE THAT METHODOLOGY
WERE PRETTY CLOSE I MEAN IT OVER
YOU CAN JOIN TO OF ALL BUT WE'RE
PRETTY CLOSE TO SENSUALLY
ADDRESSING AT LEAST THE FIRST
ITERATION FROM WHAT WE
PREVIOUSLY BEFORE SAID IT WAS A
STRAIGHT LINEAR DIDN'T TAKE OUT
FOR COSTS FIXED COSTS OR
SOMETHING.
OKAY.
WE GIVE THE WELL FOR DIRECTORS
LACKEY OKAY I LAKE AREA IT'S NOT
FROWNING THAT'S ALWAYS GOOD NEWS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
WELL I I DO HAVE I DID I DO YOU
JUST HAVE TO SAY THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT'S
GONE INTO THIS -- MY AND I
REMEMBER BEING HERE SAYING WE
NEED TO GET THIS THING FIXED AND
SO I APPRECIATE PEOPLE PUTTING
OUT -- NOW PUTTING THE WORK AND
EFFORT INTO INTO MAKING THIS
HAPPEN -- AND SO THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- ALWAYS KEEP GOING
E. ID INCREASE STORY.
QUESTION.
FOUR THANK YOU IS SIMPLE ANSWER
HERE THE DEPARTMENT WOULD
EXPECTED THIS PROPOSAL THAT ANY
PROPOSAL TO IN TO INCREASE OR
CHANGE THEIR YEAH I DO YOU WOULD
ALSO.
SUPPORT INCREASE FOR
PARTICIPATION RATES.
AND CALOR CONTRARIA CALOR SO
CALOR IS A DISTINCT MOVE AWAY
FROM THIS OLD WORK FIRST
MENTALITY IN HISTORIC EMPHASIS
ON THE W. P. R. WHICH IS THE
SINGLE.
FEDERAL MEASURE -- AND A POOR
PROXY IT BEST IN A PERVERSE
INCENTIVE AT WORST THAT
PREVIOUSLY DROVE ALL THE
DECISIONS MAKING REALLY FOR
CARRIAGE PROGRAM DESIGN
IMPLEMENTATION.
ALSO CAL OR REPRESENTS A
CRITICAL PATH FORWARD IN MY IN
MY OPINION FROM IN THE STATE'S.
FOR STANDING BY A MESSAGE OF
ENGAGEMENT AND REALLY CLIENT
CENTERED PROGRAM -- WHICH
INTENTIONALLY SERVERS CLIENTS
AND MEET SOMEWHERE THERE AT ALSO
HUNDREDS OF STAKEHOLDERS REALLY.
HAVE WORKED FOR OVER EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AND THREE MORE THAN FIFTY
MEETINGS TO CRAFT A FRAMEWORK
FOR THE CAL OR CULTURE SHIFT
REPRESENTING A MOVE TOWARD
CONTINUOUS QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
AND REAL MODEL FOR DATA DRIVEN
PROGRAM MANAGEMENT FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
US THE STATE AND STAKEHOLDERS OF
WORK VERY HARD TO DEFINE AND
DEFIES THROUGH THE THREE
COMPONENT PARTS.
IN STATUTE FOR CAL OR AND I'M
HAPPY TO LET YOU KNOW THAT THEIR
NEARLY FINALIZED IN PREPARATION
FOR THE JULY TWENTY NINETEEN
LAUNCH.
SO PART ONE IS A SET OF TWENTY
SEVEN PROCESS SHORT TERM MEDIUM
TERM.
AND LONG TERM METRICS THAT
REFLECT THE COW WORKS PROGRAM
LOGIC MODEL.
PART TWO OF THAT IS A COUNTY
SELF ASSESSMENT WHICH IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR COUNTIES TO
REALLY DIG INTO THOSE METRICS
AND REFLECT.
A GATHERING LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS
IN CONVERSATION AND
INCORPORATING ADDITIONAL CLIENT
FEEDBACK THROUGH A NEW CUSTOMER
SATISFACTION SURVEY.
THIS WILL ALLOW THE LOCAL NEW
ONES PROGRAM DESIGN INNOVATIONS
TO REALLY DRIVE THAT SPIRIT OF
CONTINUOUS QUALITY IMPROVEMENT.
ON UPDATED PROGRAM MANAGEMENT
MODEL.
THREES A SYSTEM IMPROVEMENT PLAN
WHICH CAPTURES COUNTY GOALS FOR
INNOVATIONS THOSE TWO WEEKS AND
STRATEGIES THAT WILL HELP US TO
BETTER SERVE THE COVERAGE
PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS.
COUNTIES WILL CONNECT WITH OTHER
COUNTIES THROUGH THAT PROCESS IN
PEER SUPPORT -- IN REVIEW OF THE
SYSTEM IMPROVEMENT PLANS IN THE
STATE WILL PARTNER WITH COUNTY
THROUGHOUT ALL THREE OF THESE
PHASES.
OUT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING COACHING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
HELLO OR SENT TO LAUNCH LIKE I
NOTED ON JULY TWENTY NINETEEN
WITH THE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATA
DASHBOARD INFORMATION AVAILABLE
IN THE DASHBOARD WILL BE UPDATED
WITH NEW METRICS IN PHASES AS
THEY BECOME AVAILABLE IN OUR
AUTOMATED.
AND THEN ON A REGULAR RULING
BASIS MONTHLY IN.
WORKING WITH C. WTA AND THE
CONSORTIA AS WELL AS OUTSIDE
PARTNERS TO REALLY TACKLE THE
LIMITATIONS AND GENERALLY CREATE
A WHOLE NEW SYSTEM FOR DATA
DRIVEN APPROACHES WEREN'T NONE
HAS EXISTED.
THE FIRST COUNTY CSA WILL BE
DRAFTED THE SPRING OF TWENTY
TWENTY AND THE FIRST STEPS WILL
BE.
DRAFTED TO IN THE WINTER TWENTY
TWENTY TO SPRING [inaudible]
TWENTY TWENTY ONE OUR
APPLICATION HAVE LIPSKY BROWN TO
THE QUESTION.
SO -- IN TERMS OF THE
APPLICATION HAVE THE AGAIN AT
BOTH THE CAL WORKS IN CALPERS
PROGRAMS -- WERE PART OF A
PROCESS TO LOOK VERY CLOSELY AT
HOW DO YOU IMPROVE.
VERIFICATIONS FOR PARTICIPANTS
AS WELL AS FOR THE COUNTY STAFF
WHO ARE WORKING THROUGH THIS
VERIFICATION PROCESS SEES SO WE
ENLISTED SOCIAL INTEREST
SOLUTIONS AS THE VENDOR TO YOU
AT PROVIDE A ROAD MAP I IN A
PLAN AND THEY UNDERTOOK A NUMBER
OF FOCUS GROUPS -- INTERVIEWS
AND SITE VISITS ACROSS THE STATE
HAD TO REALLY TRYTO IDENTIFY
WHAT TYPES OF SOLUTIONS WOULD
SUPPORT VERIFICATION THE
APPLICATION HUB WAS ONE AND
SEVERAL DIFFERENT
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE MANY RELATED
TO POLICY ALIGNMENT -- WAYS TO
REDUCE THAT PAPERWORK -- AND ADD
A STREAMLINED.
PROCESSES SUCH AS SCANNING
INFORMATION AND COUNTY SOCIAL
SERVICE AGENCIES LOBBIES THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS SO -- WE ARE
JUST AT THE POINT WHERE WE ARE
IDENTIFYING OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
BROUGHT FORTH IN THAT REPORT
INCLUDING THE HAVE HOW WE WILL.
MOVE FORWARD TO PURSUE THOSE AND
AS WE ARE IDENTIFYING THOSE WILL
AGAIN ENGAGING STAKEHOLDERS TO
HELP US ALONG THE WAY.
AND THEN -- THAT CHANGES THE
CITY A RESERVE.
THAT FINANCE SURE SO I CAN KIND
OF EXPLAIN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
THINKING ON THIS PROPOSAL ON
THAT WAS GENERALLY THAT.
WE CAME TO AN UNDERSTANDING THAT
WE WANTED TO APPROACH A RESERVE
MORE NIMBLY AND CAME UP WITH THE
IDEA THAT I WE DESCRIBED A
METHODOLOGY AROUND PUTTING
FUNDING.
INTO THE RESERVE AND PULLING
FINDING OUT DURING A RECESSION.
IT MIGHT OVERLOOK HOW UNIQUE
SUMMER SESSIONS ARE COMPARED TO
OTHERS.
AND WHAT THE MEDI CAL AND CAL
WORKS PROGRAM LOOK LIKE IN TERMS
OF SERVICE TYPES AT THAT POINT
IN TIME.
A CASELOAD LEVELS AND
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THIS CASE LOADS.
SO WE THOUGHT THAT BY REMOVING
THAT METHODOLOGY THAT WOULD FREE
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. TO HAVE A MORE
FLEXIBLE APPROACH TO ADDRESSING.
WHAT FUNDING NEEDS TO GO INTO
THE PROGRAM WHEN IT DOWNTURN
OCCURS?
AND THE FULL INTENT IS TO STILL
KEEP THAT FUNDING SPECIFICALLY
FOR THE COWARDS AND MEDICAL
PROGRAMS [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY -- SO ANY COMMENTS FROM LA
ABOUT ANY OF THESE OTHER -- ALL
THE ITEMS THAT.
SURE I'LL SPEAK -- SPECIFICALLY
TO THE THE RESERVE A CENTRAL
CHANGES THAT THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED.
AS PART OF UP AS PART OF THIS
BUDGET ON THE MAIN DIFFERENCE IS
JUST THE SORT OF STEP BACK ONE
STEP IS THAT.
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
ACTS -- AND RELATED LEGISLATION.
INCLUDED SUB ACCOUNTS WITHIN THE
SAFETY NET RESERVE ONE EACH FOR
CAL WORKSAND MEDI CAL AND SO.
THERE WAS SORT OF FOR A FIRE
WALL.
STATUTORY.
BUT NONETHELESS A FIREWALL
BETWEEN THE TWO PROGRAMMERS ARE
ACCOUNTS ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED TO ELIMINATE THAT AND
TREAT THEM AS SORT OF IN A
SINGLE BUCKET TOGETHER -- WE
THINK THAT THAT MIGHT.
ALLOW THE LEGISLATION
ADMINISTRATION SOME ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY IN THE FUTURE -- BUT
IT'S NOT AS THOUGH THE EXISTING
STATUTORY.
SUB ACCOUNTS STRUCTURE.
SORT OF ELIMINATED THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO SHIFT FUNDS BACK AND FORTH.
DEPENDING ON ITS NEEDS BECAUSE
IT COULD CHANGE LAW UPPER
STATUTE.
AND THEN SECONDLY.
THE FORMULA DRIVEN APPROACH THAT
WAS -- SWIFT.
RECOMMENDED OR OR THAT WAS --
INCLUDED IN THAT THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT RELATED
LEGISLATION -- DEPARTING FROM
THAT MY ALSO ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SORT OF AS
THE THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
MENTIONED -- SPECIFIC
DETERMINATIONS DEPENDING ON
WHERE YOU ARE IN THAT THE
BUSINESS CYCLE OR OR THE COW
WORKS CASELOAD THAT MIND ALLOW --
SOME ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY SO
WE CAN MAKE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS ON EITHER OF
THOSE TWO PROPOSALS.
REGARDING THE FORMULA DIFFERENT
APPROACH WE WE DID POINT OUT
THAT ONE ALTERNATIVE MIGHT BE
SORT OF A COMPROMISE -- TO
INCLUDE AS PART OF THE THE
BUDGET CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE EACH YEAR.
AN INDICATION OF WHAT THE CASE
LOAD SAVINGS ARE IN A IN DOLLAR
TERMS IN THE COW WORKS PROGRAM
FROM ONE YEAR TO THE NEXT AS THE
CASE LOADS DECLINING AS IT IS
NOW.
AND SORT OF HIGHLIGHTING ARE
ELEVATING THAT NUMBER AS PART OF
THE BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS ALLOWING
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE.
TO SEE THAT NUMBER NEGOTIATE
SAID A PORTION OF IT BE
DEPOSITED IN THE RESERVE AND
DIFFERENT PORTION BE USE FOR FOR
OTHER PROGRAM PRIORITIES --
WITHOUT THIS IS SORT OF A WAY TO
KEEP THAT FRONT AND CENTER IN
THE CONVERSATION.
SO WHAT I GUESS IN TERMS OF THE
SAFETY NET RESERVE -- AGAIN NICE
THAT THOUGH I WOULD THE
ULTIMATELY THE FOR TO OUR
BUDGETARY WHO CONCEIVED OF THE
RESERVE BUT I WOULD -- SAY AT
LEAST IN MY MIND -- AND NOW WE
TALK ABOUT THE LANGUAGE SO FORTH
SO.
RIGHT.
IT'S SO IT'S A CERTAIN EXTENT OF
FLEXIBILITY IS GOOD I MEAN AFTER
ALL -- NOW WE MAKE DECISIONS AND
HAVING MORE FLEXIBILITY -- AND
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WE DON'T
HAVE FLEXIBILITY BUT I. SO WOULD
BE SURE WE PROTECT THE INTENT OF
THE SIX THAT RESERVE AT LEAST IN
MY MIND THAT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
FIRST OF ALL.
THAT WERE.
AND THAT THE PURPOSE OF THE
RESERVE IS IS THAT DURING
ESPECIALLY DURING A DOWNTURN
THAT WE MAINTAIN AT LEAST UNTIL
THE RESERVE IS EXHAUSTD THE THE
THE SAME LEVEL OF BENEFITS AND
THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM AND
MEDICAL PROGRAM FOR
BENEFICIARIES RIGHT FOR THE
PEOPLE RECEIVING THAT THEY
SHOULD.
THAT EXISTS BECAUSE THEY TEND TO
COUNTER CYCLICAL.
YOU'RE LIKELY GET CUTS RIGHTS --
BECAUSE OF THAT THAT WE SHOULD
DO THAT THAT'S PART THE PURPOSE
RESERVE THE EVEN THAT OUT.
I WOULD ALSO PRICE SAY THAT --
IN ALSO TO VOICE A PLANTATON TO
SO WHAT HAPPENED IS THAT I MEAN
I COULD SEE EVEN GOOD TIMES ON
SAYING -- YOU KNOW LOOK WE ARE
MEETING -- TO TAKE OUT THE
RESERVE AND WE CAN.
MOVE MONEY SOMEWHERE ELSE SO
THAT OBVIOUSLY IS NOT THE
PURPOSE OF THE THE THE THE
RESERVE AS WELL IS TO BASICALLY.
ALLOW IT'S NOW I REALIZE THAT
ANY FUTURE LEGISLATURE OR
GOVERNOR BECAUSE IT'S NOT THE
CONSTITUTION CAN EVENTUALLY DO I
REALLY WANT THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AT ALL CHANGES BUT BUT
I I THINK THAT AT LEAST IN MY
MIND CONCEPTUALLY -- DOWN THAT
THE TOURNEY LOOK AT EXACTLY
LANGUAGE I THINK THAT'S PLACE TO
ME THAT'S WHAT SHOULD BE IS THAT.
YOU KNOW IF YOU LOOK AT PRIOR
YEAR AND YOU SAY WELL YOU KNOW
WE'RE LOOKING AT MAKING -- AND
THAT EVEN IF WE PUT THE SAME
LEVEL RESOURCE FOR SUSTAINING
WERE NOT SO SO WE'RE NOT
SUPPLANTING IN OUR PREVIOUS
YEARS EFFORT.
AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO STILL
MAKE CUTS TO BENEFITS FOR THOSE
PEOPLE WE GO THAT'S WHEN WE
START DRYING DOWN FROM THAT
AFETY NET RESERVE.
NOT BEFORE AND BUT THAT'S A
PURPOSE AND ONLY FOR THAT
PURPOSE SO AND CERTAINLY HAS
MANY OTHER WORTHY ITEMS AND
BUDGETS BUT IS.
I MEAN THAT'S HOW I SEE IT.
ANY THOUGHTS FROM FINANCE.
SURE AND AND I THINK THAT THAT
THE A LOT OF THE ORIGINAL INTENT
YOU SPOKE OF HIS STILL.
PRESERVED IN THAT LANGUAGE THAT
THE FINDINGS DEDICATED FOR THOSE
PURPOSES FOR THOSE PROGRAMS --
HI BUT NOT NOTED ON HOW THE
COUNTER CYCLICAL -- NATURE OF
RECESSIONS NEEDS TO BE FACTORED
IN TO HOW WE APPROACH USING
THOSE RESERVE FUNDS.
AND I I THINK OUR PROPOSAL
ALLOWS US TO LOOK AT THAT AT
THAT POINT IN TIME AND MAKE
THOSE DETERMINATIONS ALONG WITH
THE LEGISLATURE SO I THINK
WHAT'S IMPORTANT IN ANY WHATEVER
LANGUAGE WE PUT IN RECOGNIZING
BE CHANGED BY ANY FUTURE LET'S
SURGERY GOVERNOR IS TO CLEAR TO
CLEARLY.
STATE WHAT OUR DESIRE -- YOU
KNOW I THINK IT NEEDS A
DIFFERENT KIND OF CONVERSATION
WHEN ONE HAS TO CHANGE THAT
LANGUAGE.
IF YOU PUT IN THAT LANGUAGE THAT
AND TO AND SIMPLY SAY WELL SOME
LEGISLATURE SOME THAT AND THEN
WE JUST GOT LEFT A BLANK THERE
SO I'M HOPING THAT IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS WE WILL HAVE SOME
LANGUAGE TO VERY CLEARLY
DESCRIBE WHAT IS THE INTENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR.
NOW FOR THIS RESERVE SO THAT --
THE RESERVES USED IMPROPERLY AND
CERTAINLY AGAIN ANY FUTURE
LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR CAN.
MAKE OTHER DECISIONS AND OKAY.
ALL RIGHT OKAY SO WITH THAT -- I
KNOW WE HAVE SOME PARENTS WHO
WANT TO SPEAK ABOUT STAGE ONE
AND THEY NEED TO GO SHORTLY SO I
THINK WHAT WILL TAKE -- IT'S
ONLY TAKE PUBLIC COME BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY PRESENT THAT I'D.
SENT YOU CAN GET GUYS SO YOU CAN
GO AHEAD AND DO THAT NOW WILL
HERE -- ITEMS -- ISSUE NUMBER
TWO SO THANK YOU WELCOME.
I MEAN THIS MONEY.
ON THE INVOICES ARE TO GO
CHAPTER OF THE THANK YOU -- FOR
SENATOR OF HIM FOR DOING THAT --
RIGHT NOW I WANT TO ASK A MIGHT
ASK IS THAT I WANT TWELVE MONTHS
ELIGIBILITY FOR STAGE ONE CHILD
CARE -- I THINK BASICALLY WHAT
WE HAVE STAGE ONE FROM DAY ONE
PARENTS SLICE ARE DIFFERENT.
I KNOW MY LIFE WOULD BE
DIFFERENT WILL BASICALLY
HAPPENED TO ME IS BECAUSE MY
CASH A BENEFIT MY TALKING ABOUT
IF IT DID NOT START THE SAME
TIME.
AND THEY WERE ACTUALLY SEPARATED
BY WITHIN TWO TO THREE MONTHS OF
EACH OTHER I WITH I LOST MY JOB
SO I WAS ABLE TO GO BACK TO THE
JOB AFTER I GAVE MY PARTS OF MY
BABY.
IF I HAD STAGE ONE FROM DAY ONE
AND I HAD A STRONG START.
THE I WOULD HAVE NOT BE HERE
RIGHT NOW TELL YOU THAT I'M
STILL UNEMPLOYED.
I WOULD HAVE GOT IT OFF THE CAL
WORKS AND I WOULD BE WORKING IN
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
IT'S ARE REALLY WHAT THE SADDAM
EVER HAPPENED TO THE OTHER PAIR
LIKE ME YOU REALLY HAVE.
A HUGE HUGE HUGE OF THOSE THAT
YOU CAN TAKE CARE OF RIGHT NOW
THREE SURE ABOUT WHAT OTHER
PARENT.
THIS IS OUT OF THEIR CHILD CARE
BECAUSE MY STORY IS NOT UNIQUE
IT'S ACTUALLY VERY COMMON OTHERS
MANY OTHER PARENTS JUST LIKE BE
WHO UNEMPLOYED YOU DON'T WANT TO
BE BUT THEY DID GET STAGE WITH
TODAY WOULD. TO PLEASE MAKE THAT
HAPPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
SO JUST A QUICK COMMENT SO THAT
IF YOU DON'T MIND I'VE GOT LOTS
OF THE PARENTS GO FIRST AND THEN --
THEN WE'LL GET BACK TO REGULAR
PUBLIC COMMENTS THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LOWER THIS ARE
GONNA MUST FROM SAN FRANCISCO
AND I'M HERE.
TO TESTIFY ABOUT ALL THESE YEARS
THAT I SUFFERED THROUGH ALL
THESE PROGRAMS LIKE FINGERPRINT
BEING THEY FOUND ONE CASE AND
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF MONEY.
BY TRYING TO FIND SOMEBODY IS TO
TAKE IN THEIR LIVES WHICH IS NOT
TRUE WE'RE LIKE FAMILIES IN NEED
AND MOSTLY IN THE SYSTEM.
OUR WOMEN AND CHILDREN SO WE'RE
NOT ONLY ONE AND THAT. TWELVE
MIND ELIGIBILITY BECAUSE I'D
BEEN REPORTING EVERY QUARTERLY
MIGHT INCOME I NEED TO GET THE
PAPERWORK GETS LOST.
AND THIS IS LIKE A NIGHTMARE AND
I WISH LIKE.
LIKE MIGHTY.
I WITH THESE WILL BE GONE FOR
FAMILIES IT'S TIME TO MAKE IT
BETTER AND WE KNOWN THERE IS A
PRODUCTION FOR A RECESSION BUT
THERE IS ALSO THE THE NEEDLE
FAMILIES LIKE THIS MORNING WE'RE
LISTENING TO ALL THE STORIES.
THESE YOUNG CHILDREN DID THEIR
SONS AND DAUGHTERS OF ALL.
OF A DOLLARS WENT DOWN KIM CAME
BE GOOD PROFESSION ARE GOOD
PEOPLE AND SO THESE THESE
CHILDREN HAPPEN AGAIN.
AND BY SUPPORTING THE 12-1
ELIGIBILITY AND THAT THE POLICE
DID HELP TO FAMILIES IT WILL GET
THESE.
THIS IS A BETTER AGAIN THANK YOU
AND WE ARE LIMITING THE
FINGERPRINTING.
YES THAT THAT'S A THAT'S SHOULD
BE GOTTEN YES.
ALL RIGHT HI MY NAME IS JOAN
ALLEN WOULD I'M ALSO WITH --
PARENT VOICES A SAN FRANCISCO
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
TWELVE MONTHS.
FOR I I MYSELF WAS A IN AN
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP AND I
IMMEDIATELY HAD.
TO BECOME A SINGLE PARENT IN
FIVE MINUTES AND I HAD TO GET ON
ASSISTANCE I WAS IN THE PROCESS
OF TRYING TO RECOVER FROM THIS
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE AS WELL AS
TRYING TO STAND ON MY OWN TWO
FEET AS A SINGLE PARENT.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE I HAVE MY
CHILD WITH ME IF I HAD HAD THAT
TWELVE MONTHS OF CHILD CARE I
COULD HAVE.
HAD THAT TIME TO GO GET THROUGH
THAT TRAUMA.
NOT COMPLETELY BUT HAVE GOTTEN
THE HELP THAT I NEEDED BECAUSE A
LOT OF THE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE
SAY YOU CAN'T BRING YOUR CHILD
WITH YOU.
IF YOU TO HAVE THOSE THERAPIES
AGAIN I MEAN JUST -- A LOT OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE OUT THERE
SO I WOULD HAVE HAD THAT TIME TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
AND I WOULD HAVE HAD THE TIME TO
BE ABLE TO FIND A JOB I'M STILL
NOT ABLE TO GO BACK TO WORK
BECAUSE I DO NOT HAVE THE CHILD
CARE I'M IN THE PROCESS OF
APPLYING BUT IT'S TAKEN ME.
MONTHS OF TIME THE I DON'T I'M
NOT BEING ABLE TO WORK BECAUSE I
AM IN THE PROCESS OF APPLYING TO
GET THE CHILD CARE AND IT'S
MONTHS AND MONTHS AND MONTHS.
SO IF I WOULD HAVE HAD THAT I
COULD BE BACK THERE SERVING A
POPULATION.
THAT ALWAYS NEEDS EDUCATORS AND
I CAN BE THAT EDUCATOR I ONE OF
THOSE EDUCATORS IN THAT SYSTEM
SO.
I JUST WANT TO POINT THAT OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ANY OTHER PARENTS.
OKAY.
RICHARD KNIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- FRANK NICHOLAS CDB DA
WE CONCUR THAT THE CURRENT
PROCESS OF AUTHORIZING AND RE
AUTHORIZING CHILD CARE TURNING
IT OFF ON AN OFF.
ON IS A BARRIER AND IS DIFFICULT
FOR CLIENTS AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH PARENTS VOICES ON
THEIR PROPOSAL FOR CONTINUOUS
ELIGIBILITY AND WE THINK IT HAS
MERIT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYBODY ELSE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO OKAY SO WILL
YOU KNOW IT.
RIGHT HEY DONNA SALINGER ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILD CARE
ALLIANCE OF LOS ANGELES AND
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF THE TWELVE MONTH
CONTINUOUS ELEMENT ELIGIBILITY
IN STAGE ONE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WANT AND HEALTHCARE IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
TWELVE MONTH EXTENSION -- IT'S A
MEANS BY WHICH A FAMILIES CAN
LIFT THEMSELVES OUT OF OUT OF
POVERTY AND FULLY TO LIFE CáC
OUR THANK YOU.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER HERE IN%
SUPPORT OF PARENT VOICES AND THE
TWELVE MONTHS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M CRISTINA GUERRILLA
PARA BOYCE'S ORGANIZER FOR CELL
KING COUNTY -- A RECIPIENT OF
CHILDCARE IN MY COUNTY AND I'M
DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT OF TWELVE
MONTH ELIGIBILITY -- ALSO THE
BEEN HELP HOW MUCH IT BENEFITS
THE CLIENTS THAT I SERVE --
WORKING WORKING IN MY COMMUNITY
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ARE MELANIE AND I
AM ALSO A PARENT VOICE ADVOCATE.
AND I SUPPORT OF THE DRAMA THAT
WAS BILLY.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER STRAUSS HE I
AM A FORMER CAL WORKS RECIPIENT
FORMER -- CHILDCARE SUBSIDY
RECIPIENTS.
CURRENT CHILDCARE SUBSIDY CASE
WORKER AND ALSO -- PARENT VOICES
ORGANIZER FOR SOLANO COUNTY --
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT ALL OF THE
CAL WORKS BUDGET PROPOSALS BUT I
ALSO HAVE A LETTER FROM.
A PARENT WHO COULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY BECAUSE SHE'S BUSY -- WITH
HER MID TERMS -- AND I PROMISE
TO MAKE IT QUICK.
MY NAME IS KATHLEEN READ I LIVE
IN SOLANO COUNTY I AM A PARENT
LEADER WITH PARENT VOICES
ORGANIZATION AND I AM FIGHTING
TO MAKE QUALITY CHILDCARE.
ACCESSIBLE AND AFFORDABLE O ALL
FAMILIES.
I'M TAKING THE TIME TO WRITE
THIS LETTER TO INFORM YOU OF THE
CHALLENGES I FACE AS A SINGLE
PARENT.
TRANSITIONING INTO SOMETHING NEW.
WHILE PROVIDING FOR MY CHILDREN
AND MAINTAINING MY GOALS I HAVE
LITTLE TO NO SECURITY THAT MY
CHILDREN.
WILL RECEIVE CONSISTENT QUALITY
CHILDCARE I'VE HAD TO REQUEST
ELEVEN CHILD CARE APPROVALS IN
THE LAST SIXTEEN MONTHS TO
ENSURE.
MY CURRENT PROVIDER WOULD BE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN CARE IN
ADDITION MANY FACILITIES AND
PROVIDERS HAVE BEEN LESS LIKELY.
TO COMMIT TO RANDOM DAYS ARE
TIMES BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
THE SECURITY OF APPROVED AND
STEADY INCOME.
I AM A FULL TIME STUDENT I WORK
PART TIME AND I AM WITH MY MAIN
PROVIDER I'M THE MAN PROVIDER --
TO MY TO TALK TO OTHER CHILDREN.
I MUST REQUEST AN APPROVAL PRIOR
TO EACH QUALIFYING CAL WORKS
ACTIVITY THIS ADDS ADDITIONAL
STRESS TO MY ALREADY HECTIC LIFE.
SUPPORTING THESE FUNDS WILL
ALLOW MYSELF ALONG WITH SO MANY
OTHERS TO THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FOCUS ON ATTAINING MY GOALS.
AS OPPOSED TO WORRYING ABOUT
WHETHER MY CHILDREN WILL BE
CARED FOR TOMORROW NEXT WEEK OR
NEXT MONTH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY IT WAS -- THE JOINT TALK OF
REVIEW -- OKAY -- ALL RIGHT AND
WE'LL GIVE YOU ANOTHER CHANCE
ALSO OF BEFORE IT THE PROPOSALS
WERE INVESTMENTS THAT GO ON YES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MY CAROL
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS ABOUT THE OVERVIEW --
AND REALLY -- FLEET TIED
TOGETHER -- WHAT YOU HEARD
AROUND THE DISCUSSION AROUND CAL
OR AND AND THE SINGLE ALLOCATION
BECAUSE WE SEE THEM AS? TWO
PIECES OF THE SAME MOMENT IN THE
SAME DIRECTION THAT THE STATE IS
HEADED -- AND WE CAN COVER WITH
THE STATE AND WE ARE WELL I
ACTUALLY CHAIRED ONE OF THE THE
CONTINUOUS QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
COMMITTEE WE DID SPEND A LOT OF
TIME WORKING ON THIS WE ARE VERY --
ENCOURAGED BY THE PATH THAT
WE'RE GOING DOWN AND WE THINK
THAT WILL MAKE A REALLY
SUBSTANTIVE DIFFERENCE WE THINK.
ARMED AT THE SAME TIME HOWEVER --
I WOULD REALLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PUT A VERY SHARP
BY GOING FOR IT MAY REVISE AND
BEYOND.
ON THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE
SINGLE ALLOCATION FORMULA.
BECAUSE TO THE DEGREE TO WHICH
WE'RE GOING TO ACHIEVE WHAT WE
HOPE TO AND CAL WAR WE NEED TO
BE GIVING COUNTIES THE
APPROPRIATE FISCAL INCENTIVES.
TO PUSH THEM IN THE DIRECTION OF
DOING THE THINGS THAT WE THINK
ARE IMPORTANT FOR FAMILIES TO BE
SUCCESSFUL -- AND SO IN
PARTICULAR I THINK YOU KNOW WE
WOULD LIKE MORE WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE AN ENCOURAGEMENT FOR FAMILY
SO SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO WORK
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE INCENTIVES.
TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GET
EDUCATION HALF THE RECIPIENTS OF
THE PROGRAM COME INTO IT WOULD
OUT A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA SO
THESE ARE REALLY CRITICAL
DEVELOPMENTS I THINK IS.
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE DOING THAT AND TYING
BACK INTO WHAT YOU JUST HEARD ON
THE TWELVE MONTH AUTHORIZATION
FOR CHILD CARE.
IN ADDITION TO MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING APPROPRIATE
FISCAL INCENTIVES WE ALSO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT SERVICES ARE
ACTUALLY BEING PROVIDED THAT
PEOPLE NEED AT THE TIME THAT
THEY NEED THEM.
SO THAT ONCE WE TELL FAMILY
THEY'RE GOING TO IT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE GOING TO EDUCATION
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO
REPEATEDLY GO BACK AND PURSUE
AND TRY TO GET APPROVAL FOR
CHILDCARE. FOR TRANSPORTATION
COSTS OR FOR SCHOOL BOOKS WHICH
WE FREQUENTLY HERE ARE PROVIDED
TO STUDENTS AT THE BEGINNING OF
SEMESTERS SO IT'S MORE THAN JUST.
FIXING THE SINGLE ALLOCATION
IT'S ALSO MAKING SURE THAT
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED NGUYEN
FAMILIES NEED THEM AND REDUCING
THE AMOUNT OF BACK AND FORTH
IT'S GOOD CURRENTLY OCCURRING IN
THE PROGRAM.
SO WE JUST WANTED TO KIND OF
BOLD TIE THOSE TWO ISSUES
TOGETHER AND THEN LASTLY ON THE
SAFETY NET RESERVE -- WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR THE
RESERVES ABSOLUTE A GREAT THING
TO DO AND HAS SUFFERED I KNOW
YOU WERE HERE WHEN WE HAD TO
MAKE A LOT OF REALLY DIFFICULT
CUTS -- BEFORE AND THAT WOULD
HAVE MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE IF WE
HAD THAT RESERVE AT THAT TIME WE
DO HOWEVER.
TO CONCUR WITH YOU THAT WE
PREFERRED THE STRUCTURE OF THE
RESERVES IT CURRENTLY IS.
WE AND WE DO THINK IT WILL DO A
BETTER JOB OF INSULATING CALLERS
FAMILIES FROM SHARP DROPS AND
BENEFITS IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I REALIZE THAT IN
A BRIEF EVEN THOUGH I GIVE YOU
MORE TIME -- PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD I LOOK FORWARD TO
RECEIVING AND PERHAPS A MORE
DETAILED LETTER AND SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE SHOULD BE THAT
YOU THINK WE SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT IN THE CAL OR PROCESS.
OUR OUR SOME COMMUNICATION OF
SOME SORT.
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
I HAVE AN ITEM COMING UP.
OKAY EXCELLENT ALLRIGHT
WONDERFUL.
OKAY -- SO WITH THAT THAT'S MOVE
ON A KNOW THAT -- WE'VE JUST
HEARD FROM FUND FAMILIES ABOUT
CAO WORK STAGE ONE BUT I THE
SINCE THEY HAD TO LEAVE FIVE ONE
TO GIVE A CHANCE TO SAVE -- SO
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO OUR STATE WANT DISSIPATION.
SURE SO FOR THE PURPOSE
PERSPECTIVE CAN GAIN CAM JOHNSON
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES AT
YOUR QUESTIONS ON THE AGENDA ASK
ABOUT THE CASE LOAD CHANGES IN
STAGE ONE RELATIVE TO THE OTHER
AT PORTIONS OF THE CASELOAD
WITHIN CAL WORKS AND IN FACT YOU
DO SEE A CORRELATION AS WE MIGHT.
EXPECT BETWEEN THE DECLINE IN
THE PLACEMENT SERVICES CASELOAD
IN THE STAGE ONE CHILD CARE
CASELOAD THEY ARE ALMOST
IDENTICAL AS PROPOSE GOING INTO
THE NINETEEN TWENTY FISCAL YEAR --
IN TERMS OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
FAMILIES FACE WHEN DETERMINING
WHETHER TO TAKE UP STAGE ONE I
THINK THAT -- AGAIN YOU JUST
HEARD SOME SOME CHALLENGES THAT
FAMILIES HAVE FACE TO AN
EXPERIENCED -- THE AB PIECE THAT
WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT VERY
CLOSELY ARE THE POINTS IN TIME
IN WHICH A CHILD CARE IS OFFERED
THE LANGUAGE THAT'S USED TO MAKE
THAT OFFER.
AND INSURING THAT IT'S HAPPENING
IN MULTIPLE TIMES ACROSS THAT
THAT PARTICIPANTS EXPERIENCE AND
CAL WORKS SO -- THAT IS THAT IS
ONE PIECE -- IT IS A PERSONAL
CHOICE SYSTEM AND SO -- IN TERMS
IN YOUR AGENDA POINTS OUT KIND
OF ADD THE ADDITION AND ADDS CAL
WHICH PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING IN OTHER TRUCKERS
SUBSIDY PROGRAMS ABOUT TO BE ON
STAGE ONE AND SO WE DO HAVE THAT.
AVAILABLE TO FAMILIES BUT REALLY
ENSURING THAT FAMILIES
UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S AVAILABLE
TO THEM THAT IT THAT NO OR
LIMITED COST -- AND REMINDING
THEM THAT THAT AS THEY
PARTICIPATE ENGAGE IN A
MULTITUDE OF ACTIVITIES ALONG
THE WAY IS REALLY CRITICAL AND
WE DO HAVE.
I CERTAINLY REGULATIONS THAT
REQUIRE THAT WE'VE BEEN AT
FOCUSED ON THAT AND HAVE SEEN
COUNTIES -- MAKING THOSE OFFERS --
SO IN IN TERMS OF WHAT WE JUST
HEARD AND AND AND KIND OF THE
EVOLUTION THEY HAVE AT CHILD
CARE IN THE TENNIS PROGRAM
PARTICULARLY FIRST HERE ASSN
HEARING CALIFORNIAN CAL WORKS --
WE REALLY DID TO ADD DEVELOP
KIND OF OUR POLICIES RELATED TO
SUPPORTING THE CHILD CARE USE AS
A PARTICIPANT IN AN ACTIVITY
ENGAGE SO THE AUTHORIZATION THAT
OCCURS TODAY -- IS PRETTY
SPECIFIC TO THE ACTIVITIES THAT
THE FAMILIES ARE ENGAGING AYE
AND THERE IS SOME FLEXIBILITY
WITHIN THAT BUT OF COURSE AT AS
WE ADD DEVELOP THAT TWENTY YEARS
AGO AND WE'RE THINKING THROUGH
REALLY THE ULTIMATE BENEFIT OF
QUALITY EARLY LEARNING
EXPERIENCE FOR CHILDREN -- WE DO
SUPPORT THE IDEA THAT WE NEED
ACROSS ALL CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
THAT SOMETHING YOU THINK YOU'VE
SEEN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO REALLY ENSURE THIS
IS THAT A HIGH QUALITY CONSUMER
EDUCATION EXPERIENCE THAT THE
FAMILIES RECEIVING. TO THEN MAKE
THAT -- BEST CHOICE FOR THEIR
CHILD -- AND REALLY ENSURE THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO THIS QUALITY
SETTING SO.
THAT'S HOW WE GET THERE OKAY ANY
COMMENTS FROM LA -- FINANCE.
OKAY NOW WE HAVE OUR PANEL HERE
AND ZERO ONE WELCOME.
THE PRINTER THAT THE ISSUE.
IF WE START PRUNING COOPER
SENIOR POLICY AT CHECKOUT TUCKER
LAWCENTER AND THE ACTUALLY OF
FROM.
VOICES SORRY I INTRODUCE
YOURSELF.
REAVIS BY PARENT VOICES FRESNO
OKAY EXCELLENT SO -- WELCOME AND
BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU THREE
MINUTES FREE SHADED DEATH SO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN PAN.
THIS BUDGET REQUEST WILL
STREAMLINE STAGE ONE CHILD CARE
ELIGIBILITY RULES THAT ALL CAL
WORKS FAMILIES ARE AFFORDED THE
SAME BENEFITS OF STABLE RELIABLE
AND CONSISTENT CHILD CARE.
THEY NEED TO IMPROVE THEIR
FAMILIES PROSPECTS AND TO
PROMOTE THEIR CHILDREN'S HEALTHY
DEVELOPMENT AND WELL BEING.
I THINK YOU'VE HEARD QUITE A BIT
IN THE PUBLIC COMMENT IT'S KIND
OF NICE TO HAVE THAT GO FIRST --
THE ABOUT SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT PARENTS EXPERIENCE AND THE
BARRIERS THAT CAL WORKS FAMILIES
FACE TRYING TO GET AND KEEP
STAGE ONE CHILD CARE.
OFTEN THEY ARE NOT AWARE THAT
PAID CHILDCARE IS AVAILABLE IF
THEY HAVE BEEN INFORMED THE
PROCESSES BURDENSOME AND FULL OF
A LOT OF RED TAPE AND OR
MULTIPLE STEPS TO GET AN
AUTHORIZATION.
THEY ARE OFTEN SHORT TERM AND
FREQUENTLY DISRUPTED ONE DAY
THREE DAYS.
AND FAMILIES WHO DO SUCCEED AND
GETTING AND KEEPING STAGE ONE
CAN EXPERIENCE A DISRUPTION AT
THE TIME THAT THEY TRANSFERRED
TO THE NEXT STAGE OF CHILD CARE
STAGE.
TO WE FIND THAT THERE ARE
PARENTS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR CAL
WORKS CHILD CARE WHO ARE
APPEARING ON COUNTY WAITING
LISTS FOR CHILDCARE BECAUSE
THEY'VE NEVER BEEN PROPERLY
CONNECTED TO THE RESOURCES THEY
QUALIFY.
FOR SO VERY SIMPLY THIS BUDGET.
REQUEST WOULD ESTABLISH TWELVE
MONTH ELIGIBILITY IN STAGE ONE
WHICH IS ALREADY PROVIDED IN
EVERY CHILD CARE SUBSIDY PROGRAM
IN CALIFORNIA EXCEPT FOR STAGE.
ONE AND I WON'T GO INTO THE
BENEFITS OF THAT BUT I THINK
WHAT.
MS JOHNSON JUST DESCRIBED OF
MAKING SURE THERE ARE GOOD
CONSISTENT QUALITY CHILD CARE
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO PARENTS AND
THE BENEFITS TO CHILDREN OF
HAVING THAT DURING THIS TIME OF
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
IT WOULD ALSO ALLOW PARENTS TO
GET CHILD CARE TO PARTICIPATE IN
NEEDED ACTIVITIES AND AGAIN --
MOVING SLIGHTLY FROM THE WELFARE
TO WORK CONCEPT TO WHAT IS IT
THAT A FAMILY NEEDS TO STABILIZE
AND IMPROVE ITS PROSPECTS YOU
HEARD ABOUT SOMEBODY WHO
COULDN'T GO TO A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE COUNSELLING OR TRAUMA
COUNSELING.
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T BRING
THEIR CHILD WITH THEM.
AND GIVE THE PARENT THE OPTIONAL
FULL TIME CARE SO THAT THEIR
CHILDREN GET BETTER ACCESS TO
THE RANGE OF LICENSED EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES.
ENSURE SMOOTH TRANSFERS.
I'M NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
SAN FRANCISCO PILOT BUT IT HAS
HAD -- AND A VERY BIG EFFECT ON
THE STAGE ONE FAMILIES THAT HAVE
ENJOYED TWELVE MONTH ELIGIBILITY
AND IF YOU'D LIKE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION I CAN PROVIDE IT TO
THE COMMITTEE -- THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL ALSO ADOPTS THE TOP
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE ASSEMBLY
BLUE RIBBON -- COMMISSION ON
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND
CHAIRMAN PAN I BELIEVE YOU WERE
HANDED THE PARENTS
RECOMMENDATIONS -- CALLED
WAITING TO BE SEEN DEMANDING TO
BE HEARD YOU'VE GOT IT.
ON PAGE NINE THIS RECOMMENDATION
IS THE ONE FOR IMMEDIATE
IMPLEMENTATION.
OF SOME OF THE OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE ALSO LISTED
IN THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
REPORT AND I CAN LET YOU KNOW
THOSE DETAILS AS WELL -- I WANT
TO TURN TO WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
AND THE DEPARTMENT THEM -- THE
MEASURE OF YOUR YOUTH OKAY THAT --
LET ME JUST SAY IN IN VERY QUICK
CLOSING.
WE'RE NOT CHANGING ANY WELFARE
TO WORK REQUIREMENTS I THINK
THIS IS IMPORTANT IT DOESN'T
CHANGE COUNTY DISCRETION TO
DEFINE STABILITY.
IN DECIDING WHEN A FAMILY IS
READY TO BE TRANSFERRED.
AND IT DOESN'T EXPAND CURRENT
LAW GOVERNING WHEN CHILD CARE IS
AVAILABLETO EITHER VOLUNTEERS
FOR SANCTIONED ADULTS.
SO YOU'VE HEARD THAT ARE CAL
WORKS PARENTS ARE STRUGGLING TO
CREATE THE BEST LIFE POSSIBLE
FOR THEIR CHILDREN BY PROVIDING
THIS CONTINUOUS CHILD CARE.
WHERE THEY CAN GROW AND LEARN
THIS PROPOSAL WILL GIVE CHILDREN
IN THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM THE
STRONG START THAT WILL PREVENT
THE PREPARE THEM FOR LIFELONG
SUCCESS?
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM.
I REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
STAGE ONE IMPROVEMENTS AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OKAY THANK YOU.
AND OF THE FUTURE YOU TRAVELING
HERE SHE TOOK UP ALL THE TIME.
IF YOU COULD JUST -- SHARE YOUR
STORY BRIEFLY I'D APPRECIATE
WALL THE MAIN PART OF MY STORY
THAT I WANT HER TO IS THE MARK
WHERE.
I WAS ON STAGE -- ONE THAT WAS
GOING REALLY GREAT -- I GOT A
JOB TO WHERE I WAS MAKING TOO
MUCH TO STAY ON CASH.
EIGHT SO THEY WERE TRANSFER ME
TO STAGE.
TWO BUT I GOT LOST IN.
THE COMMUNICATION.
A SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE YOU
KNOW THAT.
WE HAVE THE COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE AGENCIES THE L. AT
THE DATA SCREEN SO THEY CAN SEE.
THE INFORMATION BECAUSE THEY
THEY'RE TRYING TO PUT IT ON ME.
TO LET THEM KNOW -- THAT THIS
NEEDS TO BE DONE BUT THEY'RE
LIKE NOBODY GOT IT BACK TO THEM
BUT NO NO YOU GOT TO TALK TO
THEM SO THEY KEPT SENDING ME
BACK AND FORTH INSTEAD OF
TALKING TO EACH OTHER.
THE STRESS SO YEAH AND YEAH IT
DID PUT A LOT OF STRESS ON ME --
I STARTED LOSING SLEEP -- TO
WHERE I DIDN'T GET ENOUGH REST
FOR WORK. TO WHERE I WAS KIND OF
SLACKING IN MY JOB AND THEN ALSO
TOWARD MY KIDS THEY WANTED MY
ATTENTION AND BECAUSE I WAS
REALLY STRESSED OUT I STARTED
SNAPPING AT THEM FROM THE LITTLE
REASONS OF LIKE.
THANK WAY WAY BACK IN HIS THE
WHOLE YEAH IT IS REALLY REALLY
STRESSFUL TO GO THROUGH THAT.
I THINK ANY OF US WHO HAVE
CHILDREN AND REALIZE THAT EITHER
WE HAVE TO GO PICK THEM UP FROM
CHILD CARE WE DON'T HAVE CHILD
CARE WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
I'VE BEEN IN THAT SITUATION THE
STRESS LEVEL GOES WAY WAY OF
SELF.
MYSELF WILL TELL YOU THAT.
TO THE OTHER THING TOO IS THAT
BECAUSE I LOST THE STATE CARE I
LEFT MY DAUGHTER WITH MY FATHER
WHO IS DISABLED.
SO HE HAD OR SITTING IN FRONT OF
THE TV MOST THE TIME AND I WOULD
RATHER HAVE HER BEEN IN DAYCARE
LIKE SHE WAS WHEN I WAS ON STAGE.
ONE TO ACTUALLY LEARN SOMETHING
SO SO ACTUALLY I GUESS THE
QUESTION I POSE IS ASIDE FROM
MONEY I MEAN THIS IS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE IS THERE ANY PART.
WITH THEIR ANY POLICY ISSUES
WITH THIS -- CONCERNS -- SO I
THINK WE DOUBLE ALSO AGREED THAT
THE POLICY HAS MERIT -- AND THAT
THAT THE COUNTRY'S CRITICAL WE
DO AGAIN WHAT.
THE AGAIN INTENT IN GOAL IS TO
HAVE A CHILD CARE NOT BE A
BARRIER TO THE ENGAGEMENT IN THE
REST OF THE CALYX ARRAY SO.
THAT WE WE BELIEVE THE PROPOSAL
AS MAYOR.
OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM LA UP
BECAUSE I'M ANY THINK THIS
DESTRUCTION -- AND ALSO -- WELL
FIRST OF ALL THE DESTRUCTION
CERTAINLY IS IS IS A HUGE HUGE
PROBLEM RIGHT I MEAN AS I AM A
PHYSICIAN WE TALK ABOUT KIND WE
CARE AND WHEN THE OF DESTRUCTION
CARE AND HAND OFFS AND PEOPLE
FALLING OFF SO -- AS A CERTAINLY
I THINK THAT'S A THAT'S A BIG
ISSUE AND THEN -- AND THEN OF
COURSE -- NOT KNOWING YEAH I
EIGHT EIGHT A AND A HEARING
ABOUT PEOPLE SAYING THEY'RE KIND
OF ON A STAGE WHEN THEY SERVE
HAVE AND THEY DON'T KNOW HAVE
SHORT PERIODS OF TIME BECAUSE
ONLY CAN COVER CERTAIN THINGS.
IS THERE AN ISSUE THERE IN TERMS
OF BEING SURE PEOPLE ARE AT MORE
RELIABLY KNOWS BECAUSE PEOPLE
HAVE TO DO A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT THINGS RIGHT IF YOU'RE
JUST SO.
THERE IS THAT AT I HAVE
FLEXIBILITY THAT'S BACK
CURRENTLY ALLOWED IN TERMS OF
THE TYPES OF ACTIVITIES THAT
CHILD CARE IS ALLOW IS ALLOWABLE
USES -- FOR THE AUTHORIZATIONS
AGAIN THERE ARE SPECIFIC TO THE
ENGAGE IN THOSE ACTIVITIES SO AS
THOSE AND ACTIVITIES CHANGE OVER
TIME WHICH IS HIGHLY LIKELY AS A
AS A NEW PARTICIPANTS ENTERING
THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM -- THAT
AUTHORIZATION HAPPENS FREQUENTLY
RIGHT SO THE AUTHORIZATION
CHANGES TO THAT THE CHANGES IN
THE WELFARE TO WORK PLAN IN THE
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE GOING
FORWARD SO.
THAT CHILD CARE IS CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZED TO THE ACTIVITIES
THAT DAY AT PARTICIPANTS ENGAGED
IN.
SO.
WELL LET ME LET ME JUST THIRTY
THINK THIS THROUGH WALKED US
THROUGH SO.
SOMEONE'S ON STAGE ONE RATE AND
THEY MAY.
THERE'S A LIST OF ACTIVITIES
THAT DON'T PROVIDE CHILDCARE
FOUR EIGHT AND IT'S AND THEN.
INTO THE PROBLEM SO SO.
I GUESS.
WELL.
DO YOU ACTUALLY FIND CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS FOR LIKE FINE YOU KNOW
FOR THESE FEW WEEKS I DO THIS
AND THEN THOSE TWO WEEKS OF OURS
THAT THOSE HOURS THE NUMBER OF
HOURS SHIFTS BECAUSE THIS ONE
HAS TRIED TO GET CHILD CARE
USUALLY.
YOU KNOW IT'S ONE THING TO BE A
BABYSITTER TO AND THAT'S NOT
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT OR TALKING
A MORE CONSISTENCY RIGHT.
THERE CAL LIKE OKAY YOUR CHILD'S
GONNA BE I MEAN THEY UNDERSTAND
OF THE CHILD SECOND THEY MAY BE
OUT BUT IT'S CANTONS IT'S LOOK
THE OTHER WAY RIGHT HELP YOUR
CHILD GOING TO BE HERE FROM THE
OUT THIS TIME TO THIS TIME EVERY
DAY WITH MAYBE SOME EXCEPTIONS
ON VACATION.
OR SICK OR WHATEVER BUT INSTEAD
OF JUST LOOK THE OTHER WAY
AROUND MORE.
OKAY WELL YOU'RE GOING TO BE
HERE FOR FIVE HOURS THIS DAY
THREE HOURS THAT DAY.
WHATEVER I MEAN.
ADDED JUST WONDERING LIKE IF
YOU'RE A SHE ACTUALLY ABLE TO
GET TELL CARE PROVIDERS WHO WORK
ON THAT KIND OF SCHEDULE AND
TAKE KIDS CONSISTENTLY ON THAT
KIND OF SCHEDULE. FOR THAT THAT
CAN CERTAINLY BE A CALLENGE AS
YOU ARTICULATED I THINK THAT
WHAT WE SEEM COUNTIES TO TO TRY
TO MITIGATE THAT SPECIFICALLY AS
A BRAND NEW CAL EXPERTISE OF AN
INTERCESSOR IS A VARIETY OF
OPTIONS THEY DO TO TRY TO
PROVIDE SOME IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO
THAT COULD.
BE EVERYTHING FROM SUPPORTING A
HAPPEN CHILD CARE ON SITES AT
THE COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICE
AGENCIES SO AS THEIR
PARTICIPATING IN ORIENTATIONS
AND JOB SKILLS TRAINING THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS THEY HAVE CHILD
CARE ON SITE.
AT SOME COUNTIES ALSO CONTRACT
WITH LOCAL AD CHECK YOUR CENTERS
IN PROGRAMS NEARBY TO KIND OF AT
HAVE THAT SPACE AVAILABLE -- FOR
PARTICIPANTS BUT JUST IN TERMS
OF THE OVERALL ACCESS AT THAT
THE AUTHORIZATION IS WHAT THAT
THE PARENT KNOWS THEY KNOW THEY
ARE AUTHORIZED FOR CARE AT THAT
SPECIFICITY OF THEIR ACTIVITIES
AND THAT'S HOW THEY'RE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE WHAT THEN -- THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR WITH THE PROVIDER SO
I THINK YOU COULD HEAR THAT SOME
POVIDERS YEAH THERE'S A THERE'S
A LOT OF VARIATION IN TERMS OF
WHAT PROVIDERS -- I PROVIDE SOME
ONLY PROVIDE FULL TIME CARE
SUMMER MORE FLEXIBLE PART TIME
BUT THAT REALLY DOES VERY IN A
VERY IS FOR THE AGE RANGE OF THE
CHILD AS WELL.
A AND A I'M ACTUALLY CURIOUS
FROM THE THE I MEAN.
WE HAVE PEOPLE TRY RUN CHILD
CARE IS OUR REPRESENTS YOUR IS
THAT GOING TO BE MORE EXPENSIVE
WHEN YOU DON'T KNOW SO YOU KIND
OF HAVE TO CHARGE MORE TO EVEN
OUT THE FACT THAT YOU'RE.
AT THE PERSONS LIKE.
IT NEEDS THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE
A SHIFTING STATE YOU HAVE A I'M
JUST THINKING ABOUT THE TALES OF
OBVIOUSLY WHAT OUR PRIORITIES
THE THE THE THE CLIENT THE
BENEFICIARY RIGHT IN THERE.
AND HOW THEY HAVE TO MANAGE THAT
I'M ALSO THINKING FROM THE IF
YOU'RE A CHILD CARE PROVIDER NOW
I REALIZE THE COUNTY RUNS AROUND
ETCETERA.
I THINK YOU THE COST OF RUNNING
IT WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE COMING
IN WHO BASICALLY.
THEIR THEIR HOURS ARE CONSTANTLY
SHIFTING BECAUSE YOU NEED TO
MAINTAIN A CERTAIN LEVEL
INFRASTRUCTURE NOW.
AND AND IT'S IT'S NOT LIKE YOU
HAVE OF GROUP OF CLASS I GO THE
THE MATCH LIKE PUZZLE PIECES
RIGHT SO BECAUSE THAT MEANS THAT
YOU MAY SOME THE HAVE A LARGER
ENTRIES AND IT'S ONLY DROP RIGHT
SO I AM ONE LEVEL BECAUSE A WELL
WELL WE ONLY WE SHOULD.
PAY FOR CHILD CARE ONLY FOR THE
TIME THAT THEY NEED FOR VERY
SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES AND BUT IT
SLIPS I'M THINKING IS THAT CHILD
CARE GOING TO BE MORE EXPENSIVE
JUST BECAUSE A CHILD CARE
PROVIDER HAS TO MAINTAIN A
CERTAIN LEVEL I MEAN THEY DON'T
HAVE CERTAIN TO EITHER SO.
HOW THE HOW MUCH STAFF TO THEY
HAVE HOW MUCH SPACE TO THE HAVE
HOW MUCH SUPPLIES TODAY I MEAN
I'M JUST THINKING LIKE IF I WAS
A BUSINESS PERSON WHO HAD RUN
THE CHILD CARE BUT THERE AND
THAT?
IS PERSON BECAUSE I OWN THE
CHILD CARE OR EVEN JUST ON THE
MANAGER FOR THE STATE HE FOR THE
EIGHT COUNTY AGENCY THAT HAS TO
MAINTAIN A CHILD CARE FACILITY.
I WONDER IF SOMEONE LOOKED AT
HOW WHAT THE COST OF DOING THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE THIS.
THIS VERY ABILITY -- TO YET IN
IN IN YOUR YOUR YOUR YOUR UP AT
EIGHT EIGHT IS YOUR CLIENT ADDED
THE NUMBER KIDS YOU HALF RIGHT
AND AND AND THE AND THE RANGE OF
THE AGES CELL.
IT IS I'M JUST SORRY I'M STATE
YES -- ABOUT THAT I DID HAVE A
RACK SCHEDULE LIKE THAT TO HER --
LIKE MY JANITOR JOB I WAS
WORKING FOR PM TO THREE AM AND
THEN I HAD ANOTHER JOB THAT WAS
ON CALL.
I COULD PUT MY KID AN ACTUAL THE
FACILITY I HAD TO GO THROUGH A
FAMILY MEMBER AND HAVE THEM.
BUT ON MY CONTRACTS THEY
ACTUALLY HAD PUT VARIOUS TIMES
THEY COULDN'T PUT LIKE SET TIMES
FOR MY IMAGE FOR A JOB THAT WAS
ON CALL.
SO THEY KNEW THAT THERE IS AN TO
BE SOME VARIOUS TIMES IN THERE
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO PAY MY
MY FAMILY MEMBER.
FOR THE FOR THE JANITORIAL JOB
IT WAS JUST BETWEEN THOSE TIMES
THAT THEY WOULD PAY [inaudible]
FOR OKAY.
I THINK THE REALITY IS THAT FOR
ANYONE WHO HAS -- IN
INTERMITTENT SCHEDULE A VARIABLE
SCHEDULE NONTRADITIONAL HOURS
THE ONLY OPTION IS -- LICENSE
EXAM TO A FAMILY FRIEND AND
NEIGHBOR CARE AND WHEN YOU SAY
WELL WOULDN'T THEY HAVE TO BE
PAID MORE TO HOLD THAT SPACE
OPEN THE ANSWER IS THAT THE
STATE.
SETS A CEILING ON HARASSMENT
RATES SO THAT IS NOT AN OPTION
AND AS A RESULT -- WE THINK THAT
CREATING TWELVE MONTH
ELIGIBILITY AND THE OPTION OF
FULL TIME CARE MEANS THAT
PARENTS WILL HAVE ACCESS TO A
FULLER RANGE OF LICENSED QUALITY
CHILDCARE OPTIONS THAT IS NOT
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE BECAUSE OF
JUST THE A PROBLEMS YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED AT WAS A MORE
EXPENSIVE.
IT'S DRAIN YOUR WILL SO WHAT WE
DO IS A STATE WE CAP THAT REYES
SO BUT THE PROBLEM IS I'M SAYING
THE PERSON WHO ACTUALLY OPERATED
AND SAYS WELL I CAN'T TAKE IT'S
LIKE THAT.
BECAUSE IT WILL COST ME MORE
IT'S NOT YOU KNOW AND AND AND
IT'S GONNA COST ME MORE THAN TO
AND JUST TRY TO WALK THROUGH THE
PROBLEM AND JUST THINKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW HOW TO BE SURE WE BUILD
THAT CAPACITY FOR AVAILABLE
CHILD CARE -- AND AND THEN FOR
IT SO IT IS SOMETIMES SOMEONE
BEING WHETHER REPAYING AND AGAIN
I'M.
THAT ARE SORT OF RUN NUMBERS
ANYTHING BUT I'VE WAS EYES
WONDER WHETHER BEING PENNY WISE
POUND FOOLISH SIX I COULD SEE
PEOPLE SAID WELL YOU KNOW THIS
IS THE WAY TO SAVE MONEY WHICH
ONLY PROVIDE CHILDCARE FOR VERY
SPECIFIC THINGS BECAUSE THAT
MAKE.
IT WOULD WHILE SPEND MONEY ON
DOUBT THEY SHOULD BE TAKEN CARE
TO KIDS OF THOSE OTHER TIMES AND
YOU KNOW WE SHOULD BE PAYING FOR
IT BUT IN THE END IF YOU'RE
DEPENDING ON THAT UNIVERSE OF
THINGS.
YOU MAY END UP WITH A SITUATION
WHERE IT'S YOU CREATING THIS
OKAY I'M PAYING FOR THIS MANY
HOURS THE STATUS THE HOURS THAT
THEY KNOW HOURS THAT DAY YOU
KNOW THAT IT THAT IT THINKING
ABOUT THE PERSON I SEE IS
PROVIDE THAT SERVICE THAT.
THE RAD.
THAT KIND OF A RADIC UP.
COVERAGE MAY NOT EVEN MAKE SENSE
FOR THEM EITHER RIGHT -- SO --
AND AND THEY ARE AT AND THEN
I'LL TOP LAYER ON TOP OF THAT OF
COURSE WE'RE TRYING TO GET.
THEM INTO WORK AND OFTEN TIMES
THE FIRST JOB YOU CAN GET IS
PROBABLY KIND OF THE SITE.
PEACE WORK IN -- CETERA THAT'S
IT SO.
I'M HOPING THAT -- I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE WORKING ON THIS ISSUE AND
ASSERTS THINKING DESERVE THANK
YOU KNOW LIKE.
OPERATIONALLY DOES THIS MAKE
SENSE TO DO IT THE WAY WE'RE
DOING AND I THINK THAT'S AND AND
WHAT IS REALLY THE CONSEQUENCE
OF THAT RIGHT SIZE SO -- I'LL
JUST ADD NAY A MENTION THIS IN
IN MY EARLIER REMARKS LIKE THAT
AB PART OF WHAT WE'RE DOING IT
WHEN IN THIS IS THE NEXT AGENDA
ITEM BETA HOME VISITING
INITIATIVE.
IS MAKING THAT EARLY CONNECTION
TO A QUALITY EARLY LEARNING
PROGRAM HAVING THAT CONVERSATION
BEFORE THE PARENT ESSENTIALLY IS
SUBJECTED TO THE WELFARE TO WORK
REQUIREMENTS SO HOPING THAT.
ENGAGEMENT CAN HAPPEN THAT EARLY
IN THAT CONNECTION -- TO PROVIDE
THAT CONTINUITY GOING IN SO THAT
AGAIN WE ARE WORKING TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE ISSUES THAT BETTER
OKAY SO IS A USER SOME EFFORT TO
LOOKS MORE STRATEGICALLY IT'S
STILL A MOVE IN THE START AT
LEAST IN THE THREE YEARS I'VE
BEEN HERE.
EVERYONE TALKS ABOUT WHAT WE
HAVE SAGE ONE BUT THE THIRD TOP
UP TAKE AND WE SAY WELL PEOPLE
PREFER TO HAVE FAMILIES TO PAY
FOR TO HAVE SOMETHING THAT'S
REASON AS SOMEONE STEPPED BACK
AND SAID LET'S JUST LOOK
STRATEGICALLY AT THIS.
STAGE ONE THING.
YES MY ALSO AT APPRECIATE AND
THINGS ARE SAGE ONE TOUCH AND
NOTHING.
SHE'S ALSO PART OF THAT
FACILITATING A COW WORKS CHILD
CARE INTERAGENCY WORK GROUPS AND
BOTH THIS DEPARTMENT.
AND THE DEPARTMENT YOU CATION AS
HAVE BEEN PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO SO YES KIND OF
LOOKING AT HOLISTICALLY AT WHAT
IS THE EXPERIENCE FROM HE
CLIENTS PERSPECTIVE IS SOMETHING
THE DEPARTMENT IS ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
AND WHERE WHERE CAN WE ENSURE AS
AS WAS MENTIONED THERE.
AREN'T ANY DESTRUCTION POINTS
ALONG THE WAY THAT'S A SEAMLESS
SYSTEM THAT THE POLICIES ARE
LINED WE DID PUT OUT SOME JOINT
GUIDANCE AS A RESULT OF AS
SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS WITH THIS
INTERAGENCY WORKING GROUP LAST
FALL BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION SOCIAL SERVICES AROUND.
NOT DISCONTINUING -- A FAMILY AS
THE TRANSFER MAKING SURE THAT
THE STAGE TO A CONTRACTOR HAS
FULLY AT IN ROLLED THEM PRIOR TO
ANY DISCONTINUANCE THE STAGE ONE
SO WE YES WE ARE WE ARE.
LOOKING HOLISTICALLY AT SOME OF
THESE CHALLENGES AND CONTINUE TO
FIND IN AN IDENTIFY NEW WAYS FOR
IMPROVED.
YEAH I MEAN CERTAINLY CLIENT
SHOULD COME FIRST BUT AS ND I
APPRECIATE THE CLIENTS
PERSPECTIVE I'M ALSO THINKING
ABOUT ANY AND I THINK THAT
SHOULD BE THE PRIMARY LANDS.
I ALSO THINKING ABOUT WELL WHAT
IMPLICATIONS DECISIONS WERE
MAKING HAVE ON AVAILABILITY
RIGHT ON THE EXISTING CAPACITY
OUT THERE.
AND WHAT WE REALLY EXPECTING
RIGHT SO IF A EXPECTING OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES AND THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE EXPECTING.
MATCHING UP WITH THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE THAT LIES IT DELETE
PROVIDE THAT IT AND I EVEN TALK
I'M TALKING ABOUT LIKE A RADIC
SCHEDULES RIGHT I MEAN SORRY
HARD ENOUGH.-CLIENTS WITH THEIR SCHEDULES AND
I HAPPENS IS AND SO.
IT IS SO IT GETS ITS ARE
THINKING ABOUT THE SYSTEMATIC
ISSUES KIND OF THING SO ALL
RIGHT.
QUESTION ABOUT THAT I WOULD JUST
GUESSING CLIENTS SAY THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN A
TERRIFIC PARTNER IN THIS EFFORT
TO BOTH THINK ABOUT HOW TO
CREATE THOSE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING AND TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO BEST OPERATIONALIZE
THEM AND YOU KNOW WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THOSE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS AND BELIEVE IT.
THAT'S THE WAY WILL CREATE THE
BEST POLICY THAT REALLY DOES SIR
FAMILIES AS WELL AS AS YOU
MENTIONED THE PROVIDERS.
WHO THEMSELVES HAVE FAMILIES?
AND ARE TRYING TO CREATE A
BUSINESS MODEL BASED ON
PROVIDING GOOD QUALITY CHILDCARE.
OKAY.
AND AN ADVENTURELAND OUR CURRENT
BUDGET CHAIR FORMER CHAIR THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ACTUALLY RAN A
CHILD CARE FRIDAY MAY HAVE SOME
OTHER ADDITIONAL PERSPECTIVES ON
THAT AS WELL BUT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OKAY -- WHEN WE MOVE ON THEN TO
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE --
WILL BE ABOUT THE ISSUE THREE
CAL WORKS GRANT INCREASES.
IT WAS GOOD TALKING TO INCREASES
IN THE GOVERNOR.
ALSO THE BUDGET PROPOSES
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE -- TO THE
TOWERS GROUND LEVEL BY THIRTEEN
POINT 1% EFFECTIVE OCTOBER FIRST
THAT'S IN ADDITION TO THE 10%
THAT WENT INTO EFFECT THIS MONTH
APRIL.
I WHICH WILL BRING THE MONTHLY
GRANT PAYMENTS UP 250% OF THE
PROJECTED TWENTY NINETEEN
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
IN A CONTINUES TO BUILD ON ON WE
LOOK WE LOOK FOR TO THOSE
INCREASES AS FAR AS THE CASELOAD
IMPACT OF THOSE GRANTS.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF A USE INCLUDE THE INELIGIBLE.
UNNEEDED FAMILY MEMBERS -- THE
CONCENTRATION OF THOSE CASES
WITHOUT -- IN A TO THE DOLE IS
MOSTLY IN A YOU OF ONE
APPROXIMATELY 80% OF EIGHT OF A
YOU OF ONE OUR CASES WITHOUT AN
ON AN EIGHT EIGHT ADULT.
BASED ON THE MAP LEVELS AFTER
THIS OCTOBER FIRST THE TWENTY
NINETEEN INCREASED APPROXIMATELY
27% OF CASES -- WILL BE OUT --
BELOW THE FRONT AND FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL AND CONSIDERED
KIND OF THE FURTHEST AWAY FROM
THAT 50% TARGET -- THAT 27%
REPRESENTS PRIMARILY A USE OF
ONE OF THE SOME SMALL PERCENTAGE
ADDITIONS OF A USE OF EIGHT OR
MORE.
WITH REGARDS TO THE QUESTION ON
THE LA OWES THIRD OPTION E DO
BELIEVE IT CAN BE
OPERATIONALIZED THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD WOULD REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN FUNDING OVER WHAT'S
BEEN PROPOSED IN THE CURRENT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALLEVIATE SOME COMMENTS THAT AND
ALSO QUESTION FOR YOU DIFFERENT
OPTIONS YES THANK YOU.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED THIRTEEN
POINT 1% ACROSS THE BOARD GRAN
INCREASE DIFFERS IN SEVERAL KEY
RESPECTS FROM THE LAN THAT WAS
ADOPTED AS PART OF THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT.
IN OUR VIEW IT'S CLEARLY A STEP
IN THE SAME DIRECTION AND SO IS
AN INCOMPATIBLE -- WE THINK THE%
LEGISLATURE SHOULD AND THE
SUBCOMMITTEE SHOULD CONSIDER
SORT OF ITS OPTIONS IN
RECONCILING THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO PLANS -- THE
GOVERNOR'S APPROACH APPROACH IS
ACROSS THE BOARD TO EACH.
ARE A YOU WOULD RECEIVE A GRANT
INCREASE OF THE SAME PERCENTAGE
AMOUNT.
ON THE LEGISLATURE'S PLAN THE
GRANT INCREASES WOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED DIFFERENTLY.
IN IN SPECIFICALLY A LARGER
GRANT INCREASE WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED TO IN PARTICULAR THE
A USE OF ONE WHICH UNDER CURRENT
LAW ARE FURTHEST FROM 50% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. TO SORT
OF AN OPTION OF WHICH DIRECTION
TO TO FOLLOW AS PART OF THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET -- WE THINK THERE
ARE A COUPLE ALTERNATIVES TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN COULD CONSIDER
IF IT WANTED TO PURSUE -- NOW
COM THAT WAS MORE CLOSELY
ALIGNED WITH ITS EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET PLAN HOT ONE
OPTION IS TO WORK WITHIN THE THE
PROPOSED BUDGETARY AMOUNT THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED. FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR BUT INSTEAD OF
PROVIDING A GRAND INCREASE
ACROSS THE BOARD DISTRIBUTE
THOSE SORT OF TARGETED IN A
TARGETED FASHION SUCH THAT ALL.
ALL A USER PART GRAHAM LEVELS
ARE BROUGHT TO THE SAME
PERCENTAGE OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL WE THINK THAT
WOULD BE ABOUT 48% OF THE FPL
THAT'S ONE OPTION --
ALTERNATIVELY THE LEGISLATURE
COULD MOVE FORWARD WITH ITS --
PLAN AS OUTLINED IS IN PART OF
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
ACTS.
THAT WOULD.
OVER A TWO YEAR PERIOD INCREASE
GRANT LEVELS CONSIDERABLY HIGHER
THAN WHAT IS PROPOSED ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS A
DEPARTMENT MENTIONED -- BECAUSE
NOT ONLY WOULD GRANT LEVELS BE
INCREASED 250% OF THE FPL UNDER
THE LEGISLATURE'S PLAN IT WOULD
BE 50% THE F. P. L. THAT
CORRESPONDS.
WITH THE FAMILY THAT'S ONE
PERSON LARGER THAN THE COW WORKS
ASSISTANCE UNIT ARE MINDFUL THAT
MANY CAO WORKS CASES DO INCLUDE
IN AN ELIGIBLE FAMILY MEMBER --
SO THERE'S A SORT OF THE OPTIONS
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY SPECIFICS
[inaudible]
OKAY.ZERO DO YOU HAVE A COMMENT
ON ON THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MY CAROL
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY -- YES ACTUALLY WE HAVE
A WILL A WITNESS HERE TODAY
WHOSE EXACTLY THE KIND OF CASE
IS THAT -- THE ONLY -- JUST
DESCRIBED -- WHERE WE HAD SHE
CHAIR IT WAS DURING THAT AND SHE
IS THAT SHE'S SINGLE DAUGHTER
BUT SHE'S TIME OFF OF THE
SYSTEMS SHE SAID HER FORTY EIGHT
MONTH LIMIT?
SOMETHING WE HOPE YOU'LL ADDRESS
DURING THIS YEAR'S BUDGET BY THE
WAY -- BUT UNDER THE UNDER THE
PROPOSAL PUT FORTH BY THE
GOVERNOR -- HER GRANT LEVEL
WOULD STILL BE I BELIEVE IT
FORTY TWO OR 43% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL AND AGAIN WE ARE
REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL ON
THIS.
WE JUST HAD A 10% GRANT INCREASE
NOW WE HAVE A 13% INCREASE.
ON TOP OF THAT IN THE SAME
CALENDAR YEAR.
THESE ARE REALLY HUGE STEPS THAT
WERE MAKING AND IT'S GOING TO
MAKE A REAL DIFFERENCE IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES -- HOWEVER WE
WOULD PREFER THE APPROACH I
THINK THAT WAS.
PUT FORTH BY THE LEGISLATURE
LAST YEAR IN WHICH WE WOULD
RAISE GRANT LEVELS EXPRESSLY FOR
AND WHAT WE THINK ARE VERY
VULNERABLE HOUSEHOLDS OF STUFF
BUT I'VE DESCRIBED AS SORT OF A
LEGAL FICTION.
THAT THESE ARE HOUSEHOLDS OF ONE
IN FACT THERE ARE NO SUCH THING
THEY'RE ALWAYS AT LEAST A TWO
PERSON HOUSEHOLD AND THE PATH OF
THE LEGISLATURE'S ESTABLISHED
LAST YEAR WOULD BE INCREASE YOU
WOULD BE PUTTING MORE FUNDING
INCREASING THOSE GRANT LEVELS
HIGHER.
AND THEN IN TWO YEARS OUT WE
WOULD BE GETTING TO WHAT THE LA --
DESCRIBE WHICH WOULD BE 50% PLUS
ONE ADDITIONAL PERSON IN THAT.
CASE LOAD AND THAT WOULD MAKE
SURE THAT.
NO FAMILY EVEN WHERE WE HAVE AN
EXCLUDED ADULT.
IS BELOW 50% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL AND THAT'S WHAT
WAS THE LEGISLATURE DROVE TOWARD
IN THE BUDGET LAST YEAR.
AND WHILE WE AGAIN APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR TAKING A VERY LARGE
IMPORTANT STEP THIS YEAR -- WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP WITH
THE DEAL AND TO PUT A LITTLE BIT
MORE MONEY IN THE BUDGET IN THIS
YEAR SO WE STAY ON THAT PATH TO
GET TO WHERE WE AGREE TO LAST
YEAR.
SO THAT THAT'S THAT'S OUR THAT'S
WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE CHIEF
THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU THAT COMES FROM
FINANCE.
IT'S ONLY IT'S A QUESTION -- SO.
THE PRE SHEET FIRST OF ALL I
THINK GOVERNOR -- FOR FOR FOR
RELATIONAL INCREASE -- AND IS
PROPOSAL AND CERTAINLY THAT'S
SOMETHING I THINK WE'RE IN
LEGISLATURE'S VERY OPEN.
TO LIKE THE IDEA -- IT'S BEEN
THEY'LL.
RECOGNIZE THAT COVERS POSING A
CROSS THE BOARD CUT ONLY SAYS
HISTORICAL CONTENT I MEAN IT
COULD HAVE A GOOD CAR SUPPORT
INCREASE OUR INCREASE ACROSS THE
BOARD INCREASE SORRY.
YOU KNOW I DID COME IN THE
RECESSION -- THE BUT SO OF
COURSE FOR THE REASON AB SO
WEISS'S STRUGGLE REASON THE YOU
ONE IS SO FAR BEHIND.
THIS WAS A POLICY THAT DROVE
THAT OR IS IT SOMETHING ELSE I
MEAN BECAUSE WE WERE DOING A
GREAT THAT I MEAN.
THIS WAS LIKE BOTH BEFORE AND
AFTER RIGHT BECAUSE WE'RE DOING
ACROSS BOARD INCREASE PERCENTAGE
INCREASE.
THE REASON -- BEHIND BECAUSE
THEY WERE STARTED BEHIND SO WHY
A WISE AN EIGHTY ONE SO FAR
BELOW EVERYONE ELSE.
NOW YOU ANSWER THE QUESTION --
THIS IS LONG AS I'VE BEEN
WORKING AT CAL WORKS GRANTS
GOING BACK AT LEAST THIRTY YEARS
THE CIRCUMSTANCES ALWAYS BEEN
THE CASE -- IT WAS A DECISION
MADE BY THE LEGISLATURE NGUYEN
IN THE OLD A FDC DAYS -- IT AND
IT'S A DECISION THAT THIS LET
THE CURRENT LEGISLATURE COULD
CHOOSE TO FIX IT'S JUST A POLICY
AND BUDGETARY DECISION.
THAT HAS STOOD THE TEST OF TIME
UNFORTUNATELY AND ONE THAT WE
HOPE IS GOING TO GET REVISITED
OKAY SO THIS IS A REALLY LONG
STANDING AREA.
OKAY I'M GONNA SPECULATE BECAUSE
I WAS A DON'T HAVE EVIDENCE
SPECULATE THAT IF IT WAS THAT
LONG AGO THAT PROBABLY PEOPLE
SAID -- YOU KNOW THAT'S PROBABLY
A SINGLE.
PERSON DOESN'T HAVE KIDS WE
DON'T KNOW WE'RE WORRIED WE
THOUGHT OF A LOSS OF THE FEE AND
THAT THEY SHOULD GET ON FULL OF
THEIR BOOTSTRAPS AND GET THE
WORK IS THAT -- PERHAPS WAS
GOING ON BACK THEN THAT'S BEFORE
LIMITS TO WHERE PEOPLE WITH SO I
DON'T KNOW IS THAT MY GUESSING
WRONG MAYBE.
THE GAP BETWEEN THE ONE PERSON
IN THE TWO PERSON HOUSEHOLD SIDE
IS WELL OVER TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
IT'S SUCH A LARGE GAP IT'S HARD
EVEN JUST TO FIND THE GROUNDS A
YOU JUST DELIVERED.
HI HI.
I THINK YOU PROBABLY AT SOME
POINT WAS BASED ON THE ON THE
OLD STANDARD THAT WE HAD AROUND
THE THE EMBASSY SACK AS WE CALL
IT THE MINIMUM BASIC STANDARD
ADEQUATE CARE.
AND THAT -- WAS SOMEWHAT CLOSELY
ALIGNED WITH THE POVERTY LEVEL
FOR THAT INCOME SIZE AS OF
POVERTY WEALTH OF ADJUSTED
OVERTIME AND WE'VE STOP USING
THE OF THE SACK AS A WAY BE
SECOND RANTS.
THINGS I THINK JUST GOT EXTENDED
OUT OF WHACK OVER TIME OKAY.
SO LET ME JUST SAID AND LET ME
POSE QUESTION DIRECTED IS
ANSWERED IT I DON'T KNOW YEAH
I'LL TRY THE EASIEST THING IS
LET'S DEAL WITH IT WE HAVE MONEY
WILL DO OAK TREES ACROSS THE
BOARD I MEAN THIS THIS THE IN
TERMS OF POLICY.
ISSUE HAVING THIS DISPARITY
BETWEEN AN EIGHTY ONE AND FOR
WHATEVER HISTORICAL REASONS I
SAID I'D TO SPECULATE NO
EVIDENCE FOR ANYTHING AND I
THINK YOU BROUGHT SOME OTHER.
POINTS UP BUT AGAIN REALLY
HISTORICAL -- DO IS -- POLICY
ISSUE WITH SAYING THAT WE SHOULD
TRY TO GET THE YOU KNOW EVEN
THIS AT IN TERMS OF GETTING A
YOU ONE OUT -- SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE SUCH A DISPARITY BETWEEN
THE DIFFERENT -- THAT SYSTEM
UNIT SIZES.
A I THINK TO AT WHAT MR ALAMO
OUTLINED IN LA WAS OUTLINED HERE --
I THINK THAT'S THOSE ARE THE
CHOICES THAT THAT CAN BE MADE
SIX CERTAINLY WILLING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
BUT I JUST CHECKING THE
MINISTRATION DOESN'T HAVE ANY
POLICY ISSUES WITH THE IDEA OF
TRYING.
TO CLOSE THE GAP BETWEEN
ADMINISTRATIVE UNITS THAT WE
BASICALLY SAID WE DON'T THERE'S
NO POLICY REASON TO HAVE A
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF RELATIVE --
BENEFITS FOR DIFFERENT SIZE
ADMINISTRATIVE UNITS.
I THINK AT THIS POINT WE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO COMMENT ON
THAT SPECIFICALLY BUT I WOULD
SAY THAT THAT THIRTEEN POINT 1%
ACROSS THE BOARD WHEN IT WAS
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED LAST WAS.
TARGETING THOSE HOUSEHOLDS OF
TWO AND THREE WHICH MAKE UP OVER
HALF OF THE CAL WORKS CASELOAD.
BUT WE COULD CERTAINLY REVISIT
IF IT'S LEGISLATURE'S INTENT TO
REDISTRIBUTE THAT OKAY WELL I I
YOU KNOW I I SAW THE DIVINE
LEVELS THE MONEY WHICH OBVIOUSLY
IS BUDGET COMMITTEE WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THAT FIVE ALSO THERE'S
AN UNDERLYING POLICY ISSUE RIGHT.
AND I THINK -- AND THEN THEIR
HEAD ASSESS PRICE OF HISTORICAL
ROOTS WHICH WE MAY NOT KNOW IN
THE MISTS OF TIME -- BUT I'M
JUST WONDERING BASICALLY HE
WOULD WHO ARE PERPETUATING THAT
WHATEVER THAT POLICY CHOICE WAS
BACK THEN.
YOU KNOW MAYBE -- AND SO
THINKING LIKE IS THAT SOMETHING
WE SHOULD BE FIXING IS MAYBE
BASED ON ASSUMPTIONS THAT EITHER
OF OUR WORK.
FOLLOW ARE INCORRECT NOW RIGHT
SO FOR EXAMPLE NOW THE SITUATION
IS IS THAT -- AND I APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S EMPHASIS ON YOU
KNOW TREAT ON CHILDREN OF
PEDIATRICIAN A FATHER -- AND THE
A. S. IT STATES THAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HOUSEHOLDS THAT DEPARTED REASON
THE TEN A. L. MYSTERY OF UNIT
ONE IS BECAUSE THERE MAY BE
OTHER PEOPLE IN HOUSEHOLD.
TWO DISCS FIRE SIDE METED OUT
BITS THAT MAY NOT BE WHAT PEOPLE
CONCEIVE THAT MY ASSUME THE
HOUSEHOLD IS CORRECT.
IS THAT IT GETS THE POINT YOU'RE
MAKING.
YEAH.
COMMENTS FROM LA ABOUT THAT.
I MEAN TO JUST.
BRIEFLY WE'RE NOT AWARE OF
HISTORICAL.
SORT OF REASON FOR THIS THE
DISTRIBUTION OF OF GRANTS ACROSS
THE A USE NOW AN SIMILARLY.
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL IS IN
A PERFECT MEASURE.
DIFFERENCES AMONG FAMILY SIZES --
IT MIGHT BE MORE STANDARD -- I'M
SPECULATING BUT WE'RE NOT AWARE
OF THAT SORT OF EXISTING.
STORY SO TO SPEAK OF OF WHY THE
GRANTS ARE ARE THE WAY THEY ARE
TODAY.
WELL THIS IS THE SITE OF HER
WELL UNDERLYING WHATEVER WE'RE
DOING RIGHT AND THIS IS THE
UNDERLYING IT THERE IS.
WHETHER EXPLICITLY OR IMPLICITLY.
SOME DECISION WAS MADE WAY BACK
WHEN THAT ADMINISTRATIVE UNIT OF
ONLY WIND SHOULD GET A LOT LESS
RELATIVE TO TWO OR MORE.
RIGHT.
AND FOR WHATEVER REASONS AND SO.
I GUESS THE QUESTION I HAVE IS
NOW IS IS THAT FOR WHATEVER AND
AGAIN APPRECIATE GOVERNOR
PUTTING MORE MONEY INTO THIS.
IS THAT DO WE WE CAN SIMPLY SAY
WE GIVE MORE MONEY WEEK
PERPETUATE THAT DIFFERENCE ABOUT
BC THEY'RE GOING TO BENEFIT TO
OR DO WE SAY THAT.
KNOW WHAT WE LOOK BACK POLICY
WAS WHATEVER REASON THAT
HAPPENED BEFORE MAYBE THAT'S NOT
SUCH A GOOD THING WE SHOULD
CONTINUE NOW YOU KNOW IT'S ONLY
ALSO UNDERSTAND ON THE DESIRE TO
GET MORE RESOURCES TO YOUR
FAMILY ON THE OTHER
ADMINISTRATIVE UNITS.
SO I AM NOT A CHANCE THAT BUT
THAT THE I GUESS I'M TRYING TO
DIG BACK INTO LIKE DOES IT MAKE
SENSE TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
ADMINISTRATIVE UNIT SIZE ONE BE
SO DESPERATE FROM.
THE OTHER ONES.
RIGHT I THINK THAT THAT BECAUSE
WE DIDN'T MAKE THAT POLICY NONE
OF US WERE HERE PROBABLY WANT TO
HAPPEN DOWN ON TO THE VOTE WAS
PRIDE VERY YOUNG BUT I HAD NO
IDEA I WAS A PART OF IT BUT I'M
JUST.
I'M JUST RAISING THAT ISSUE
BECAUSE I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
TO STEP BACK AND SAY WHAT IS OR
WHAT DO WE WANT TO POLICY
CALPERS TO BE.
REGARDS TO THAT.
SO HOPEFULLY THAT CAN BE A
LITTLE BIT BUT THE DISCUSSION IS
WORTH THINKING TOWARD MEET MAY
REVISE -- THAT -- AND EVEN EVEN
BEYOND IF WE DON'T DECIDE TO FIX
IT RIGHT AWAY -- BUT I I THINK
IT'S CERTAINLY IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE FIRST THOUGHT
ABOUT OUR PLAN I THINK THAT WAS
PART.
DISCUSSION WAS KIND OF LIKE WELL
WE DON'T SEE WHY THAT THEY
SHOULD BE SO DESPERATE AND MAYBE
SHOULD TYPING EVERY THING ALL
THE VOTES UP TO THE SAME LEVEL.
CELL.
BUT IF THERE'S A GOOD POLICY
RATIONALLY KEEP THAT DIFFERENCE
I'M ALWAYS OPEN TO HEARING IT
BUT I'M NOT HEARING IT YET SELF
OKAY.
ANYTHING ELSE IN.
ALL RIGHT.
BUT I THINK IN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE GOVERNOR.
FOR FUNDING FOR THE BEING TOO
SELF BY TWO IF WE DO.
THE LACK OF GRATITUDE THERE FOR
THAT OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE THE ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR PC P. AND OVERVIEW
OF THE CALVERTS HOME VISITING
INITIATIVE.
THANK YOU CARE.
I'LL GIVE A BRIEF OVERVIEW FIRST
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENTS VERY EXCITED TO BE
AUNCHING THE COW WORKS ON
VISITING INITIATIVE AND IT'S
LAUNCHING FORTY FOUR COUNTIES AS
PART OF THIS FOR CYCLE.
HOW WE FEEL THAT LEVERAGING THIS
HOME VISITING SERVICE IN THE
COLLEGE PROGRAM REALLY PRESENTS
A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO PROMOTE
TO GENERATION POLICIES AS MISS
JOHNSON NOTED EARLIER?
THAT REALLY MEET THE NEEDS OF
BOTH THE PARENTS AND THEIR
CHILDREN.
COUNTIES ARE LEVERAGING FOR
DIFFERENT EVIDENCE BASED MODELS
INCLUDING HEALTHY FAMILIES
AMERICA PARENTS AS TEACHERS
NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIPS IN
EARLY HEAD START IN ADDITION FOR
COUNTIES PROPOSED NEW UNIQUE
MODELS THAT ALSO MEANT THE
EVIDENCE STANDARDS -- AND RIGOR
OF THE INITIATIVE AND ARE ARE
LAUNCHING THE GUNNERS JANUARY
BUDGET INCLUDES A PROPOSAL TO
MAKE COME VISITING AN ONGOING
PROGRAM COMPONENT AND CAL WORKS
IN FOR THIS REASONS IT'S
NECESSARY FOR STAFFING TO
SUPPORT AND MAINTAIN THE PROGRAM.
WHICH LEADS TO THE DISCUSSION OF
THE BCP -- THIS VCP REQUEST A
TOTAL OF SIX POSITIONS ONE STAFF
MANAGER THREE ASSOCIATE -- THREE
GPA IS AND ONE OUR EIGHT PLUS
WELLS ONE RESEARCH PROGRAM
SPECIALIST IMPLEMENT THE H. B.
I'D THIS BCP IS CONSISTENT WITH
STATUTORY MANDATES THE CHURCH
CDSS WAS -- SERVING AS THE
PRIMARY IMPLEMENTATION ROLE FOR
THE INITIATIVE.
THESE RULES WILL PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR THIRD PARTY
EVALUATOR TRACKING UPDATES TO
THE LEGISLATURE IT CETERA.
AS FAR AS OUR ME MOVE ON TO THE
QUESTION OF THE METRICS.
SENATOR SO WILL BE TRACKED AS A
CONDITION OF THE FUNDING
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES MUST
PROVIDE DATA NECESSARY TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM AND
DEMONSTRATE THE OUTCOMES OF
PARTICIPANTS AND CHILDREN BY
RACE ETHNICITY AND NATIONAL
ORIGIN.
PRIMARY AND SECONDARY LANGUAGE
AND COUNTY THE DATA COLLECTION
SHALL INCLUDE PROGRAM OUTCOMES
FOR BOTH THE PARENTS AND THE
CHILDREN SERVED IN THE PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS HOW THEY'RE ALLOCATED
IN THE MODELS UTILIZED IN THE
MEASURE SPECIFIC TO THE COW
WORKS OBJECTIVES.
SUCH AS PARTICIPATION OFFERED
WORK ACTIVITIES SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION INTO FOUR WHEEL FOR
TO WORK PLANS ACCESS TO REFERRAL
SERVICES.
AND SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION OF THE
HOME VISITING PROGRAM AS WELL AS
THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM ANNEXES
WITH EARNINGS IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS ELIO
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
QUESTIONS.
OKAY WELL I'VE I'VE FREE SHEET
THE OF THE ON GOING PAYMENT --
FOR INVESTMENT IN HOME VISITING --
SOMEONE WHO -- KNOWING FEATURES
OF IT WAS ON THE FIRST FIVE
COMMISSION MY COUNTY -- IN
THOUGH THAT THERE'S A LOT --
THAT TOM VISITATION HELPS REDUCE
CHILD ABUSE AND AS MANY OTHERBENEFITS AS WELL AND I
APPRECIATE THE THE PREVIOUS
GOVERNORS INVESTMENT IN THAT AND
OUR CURRENT GOVERNOR'S ONGOING
INVESTMENT TO MAKE IT ONGOING
EFFORTS SO THANK YOU IN.
EARLY ONE BE SURE YOU HAVE THE
STAFF.
TO CARRY THAT OUT.
ALL RIGHT -- LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE APPLICATION FEE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS IN EMERGENCY CHILD
CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM.
AS CHAIR AT AND IN CENTER SO AND
THIS IS A HAVE HAD TECHNICAL
PROPOSAL REALLY AND ALIGNMENTS
WITH -- EMERGENCY CHILDCARE
BRIDGE FOR FOSTER CHILDREN WITH
THE REST OF THE CHAPTER SUBSIDY
PROGRAMS -- TO INSURE THAT ANY
EXAM AT ANY ANY PROVIDERS EXEMPT
FROM BEING LICENSE TO HAVE THE
COMPREHENSIVE BACKGROUND CHECK A
MAP THE FEES ASSOCIATED WITH
RECEIVING THAT BACKGROUND CHECK
COULD BE REIMBURSED AS THEY ARE
ANOTHER SUBSIDY PROGRAMS.
OKAY ANY COMES FROM MILLENNIAL.
FINANCE QUESTIONS.
ALSO.
THERE WE ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT
THE SUPPORT FOR REIMBURSING THE
FEES CAN BE ABSORBED IN EXISTING
DOLLARS.
OKAY EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT SOUNDS
GOOD LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER SIX TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
WERE CONSENT OF NEED.
WHEN'S TO PARA POPULATION.
THANK YOU CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBER
OF THE TRAILER BILL AS PURELY
TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND IT'LL
LINES THE STATE LAW WITH CURRENT
PRACTICES AS WELL AS THE BUDGET.
OKAY COMMENTS VALUE.
RIGHT FINANCE.
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS OKAY
EVERYONE AGREES WITH THAT ALL
RIGHT SOUNDS GOOD.
OKAY WELL -- SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO.
NOW IS -- WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS -- AND WELL ACTUALLY IF
SOMEONE.
A REVIEW THROUGH -- ISSUE NUMBER
SIX SIGN OF MANY PEOPLE RE SPOKE.
ON THE ON ISSUE NUMBER TWO ROUND
STAGE ONE BUT IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER FURTHER.
COMMENTS ON THOSE ITEMS BEFORE A
MOVE INTO THEIR AND PROPOSALS
INVESTMENT THESE COME THE
MICROPHONE THANK YOU WHAT
GOVERNOR'S THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA WELL FOR RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS.
ARMEN NEW KID ON THE BLOCK BUT I
REMEMBER THE NINETEEN SEVENTY
MONDAY START THE GRANT STRUCTURE.
THE THERE WERE NO SANCTIONS.
SO YOU DIDN'T HAVE ONE PARENT
FAMILIES -- WAS A RARITY AND
THAT'S WHY THE DISCREPANCY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HE'S AN INDEFINITE CHILDREN NOW
AND SUPPORT ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE
AND THE TRUST LINE.
BAD TRAILER BILL THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON MARTHA
GROW REPRESENTED THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
WE ARE VERY THANKFUL IN SUPPORT
OF THE COVERAGE RENT INCREASE --
WERE SUPPORT OF THE CAL WORKS
HOME VISITING PROGRAM -- HOWEVER
WITH THE CAL WORK SINGLE
ALLOCATION RECOMMENDATION WE
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
YOU -- YOU KNOW THERE WERE A LOT
OF ADJUSTMENTS WE CAN NEED TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
WELCOME.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ON THE COW
WORKS GRAN INCREASE WERE ALSO
GRATEFUL FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL BUT WANNA.
ALAINA MY COMMENTS WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE WESTERN
CENTER.
WELCOME AT A FREE NEW BURGER
FROM THE CHILD CARE LAWCENTER
ALSO ALIGNING MY COMMENTS WITH
WESTERN CENTER REGARDING THE CAL
WORKS GRANT INCREASES.
AND SUPPORTING THE TRUST LINE A
TECHNICAL FIX OKAY.
THANK YOU AND THIS IS ONE MORE
PERSON COMING UP [inaudible]
JACKIE. ONE AGAIN WITH GRAYSON
AND HELP OUR IN CALIFORNIA --
JUST WANT TO SUPPORT THE COW
WITH INCREASES IN THE ADVOCATE
PROPOSALS THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU.
RIGHT SEEN ALSO THE MICROPHONE
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUES
NUMBER SEVEN WE HAVE I BELIEVE
EIGHT PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT
SO -- ALL RIGHT SO LET'S START
OFF WITH US STRENGTHENING THE
EARNED INCOME DISREGARD AND WE
HAVE FRANK MECCA IS A RADIO BUT
THE THANKFUL THANK YOU DOCTOR
PAN AND WHILE I A MUCH YOUNGER
THAN KEVIN AS LANEY AND I WAS
HERE.
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE --
CONSTRUCTED THE CALYX PROGRAMS
IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN AND AT
THAT TIME IT WAS A BIPARTISAN
BILL WAS SIGNED BY THEN GOVERNOR
PETE WILSON AND ONE OF THE CORE
TENANTS OF CAL WORKS WITH THAT
WORK SHOULD PAY. FOR WELFARE
RECIPIENTS WHO DO THE HARD WORK
TO MOVE INTO THE WORK FORCE THEY
SHOULDN'T BE SO UNDULY PENALIZE
THAT THEY LOSE THEIR SUPPORT.
AND SO THE LEGISLATURE
OPERATIONALIZE THAT TENET IN A
COUPLE OF WAYS IN THE EARNED
INCOME DISREGARDS ONE OF THEM.
THE EARNED INCOME DISREGARD IS A
FEATURE THAT ALLOWS CLIENTS TO
RETAIN A PORTION OF THEIR
EARNINGS.
SINCE -- AND A PORTION OF THEIR
GRANTS.
UNTIL THEIR INCOME IS
SUFFICIENTLY IGH ENOUGH THAT WE
THINK THAT THEY CAN MANAGE THE
TRANSITION TO SELF SUFFICIENCY
WITHOUT CONTINUED SUPPORT.
AS THE EARNINGS GROW THE THE
GRANT GRADUALLY SHALLOWS -- AND
SO CLIENTS COULD COMBINE
EARNINGS THERE GRANT AND OTHER
WORK SUPPORTS LIKE CHILD CARE
AND TRANSPORTATION AND OTHER
TYPES OF ASSISTANCE -- AND HAVE
A GRADUAL BRIDGE TO SELF
SUFFICIENCY.
THE PROBLEM IS THE WORK
INCENTIVE -- THAT WAS CREATED ON
A BIPARTISAN BASIS HAS DEGRADED
SIGNIFICANTLY BY ALMOST 50%.
IT HASN'T BEEN UPGRADED IN THE
TWENTY YEARS TWENTY TWO YEARS
SENSE CAL WORKS WAS CREATED.
AND SO INFLATION AND INCREASES
IN THE MINIMUM WAGE OF DEGRADED
THE VALUE.
HAD THE EARNED INCOME DISREGARD
WHICH IS CURRENTLY TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS AND THEN
50% OF OF THE REST OF YOUR
INCOME.
AT THAT -- DISREGARD BEEN
UPDATED FOR INFLATION AND THE
MINIMUM WAGE IT WOULD CURRENTLY
BE FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS AND 50%
TO ALMOST DOUBLE.
AS A RESULT WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS
MORE OF A CLIFF THAN A BRIDGE --
AND IT'S JEOPARDIZING THE
SUCCESS OF HELPING -- MOVE
PEOPLE FROM WELFARE TO WORK AND
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE ACCORDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET POLICY
CENTER -- IN THERE EXCELLENT
RECENT ANALYSIS A PERSON WHO WAS
WORKING AT A FULL TIME MINIMUM
WAGE JOB AND CAL WORK STARTED --
WOULD STILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR A
MODEST GRANT AND THE OTHER
SUPPORT FROM THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM.
A PERSON TODAY EARNING MINIMUM
WAGE IS OFF CAL WORKS -- WITHOUT
A GRANT AND WITHOUT THOSE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES LIKE
TRANSPORTATION.
IT'S A TERRIBLE CATCH TWENTY TWO
FOR CLIENTS.
THEY ARE FACED WITH THE CHOICE
OF ACCEPTING MORE WORK -- BUT
PERHAPS BEING PUSHED OFF THE
PROGRAM IN THE LOSING THE
CRITICAL SUPPORTS THEY NEED TO
MAINTAIN THEIR CONNECTION TO THE
WORK FORCE.
THAT SAME CLIENT IN -- AT THE
BEGINNING OF CAL WORKS FACED A
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY MARKET
THAT WAS THREE TIMES LESS
EXPENSIVE.
RENTS HAVE HAVE RAISED THREE
TIMES THE RATE OF WAGES AND
INFLATION AND SO THAT CLIENT
TODAY WHO IS NOW OFF A ALSO
FACES AN UNPRECEDENTEDLY
UNPRECEDENTED EXPENSIVE HOUSING
MARKET. TO OUR PROPOSAL IS TO
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS
REYES THAT THE DISREGARD -- TO
ACCOUNT -- FOR THAT MINIMUM WAGE
AND AND CURRENT AND SCHEDULED TO
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES AND
INFLATION.
IT WOULD PHASE IN OVER TWO YEARS
TO SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS AND 50%
AND THERE AND THEN GOING FORWARD
IT WOULD BE INDEXED -- FOR FOR
INFLATION -- WERE NOT INCREASING
THE GENEROSITY OF THE DISREGARD
AS WE PROBABLY SHOULD -- BUT WE
THINK THAT IT -- IT'S AN
IMPORTANT -- POLICY THAT WOULD
ALSO HELP US WITH THE FEDERAL W.
P. R. BECAUSE THOSE CLIENTS WHO
ARE KICKED OFF OF AID.
PREMATURELY ARE ALSO KICKED OUT
OF OUR DENOMINATOR -- IN OUR
NUMERATOR AND SO IT WOULD HELP
US MAINTAIN OUR FEDERAL
COMPLIANCE AS WELL.
OKAY THANK YOU.
COMES FROM THE SOCIAL SERVICES.
THANK YOU THE OTHER PERSON
RECOGNIZES THAT THE ID IS
OVERDUE FOR AN UPDATE ESPECIALLY
WHEN CONSIDERING AS MR MY
CONNOTED ON GOING IN PLAN
UPDATES TO THE MINIMUM WAGE AND
SUPPORTS PROGRESS THAT ALLOWS
INCENTIVIZE IS FAMILIES TO
ENGAGE IN THE WORK FORCE WHILE
STABILIZING IN DEVELOPING
ADDITIONAL SKILLS.
IN OVERCOMING.
ADVERSITY THE DEPARTMENT
ENCOURAGES THE CONSIDERATION --
OF ALL THE VARIOUS PROPOSALS.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THOSE EFFORTS IN
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND EXAMINING THOSE FISCAL
RESULTS IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
LEGISLATORS PRIORITIES IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PRIORITIES.
I THANK YOU AND I WILL RECOGNIZE
THAT -- FINANCIAL POINT OUTSIDE
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND
ALSO THE AGENCY LAST RECOGNIZE
NOT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
BUT BEYOND THAT I APPRECIATE THE
TECHNICAL COMMENTS.
THAT LEO.
SIMILARLY -- WE'VE BEEN
REVIEWING THE PROPOSAL AND ARE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
YOUR STAFF AS THE SUBCOMMITTEE
THINGS.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
CITY IRENE I KNOW IT IS A ALL
RIGHT BUT IF YOU EVER HAVE ANY
MORE YES CENTER STONE.
I JUST WANT TO SAY IT -- IT MAY
NOT BE IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
BUT I THINK YOU MAKE AVERY
VALID ARGUMENTS AS TO WHY WE
SHOULD BE ENTERTAINING THIS
BECAUSE WE WANT TO JUST PUSH
PEOPLE ARE.
ARTIFICIALLY OVER THE CLIFF
UNTIL THEY'RE READY TO BE SELF
SUFFICIENT SO.
YOU'RE IN CONTROL THE MINIMUM
WAGE YOU DON'T CONTROL ACOSTA
HOUSING AND SO
I THINK IT'S A VERY --
BENEFICIAL REQUEST THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND TELLING US ABOUT
IT.
AND I TO THINK.
I MEAN CERTAINLY THERE'S A LOT
OF FUN GOOD POLICY RATIONALE FOR
I GUESS IS HAS ANYONE LOOKED AT
AND I KNOW TO BE HARD TO STUDY
BECAUSE THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT
SOMEONE'S APPROACHING IT THEN IS
MAKING CERTAIN DECISIONS SO THEY
MAY MAKE DIFFERENT DECISIONS IF
THE INCOME DISREGARD.
BUT ENOUGH TO TO ME.
YEAH WE TALK ABOUT THE PLANNING
PHASE LOAD BECAUSE ECONOMIES
CONTINUE TO PROVE -- BUT ALSO TO
WHAT DEGREE ARE WE ARE PEOPLE --
THEM FOR GOING OUR OPPORTUNITIES
TO EVENTUALLY GET OFF RIGHT
BECAUSE THE FOOD BECAUSE THE
ISSUE ISN'T THAT -- L. CAL WORKS
I'M JUST NOW GETTING WELFARE AND
GETTING YOU KNOW CHECKS FROM THE
GOVERNMENT RIGHT IT'S ABOUT ALL
SPORTS.
AND SO THEY LOSE EVERYTHING
RIGHT AND SO AND THEN THERE'S
LESS LIKELY TO BE SUCCESSFUL I
MEAN THAT'S WHAT WE TRIED TO
BUILD THIS THING AROUND THAT WAS
KIND OF PART OF THE DEAL -- SO --
YOU KNOW I AM JUST WONDERING
LIKE IF WE HAD IF WE RAISE THIS
REGARD BECAUSE THEY ALWAYS GOING
COST X. NUMBER DOLLARS BECAUSE
WE WOULD HAVE UP OF WHAT ELSE
BUT IF WE DON'T DO IT.
WHEN OVERFLOWED WE FOR GOING OUT
OF THERE'S ANYBODY'S I'D DONE
ANY SORT OF A LOOK I KNOW IT'S
REALLY HARD THING TO FIGURE OUT?
AS IT WENT IN ANY ASSESSMENT AS
TO THERE WAS RESEARCH THAT WE
BASED CALYX ON THAT SHOW THE
POLICIES LIKE EARNED INCOME
DISREGARDS ACTUALLY DID INCREASE
WORK.
AND INCREASE OUR CONNECTION TO
THE WORK FORCE AND REDUCE YOUR
LIKELIHOOD OF COMING BACK ON TO
THE CAL ARTS PROGRAM.
IT WAS BASED ON SOLID RESEARCH I
DON'T THINK WE'VE.
WE'VE LOOKED FROM A RESEARCH
STANDPOINT ABOUT HOW HOW MUCH
WE'VE LOST THOSE ADVANTAGES AS
THE EARNED INCOME DISREGARD --
HAS ERODED BUT BASED ON THE
SCIENCE THAT THE DID THAT THE
DISREGARD IS BASED ON IN THE
FIRST PLACE IT'S CLEARLY THE
CASE THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT
ARE TURNING BACK ON TO THE ROLES.
WHO WOULDN'T BE -- BECAUSE THAT
THE INCENTIVE AND THE SUPPORT
HAS HAS WANED -- AND AND MY
CONCERN IS IS THAT NOW WE HAVE A
CLOCK SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THE
MAIN APPEAL TURNED BACK BECAUSE
THE CLOCK RAN OUT BUT NOW WE
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH FAMILIES TO
BOTH CAN'T GET IT BECAUSE OF THE
CLOCK.
BUT WE ALSO SET THEM UP FOR
FAILURE SO I MEAN I'M JUST
WHINING ABOUT THE COST OF THAT.
NOW I MEAN AS WE AS AS WE LOOK
AT THE COST OF AT IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH DSS.
I THINK WE WE OUGHT TO LOOK FOR
F. NOT STE YOU KNOW SCIENCE BUT
AT LEAST SOME PROXY VARIABLES.
TO ESTIMATE THE LIKELY REDUCE
CHURN EFFECT OF MAKING THIS KIND
OF INVESTMENT.
OF ANY THEM THAT IT COVER IN
ADDITION I'D LIKE TO NOTE IN
WE'VE PROVIDED THIS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IS HE TO BE DAY WILL
MAKE YOU AWARE OF IT AS WELL
THAT THERE'S POTENTIAL COST
pSAVINGS IN ADMINISTRATIVE
SAVINGS WITH INCREASING THE
INCOME REPORTING THRESHOLD ALONG
SIDE THE E. ID -- AS A POTENTIAL
COST SAVING AND STABILIZING
MECHANISM ALONG SIDE.
OKAY WELL LIKE THAT TO SELL ALL
RIGHT.
OKAY SO YEAH I I MEAN I THINK
THAT.
THE HOPEFULLY I REALIZE AS A BIG
I MEAN WE'RE WORKING OUT THE
NUMBER HAS A SOMEWHAT YOU KNOW
THE THE THE THE PRICE TAG BUT
ADDED MINIMUM AND I'M HOPING WE
CAN DO SOMETHING LIKE THIS BUT
MINIMUM AT LEAST TO A PILOT AND
GET SOME MORE DATA.
RIGHT BECAUSE I DON'T THINK WE
REALLY.
NO.
I MEAN I'M.
I THINK THAT'S NOT GONNA CLASSES
MUCH AS WE THINK IT IS THAT'S
WHY I WONDER.
AND AND THAT THAT THAT THAT THIS
IS ONE OF THE THAT'S THAT'S WHY
THESE THINGS LIKE.
IF WE DON'T DO IT NOW DO WE
REALLY AND IT'S EASY TO SAY WELL
IT'S GONNA COST EXT NUMBER
BECAUSE NOW THE NOW THIS MAY
PEOPLE THAT SET UP IT'S NOT A
STREAMLINED CALCULATION RIGHT.
AND SAID IF WE CAN DO
ADMINISTRATIVE EFFICIENCIES
PEOPLE GALLON BEING ABLE TO COME
OFF AND STAY OFF.
AND BE IN THE WORKPLACE -- THAT
IS HARDER TO CAPTURE THAT THAT
COSTS SO I'D TELL I'M NOT A BAD
WAY I'M NOT PROPOSING TO SAY
THAT WE SHOULD DO PILE INSTEAD
BUT IF WE FOR SOME REASON CAN'T
GET TO BE CONVINCED PEOPLE AT
LIKE WE MAKE ASSUMPTIONS AND
MUCH BIGGER BUDGET ITEMS.
BASED ON HARD DATA THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THAT REASONABLE PEOPLE MAKE
REASONABLE ASSUMPTIONS BASED ON
THE BEST AVAILABLE INFORMATION.
AND WE CERTAINLY HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO MAKE SOME OF
THOSE ASSUMPTIONS IN THIS
PROPOSAL I BELIEVE.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE
ON TO BEST NUMBER TO CAL WORKS
TWO POINT OH AUTOMATION I THINK
YOU'RE UP AGAINST DOCTOR PAN
THIS IS A ONE TIME -- FUNDING
REQUEST OF ABOUT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. TO AUTOMATE TOOLS THAT
HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED AS PART OF
THAT CAL WORKS TO PLANO PROJECT.
SO THE DSS FOLKS TOLD YOU ABOUT
CAL OR IN AS A COMPANION TO CAL
OR THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN PARTNERING.
WITH MATHEMATICA POLICY RESEARCH
AND OTHER -- AND UP AND ENGAGING
ADVOCATES AND LEGISLATIVE STAFF.
TO IMPROVE THE WAY WE DO CASE
WORK TO TRY TO TO TRY TO GET AT
THIS MORE HOLISTIC BROADER SAID
ABOUT CALMS -- THE UTILIZING
BRAIN SCIENCE BEHAVIORAL
RESEARCH -- ON HOW ADULTS LEARN
AND BUILD CRITICAL SKILLS.
IT'S A CULTURE SHIFT AWAY FROM
THE COMPLIANCE DRIVEN.
CASE MANAGEMENT APPROACH IN
TOWARD ONE THAT'S BASED ON
RESPONSIVE REAL INTERACTIONS
BETWEEN THE CASE MANAGER IN A
CUSTOMER -- BASED ON IDENTIFYING
PLANNING AND ACHIEVING GOALS
THAT BUILD ONE UPON EACH OTHER
IT'S IT'S A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
WAY.
OF DOING CASE WORK MATHEMATICA
POLICY RESEARCH OUR PARTNERS
DEVELOPED AN INCREDIBLE SUITE OF
TOOLS TO HELP CASE WORKERS TO
THEIR JOBS I SHOULD SAY MISS
NIKOLAI WAS THE PRINCIPAL
INVESTIGATOR WITH MATHEMATICA
BEFORE SHE WAS STOLEN AWAY -- BY
DSS -- A WIN WIN FOR ALL OF US I
BELIEVE -- BUT THOSE THE SUITE
OF TOOLS THIS IS A VOLUNTARY
PROJECT THAT THE COUNTIES OF
ENGAGED INVOLUNTARILY AND IN
ORDER TO INCREASE THE TAKE UP WE
HAVE TO MAKE IT EASIER I THINK
FOR WORKERS HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE
TOOLS.
AND IDEALLY WE WOULD EMBED THOSE
TOOLS INTO THE COMPUTER SYSTEM
THAT THEY'RE ALREADY USING SO
THAT THAT DATA AND THE TOOLS CAN
BE HELPFUL MOST HELPFUL FOR CASE
MANAGEMENT.
AND FOR RESEARCH AND SO THAT IS
OUR PROPOSAL.
COMES FROM THE PARSER SERVICES.
JUST BRIEFLY NOTE THE SUPPORT OF
SEATED MEDIA AND CONTINUING TO
EXPLORE AND APPRECIATE THE
COUNTIES EFFORTS AROUND TWO
POINT NO KNOWING THAT IT'S NOT
OUR INITIATIVE BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT THEY
LEARNED NOT AND SUPPORTING THEM
AS WERE ABLE.
TO OKAY GREAT HELLO [inaudible]
FINANCE.
CORRECT THANK YOU THANKS FOR
MUCHAS.
THREE QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT OKAY.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER --
INVESTMENT AMBER THREE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR HOME
VISITING INITIATIVE AND I THINK
WITH ANGELA RATHER WELL HELLO
WELCOME FROM THE CHILDREN NOW.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
HI MY NAME IS ANGELA RUFFLING
HERE CONSIDER NOW AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
COMMITTEE TO BUILD UPON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
INVESTMENT.
IN THE CAL WORKS HOME VISITING
INITIATIVE BY ALLOCATING AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE MILLION
TO THE PROGRAM.
AND CORPORATE IN KEY TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS IN ORDER TO ENHANCE
AND EXPAND VOLUNTARY EVIDENCE
BASED ON VISITING FOR CAL WORKS
FAMILIES.
INCREASING SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH
POINTS EARLY CHILDHOOD IS A
CRUCIAL PERIOD OF TIME. TO
ESTABLISH CHILDREN'S FOUNDATION
FOR LIFELONG HEALTH WELL BEING
AND SUCCESS AND IT MAKES IT
CLEAR THAT POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIPS ARE WHAT FUELS
EARLY BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
IN THE FIRST FEW YEARS OF LIFE
BABIES BRAINS ARE FORMING MORE
THAN ONE MILLION NEURAL
CONNECTIONS EVERY SECONDS.
AND ALTHOUGH POVERTY AN UNMET
NEEDS -- CAN WE CAN THIS
ARCHITECTURE STABLE NURTURING
RELATIONSHIPS AND PARENT CHILD
INTERACTIONS BUT FOR THE IMPACTS
OF ADVERSITY AND FOSTER
RESILIENCY [inaudible]
OUR IT'S A CRITICAL TIME TO
SUPPORT FAMILIES WITH DUAL
GENERATION PROGRAMS LIKE
VOLUNTARY EVIDENCE BASED HOME
VISITING -- WHICH CAN REINFORCE
PARENTS OWN EFFORTS AND SKILLS
AND ALSO HAVE DEMONSTRATED A
SPECTRUM OF POSITIVE OUTCOMES
THAT CAN PROVIDE CHILDREN IN
FAMILIES WITH CRITICAL LIFELONG
PROTECTIVE FACTORS.
WE APPLAUD THE LEGISLATURE FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP LAST YEAR.
IN PUSHING THE ADMINISTRATOR
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION TO THINK
BIG ABOUT HOME VISITING AND CAL
WORKS HPI.
AND WHILE IT'S AN UNPRECEDENTED
EXPANSION OF HOME VISITING IN
FORTY FOUR COUNTIES -- CURRENT
FUNDING WILL ONLY GO FAR ENOUGH
TO REACH AN ESTIMATED 80% OF THE
ELIGIBLE POPULATION.
SERVE THE COWARDS HOME VISITING
INITIATIVE ENCOURAGES COUNTIES
TO LEVERAGE EXISTING LOCAL.
I. EVIDENCE BASED HOME VISITING
PROGRAMS WILL ALSO EMPHASIZING
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND THIS IS -- VERY SMART POLICY
BUT KEY TO THE SUCCESS OF THIS
APPROACH WILL BE DATA.
AND ALSO -- INSURING THAT -- THE
COVERED CGI'S SITUATED SMARTLY
IN THE LOCAL EARLY CHILDHOOD
LANDSCAPE.
BECAUSE THERE'S AN EXISTING
DIVERSE ARRAY OF HOME VISITING
ACROSS THE STATE AND THIS UNTIL
LAST YEAR THIS ODD NETWORK WAS
FULLY FUNDED BY FEDERAL AND
LOCAL FUNDS.
THERE'S A FOUNDATION TO BUILD
UPON BUT THERE ARE ALSO MULTIPLE
FUNDING STREAMS EXISTING
REGULATORY FRAMEWORKS AND VARIED
DATA CONNECT COLLECTION
MECHANISMS.
HALF OF THE COUNTIES FUNDED IN
THE H. B. I ALSO RECEIVE --
FEDERALLY FUNDED CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH HOME
VISITING SITES AND ALSO HAVE
EARLY HEAD START -- HOME
VISITING PROGRAMS IN FIRST FIVE
FUNDED FOR HOME VISITING
PROGRAMS IN ALMOST ALL OF THEM --
THESE ARE RELIABLE PARTNERS TO
WORK WITH THE STATE TO SCALE UP
THE PROGRAM BUT THEY NEED HELP --
WHEN LOCAL PROGRAMS AND PARTNERS
COLLABORATING OR WELL CONNECTED
THEY CAN WORK TOGETHER TO BETTER
MAXIMIZE SCARCE RESOURCES?
SO THESE EARLY YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTATION WE BELIEVE ARE
CRITICAL TIME -- TO FOCUSED ON
LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE CAL WORKS
FROM VISITING ISSUE AND BY DOING
SO WE ACTUALLY COULD MAXIMIZE --
MANY MANY MULTI FACETED --
THERE'S OF SUPPORT AND
ADDITIONAL NON TEN OF RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT TWO GENERATIONS
WITHIN THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM --
EFFECTIVE SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEMS OF COURSE MUST BE BACKED
BY INFRASTRUCTURE SO THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WILL NOT ONLY
PROVIDE CAPACITY TO SERVE A
GREATER NUMBER OF CAL WORKS
FAMILIES.
BUT ALSO SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES -- AROUND THE
WORK THEY NEED TO DO ON DATA AND
COORDINATING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
WE'RE ALSO REQUESTING KEY
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS WHICH WE'VE
OUTLINED IN A LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION ON
THANK YOU THOMAS FROM THE
PHARMACIST SERVICES.
YES THANK YOU SO THE DEPARTMENT
BELIEVES THAT THE PROPOSAL FROM
THE ADVOCATES OF MERITS AND THAT
FAMILIES WITH MORE THAN ONE
CHILD CAN INDEED BENEFIT FROM
HOME VISITING.
I WOULD NOTE -- FOR YOU THE
TWENTY SIX OF THE FORTY FOUR
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES TO DATE I
HAVE ALREADY PROPOSED EXPANDED
POPULATION'S IT'LL BE SERVING OF
THOSE TWENTY ONE PLAN TO SERVE --
PARENTS WITH MORE THAN ONE YOUNG
CHILD FIVE PLAN TO EXPAND
SERVICES TO CAL LEARN OF THE
TEEN POPULATION AND ANOTHER FIVE
HAVE PLANS TO EXPAND THE
SERVICES. TO PARENTS WITH OLDER
CHILDREN THOSE BETWEEN TWO AND
FIVE BY A IN ADDITION I WOULD
NOTE THAT WITH REGARD TO THE
EXPANSION COUNTIES ALREADY
EXPERIENCED SOME IMPLEMENTATION
THOUGH IS RELATED TO LOCAL
CONTRACTING PROCESSES BOARD OF
SUPERVISOR APPROVALS HIRING
TRAINING.
AND DEVELOPING A USING DATA
SHARING AGREEMENTS AND SO THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD RECOGNIZE THAT
IN MOVING FORWARD WE WILL BE
PERFORMING TECH PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ETCETERA
BUT THAT THAT CAPACITY P. IS
REALLY WILL MATTER -- I ALSO
KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS TO
EXPAND HOME VISITING PROGRAMS
ADMINISTERED BY C. PH.
BY ANOTHER TWENTY THREE MILLION --
AND LEAVE IT AT THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU VALUE
[inaudible]
FINANCE OKAY.
AT THIS PROPOSAL BECAUSE THERE
IS THAT THERE'S A YEP BECAUSE
MULTIPLE PROPOSALS SO HOW DOES
THIS FIT IN WITH ALL OF THOSE.
I'LL.
WE BELIEVE THE INVESTMENT OF THE
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WOULD ACTUALLY HELP TO
INTEGRATE -- AND COORDINATE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH FROM VISITING WITH THE
ETI AT THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVELS THAT WOULD BE -- A KEY A
KEY WAY THAT THE STATE COULD SET
THINGS UP WELL NOW TO MAXIMIZE
AND BE MORE EFFICIENT IN THE
LONG TERM IT'S REALLY -- A
CRITICAL TIME WHEN YOU'RE DOING
AN EXPANSION THIS BIG T BE
ATTENTIVE TO HOW WELL THE
DEPARTMENTS WHICH ARE ALREADY
DOING A GREAT JOB OF WORKING
TOGETHER BUT HOW WE COULD BETTER
RESOURCE THEM TO WORK TOGETHER
IN SMARTER WAYS [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
SHOULD THANK YOU ALL RIGHT --
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER FOR
RESTORATION OF THE SIXTY MONTH
TIME CLOCK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GIVE US A HEADS WAS COMING IF WE
DO AS AN AGENDA.
YES -- MISTER CHAIR MY CAROL
AGAIN WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY -- I'M HERE
TODAY TO TALK TO ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE THE LEGISLATURE TO
RESTORE THE TOWN OF SIXTY MONTH
TIME CLOCK AND I DO THIS AND ON
BEHALF OF BOTH WESTERN CENTER
AND THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION TODAY -- AS YOU KNOW --
CENTER DR PAN IN -- TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN TWELVE WE OOK MANY MANY
DEVASTATING BUDGET CUTS AND TO
THE THINGS THAT WE DID DURING
THAT TIME ONE IS THAT WE REDUCE
THE TIME ON AID.
FROM THE FEDERAL MAXIMUM OF
SIXTY MONTHS PUTTING US IN A
MINORITY OF STATES IN THE UNITED
STATES INCLUDING -- SEVERAL --
SOUTHERN STATES THAT CONTINUED
AB SIXTY MONTH CLOCKS OUR STATE
DOESN'T BIRD AND FORTY EIGHT
MONTHS AND THEN THE FOLLOWING
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE.
AGAIN UNDER THE DRESS OF A VERY
DIFFICULT BUDGET SITUATION -- WE
MADE CHANGES TO WE SPLIT THOSE
FORTY EIGHT MONTHS IN HALF
TWENTY FOUR FOR FLEXIBLE A
FLEXIBLE CLOCK TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS FOR THE MORE DIFFICULT
CAN OFF TO A WORK REQUIREMENTS.
I I THINK -- IN NOT JUST
OURSELVES BUT I THINK THE RAND
CORPORATION HAS -- CONFIRM THAT
THOSE CHANGES EXPRESSLY
SPLITTING THE CLOCK AND HAVE --
HAD VERY LITTLE IMPACT ON THE
ABILITY OF FAMILIES TO GET OUT
OF POVERTY -- NOW HAVING SAID
THAT I MEAN WE DO THINK THAT
THERE IS A BENEFIT TO PRESERVING
THE FLEXIBLE APPROACH WE THINK
ABOUT APPROACH ACTUALLY MAKES
SENSE IN LIGHT OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT YOU JUST HAD.
AROUND -- TOWN AFTER HOURS TWO
POINT NO FEE THE NEW APPROACH
THAT WERE USING THAT'S THE TO
GENERATION APPROACH MOVING AWAY
FROM THE OLD COMPLIANCE MODEL.
SO THAT FLEXIBLE APPROACH WE
BELIEVE MAKES A LOT OF SENSE AND
SO IN GOING BACK TO THE SIXTY
MONTH CLOCK WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
THE STATE TO EXTEND OUT THAT
FLEXIBLE PARTS OF THE ENTIRE
SIXTY MONTHS. TO ALLOW TEN OF
TWO POINT NO CALORIES TWO POINT
NO TO BE ABLE TO APPLY ITSELF AS
NEEDED -- THE OTHER THING THAT
WE WOULD SAY ABOUT THE NEED FOR
THE SIXTY MONTH CLOCK IS -- OUR
FAMILIES ARE NOT ALL THE SAME
AND THEY THEY THEY THEY SUCCEED
IN THE PROGRAM AT DIFFERENT
LEVELS AT DIFFERENT SPEEDS.
M. IN ADDITION TO THAT WE ALSO
KNOW WE HAVE A CASE LOAD NOW IS
IT'S GOTTEN SMALLER AND SMALLER.
THAT IS MORE COMPRISED OF
FAMILIES WHO HAVE MORE BARRIERS
TO OVERCOME I THINK WHEN YOU
HEAR RECIPIENTS COME OFF AND ONE
OF THE THINGS YOU'LL OFTEN HEAR
THEM SAY AS THEY WERE LEAVING A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SITUATION.
AT THE POINT THAT THEY ENTERED
INTO THE CASELOAD -- PEOPLE
OFTEN NEED MANY MONTHS TO TRY TO
GET THROUGH A SITUATION LIKE
THAT OUR CURRENT RULES STILL
REQUIRE PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE
MOST THE TIME IN WELFARE TO WORK --
SO MONSTER TAKING OFF WHEN THEY
REALLY CAN'T.
ENGAGE IN THE WAY THAT WE WOULD
LIKE AND YET WE STILL HAVE A
FORTY EIGHT MONTH CLOCK THAT
SORT OF PUTS THEM THERE.
AND THEN THE OTHER THING WE
WOULD SNOW TO IS THAT -- WE'VE
WE FREQUENTLY SEE THAT SOMETIMES
FAMILIES COME THROUGH THEY GET
OFF OF THE THE FIND A JOB
THEY'RE DOING WELL AND THEN
PERHAPS THE ECONOMY FALLS OUT.
AND THEN THEY HAVE TO COME BACK
ON AID FOR A SECOND A SECOND
SPELL SO HAVING THE FULL SIXTY
MONTHS ALLOWS THOSE FAMILIES TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE A CHANCE TO GET
RETRAIN AGAIN GET INTO AN
OCCUPAION.
THAT WILL ALLOW THEM TO GET OUT
OF POVERTY AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE WOULD URGE YOU -- TO SUPPORT
THE EXTENSION BACK TO A SIXTY
MONTH TIME CLOCK FOR CALYX.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
PARSER SERVICES ALEJO
[inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
RIGHT.
AMAZON OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL.
DID A GOOD JOB.
ALL RIGHT SO -- INTO THIS IS.
NOW IS THERE A MINISTERS THAT
ANYONE TELL.
YOU TO HAVE A CAT.
I MEAN THIS PROPOSALS COME UP
MULTIPLE TIMES WE HAVE A GUEST
MEDFORD ACOSTA THIS AND SEE THIS
AND RIGHT.
WE CAN CERTAINLY PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ACT IN
PROVIDE THAT CONSISTENT WE DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE IT.
OKAY NO WONDER.
THE LAST WEEK RIPPLES WE CAN AB
IN ADDITIONAL NEW INFORMATION
BASED ON THE CASE LET'S MADE UP
DATE THAT'S OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- MOVING ON TO CAL OR
AND CAL WORKS TO PLANO TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE.
WELCOME BACK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- AGAIN --
ON THIS ISSUE WEHAD A LOT OF
DISCUSSION TODAY ABOUT CALOR AND
CAL WORKS TWO POINT NO AND THE
SINGLE ALLOCATION AND I MADE AN
OR A PLEA EARLIER.
TO KEEP OUR FOCUS ON SINGLE
ALLOCATION.
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IN THIS
ARENA IS ARE TWO THINGS I THINK
ONE IS?
AS THE COUNTIES BEGIN TO
IMPLEMENT THE NEW TWO POINT OH
APPROACH -- WE FEEL THERE'S A
CONFLICT WITH THE EXISTING
STATUTORY STRUCTURE WHICH
CONTINUES TO PUSH TOWARDS --
WHAT WAS EARLIER DESCRIBED IN
OUR TESTIMONY DAYS THE OLD WORK
FIRST APPROACH A SO THE COUNTY
AND THE WORK PARTICIPATION RATE
ARE STILL OUT THERE?
THAT THE COUNTY IS STILL
REQUIRED TO FOLLOW THE STATUTE --
THE COUNTY IN SOME DEGREE IS
STILL BEING PUSHED -- TO TRY TO
ME WORK PARTICIPATION RATES EVEN
THOUGH WE KNOW THAT THAT IS NOT
REALLY A GOOD MEASURE WHAT WE
WERE DOING AND IT.
ALSO IS NOT CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
WE'RE DOING IN CALOR.
SO OUR RECOMMENDATION ON THIS I
REQUEST OF THE COMMITTEE IS THAT --
THE LEGISLATURE CREATE A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES THAT
WOULD TAKE A LOOK AT THE STATUTE
AND COME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT
CHANGES THAT WOULD BE NEEDED TO
BE MADE.
TO THE CASE THE STATUTE IN ORDER
TO FULLY EMBRACE THAT THE TOWN
OF TWO POINT OH TWO POINT OH
MODEL.
AND WE WOULD ALSO GET LEASE
RECOMMENDED YOU CONSIDER --
WHETHER OR NOT WE WOULD WANT TO
PUT SOME INTENT LANGUAGE IN THE
BUDGET THIS YEAR THE KIND OF BIG
KNOWLEDGE AND RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS IS HAPPENING.
AND THAT THERE IS GOING TO BE A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS IT'S GOING
TO COME BACK AND INFORM THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT POTENTIAL
POLICY CHANGES THAT MIGHT BE
NEEDED.
SO THAT'S OUR REQUEST IN THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU CON A COMPASS FROM
DEPARTURE SERVICES.
OHIO [inaudible]
FINANCE.
MEMBERS OKAY SO -- I GUESS IN
TERMS OF WELL THIS TERMS OF RE
LOOKING AT THEY OUT SOME REALLY
APPROACH RIGHT THE EXISTING
LANGUAGE RIGHT.
IS THAT MEANS THAT.
DOES THAT HAPPEN AS A ONE DONE
THAT FOR RULE SOUNDS LIKE ENOUGH
FOR A VERY LONG TIME I MEAN ARE
WE ARE WE TRYING TO MOVE TO A
DIFFERENT PLACE THAN WE WERE
BACK THEN RIGHT.
WE HAVE LEARNED A LOT NO DOUBT
YES WE LEARNED A LOT AT EIGHT IN
THE KIND OF HISTORY OF OUR
EXISTING PROGRAM I THINK PART OF
WHAT AT MR HERALD JUST LAID OUT
IN TERMS OF THE TWO POINT NO
INITIATIVE AS WELL AS WHAT WE
ARE PLANNING TO DO.
WITH THIS NEW WORLD WAR WILL
HAVE A LOT MORE INFORMATION AND
DATA RIGHT TO DEMONSTRATE WHAT
IS WORKING I THINK IT'S A IT'S
WERE HAPPY TO EXPLORE AN
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS TO TO
SEE WHAT ADDITIONAL.
MODIFICATIONS TO BE MADE STATURE
OKAY SO.
SO I THINK.
SO I THINK THAT -- HE COULD.
TO FIGURE OUT PROCESS FOR THAT
AND THEN OF COURSE.
BUZZ A LEGISLATORS WOULD LIKE TO
GET SOME ADVICE -- ABOUT -- IT
BECAUSE OF A RE FRAMING OUR
PROGRAM -- WE WE DON'T PEOPLE
LOOKING AT THE LANGUAGE F THE
STATUTE AND SAY WELL.
THAT'S AND IN CONFLICT ARE ARE
NOT SUPPORTIVE OF THE DIRECTION
RIGHT SO.
I WILL BE SURE CODE REFLECTS OUR
INTENTIONS SO AND OBVIOUS IT'S
OUR JOB HERE TO CHANGE THE CODE
BUT WE NEED SOME ADVICE AND HELP
ON THAT -- AND UP THAT IS THE
WILL WILL HAVE OUR OWN OPINIONS
ABOUT IT TOO BUT YEAH.
YEAH I'LL JUST MENTION HAT THE
THE CAL OR PROCESS IS ACTUALLY
THAT'S EMBEDDED WITHIN IT SO AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT WHAT.
WE'RE LEARNING FROM THE COUNTIES
PROGRESS IN EACH OF THE MEASURES
WE WILL BE LOOKING HOLISTICALLY
AS A STATE ON WHAT OTHER
MODIFICATIONS IN THE MADE THE
POLICY ALONG THE WAY THAT IS
PART OF HOW THAT THAT THREE YEAR
CONTINUOUS QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
CYCLES ENVISIONED SO.
ABSOLUTELY ANTICIPATE NOT ONLY
AND SHARING AND AND IDENTIFYING
WHAT ADDITIONAL POLICY CHANGES
NEED TO BE MADE A PROGRAM AT
DESIGN COMPONENT SEEM TO BE
MODIFIED BUT ALSO -- SETTING
THRESHOLDS AND BENCHMARKS ON
EXPECTATIONS OF SOME OF THOSE
MEASURES ALONG THE WAY SO BOTH
OF THOSE THINGS WERE ENVISIONED
IN THE CAL OR STATUTE WILL BE
PART OF OUR PROCESS BACK.
ALSO JUST AGREE AND AGAIN A
KNOWLEDGE IN IN TERMS OF MISTER
HELD COMMENTS THAT WHAT
CURRENTLY IS AND IS THIS
EXISTING STATUE RELATED TO WPR
THAT IS ALL BASED ON KIND OF THE
HISTORICAL PROGRAM AS IT WAS
DESIGNED TWENTY YEARS AGO.
AND PERHAPS LA -- YOU MIGHT LOOK
AT THAT.
TOO WE WILL BE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH APARTMENT AND OTHERS AND
YOU AND YOUR STAFF OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL MONTHS.
TO HELP THINK ABOUT THIS PROCESS
OKAY.
I FIND MYSELF UP HERE OFTEN
GOING BACK IN TIME GOING OKAY
WELL CAN WE FIX SOMETHING THAT
SEEMS WE JUST LIKE.
IT'S THE SIXTH.
WE'LL HAVE THAT SOMETIMES RATE
SOME SOME OLD HABITS NEED TO BE
CHANGED OKAY.
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT ITEM NUMBER --
SIX HOMELESS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
AND THE STRESS ON IN WELCOME
BACK [inaudible]
PLEASE [inaudible]
OKAY.
PLEASE BE IN.
I ALWAYS BRING SOME PAPER WITH
ME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KEVIN
AS THE NOW WITH CALLS FOR
CALIFORNIA WELL FROM RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION.
IN THIS BUT THE HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AND NOT ON
THE HAND OUT.
WHICH IS THE LIKE THE SCENES
WERE FAMILIES ARE HOMELESS.
THE HOMELESS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
IN CALIFORNIA HAS TWO PIECES ONE
IS TEMPORARY HOMELESS ASSISTANCE.
SOMEONE OF FAMILIES HOMELESS TO
GIVE ME A TEMPORARY HOME RENTS
ASSISTANCE FOR SIXTEEN DAYS.
AND THEN IF YOU FIND A PLACE.
THAT WILL HELP YOU WITH THE LAST
MONTH'S RENT PLUS A DEPOSIT.
NOT TO EXCEED 80% OF YOUR THE
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICE BENEFITS.
WHICH STUDENT NUMBER PROBLEMS SO
WE HAVE A BUNCH OF
RECOMMENDATIONS -- THE SIX
RECOMMENDATIONS. ONE IS TO
REPEAL THE SIXTEEN DAY.
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE POLICY OF
USE IT OR LOSE IT.
WHICH KERN THE CURRENTLY IF YOU
GET SIXTEEN DAYS YOU HAVE TO USE
A WITHIN THOSE SIXTEEN DAYS.
IF YOU TAKE A COUPLE OF DAYS AND
STAY WITH YOU AND AND THEN COME
BACK.
YOU LOSE THOSE TWO DAYS.
SO THIS -- THIS PROPOSAL SAYS.
YOU GET SIXTY DAYS AND YOU CAN
USE IT WITHIN A MONTH OR TWO
MONTHS OR WITHIN TWENTY DAYS.
SHOULD BE NO DISINCENTIVE FOR
BEING -- FOR BEING INNOVATIVE.
THE NEXT ONE IS.
TO ELIMINATE THE ONE YOU'RE.
LIMITATION ON HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE RIGHT DOWN TO GET
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE OF FEBRUARY.
AND THEN SOME IN JUNE THE LAND
OR THE VICKS TO BECAUSE THEY
FIND OUT THAT YOU'RE ON WELFARE.
YOU HAVE TO WAIT FOR NEXT
SEPTEMBER SO YOU HAVE TO HAVE
THE FAMILY OF TWO HAS TO BE IN
THE STREETS.
OF CALIFORNIA WAITING FOR
SEPTEMBER TO COME THREE COULD
APPLY FOR HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
AGAIN.
NOW SOME OF THESE POLICIES WERE
DEVELOPED IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WHEN WAS
DIFFERENT AND DESERVE THIS IS
THE MOON WE TRY TO BRING IT INTO
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
SO THIS PROPOSAL WOULD ELIMINATE
THE ONE YOU.
LIMITATION AND GIVE YOU HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE ANYTIME THAT YOU
HOMELESS YOU SHOULD GET HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE.
THE CURRENTLY WITH THE TEMPERATE
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE IS LIMITED
TO HOTELS OR MOTELS.
HOTELS AND MOTELS ONLY TAKE
CREDIT CARDS.
ENOUGH FOLKS DON'T HAVE CREDIT
CARDS.
SO AWFUL TO END UP IN THESE FREE
BAG.
CRIME INFESTED HOTELS OR MOTELS.
IN THIS PROPOSAL BASS HE WOULD
GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO USE
THAT MONEY.
SOMEWHERE ELSE THAT THEY COULD
USE THAT THE CONFINED BESIDES
THE HOTEL MOTEL THAT WOULD GET
HIM OUT OF THE STREET.
AND INTO.
A ROOF.
THE NEXT PROPOSAL IS TO GET DATA.
ON HOW MANY.
PEOPLE ON CAL WORKS A HOMELESS
RIGHT THOUGH WE HAVE NO IDEA.
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA?
AND THIS IS A PROPOSAL TO LOOK
AT THE TRY TO GET SOME DATA.
SO WE KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING OUT.
THE NEXT PROPOSAL IS TO COUNTY
OPTIONAL EXTENSION OF TEMPORARY
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE.
THEY GIVE YOU SIXTY DAYS
A PERMANENT HOMELESS. FOR
EXAMPLE.
IF YOUR TEMPER HOMELESS
ASSISTANT ENDS ON THE TWENTY
FIRST OF THE MONTH AND YOU GOT A
PERMIT A PLACE TO LIVE ON THE
FOUR ON THE FIRST.
THEY SHOULD GIVE YOU FIVE MORE
DAYS CITY COULD GET HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE.
AND THE FINAL PROPOSAL IS TO PUT
A KALRA. FOR THE EIGHTY FIVE
DOLLARS A DAY THAT THEY GIVE YOU.
AND I HAVE A CHART THAT SHOWS
YOU.
THAT THEY START OUT WITH THIRTY
DOLLARS AFTER ELEVEN YEARS A ONE
UP.
TO FORTY THEY WE WAIT FOR THAT
IS SEVEN YEARS TO GO UP TO SIXTY
FIVE AND THEN WE WAITED FOR THAT
A THIRTEEN YEAR IS. TO GO UP TO
EIGHTY FIVE THE SUGGESTIONS TO
HAVE A COLA.
SORRY THERE IT TAKES SO LONG.
THANK YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM
SOCIAL SERVICES WE WE WE JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANT BENEFIT THAT IT
THAT A SIXTEEN DAVE EMERGENCY
SHELTER PLACE FOR FAMILIES BUT
IT ALSO DOESN'T SOLVE THE FULL
NEED WE ENCOURAGE AND FULLY
SUPPORT COUNTIES THAT ARE
BLENDING IN BRAIDING THEIR
HOMELESS.
ASSISTANCE RESOURCES WITH THE
HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM AND AT
THEIR HOUSING.
I'M SUPPORT PROGRAMS OF LOCAL
RESOURCES THAT I'VE BEEN FUSED
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
ASSISTANCE SO I ENCOURAGE
CONTINUE DO THAT WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
OTHER WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN
IMPROVE AT THE PROGRAM.
OKAY THANK YOU -- COMMENTS
FAMILIAL [inaudible]
FINANCE.
QUESTION FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
NOW ALL RIGHT -- OKAY WELL
THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
THIS MOVE ON OKAY WE HAVE ITEM
NUMBER.
SEVEN THANKS.
EITHER SEVEN REPEAL COWARDS ACID
TEST -- SEE WHO'S JUST FOR
BUFFALO.
WESTERN CENTER NOW JUST STILL
HERE NOW [inaudible]
OKAY.
I SHOULD TRY JUST TO BRIEFLY
POINT OUT THAT -- I ALSO SERVE
ON HUMAN SERVICES AND HEARD
PRESENTATION OF A BILL BY SIR
WIENER ALONG THE SAME LINES I'VE
SOME FAMILIAR IT ISSUED ON THE
ONLY ONE LEFT IN THE DíAS WHOSE --
NOVEMBER SO REVENUE IN ORDER OF
REVENUE MAY BE IN ORDER.
OF MY APOLOGIES MY COLLEAGUE NOT
BEING HERE I KNOW SHE'S BEEN IN
OTHERS BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES
TODAY -- SO VERY VERY BRIEFLY ON
THIS MATTER -- OF CAL WORKS HAS
MANY ELIGIBILITY RULES THAT WE
HAD IN PLACE FOR A LONG TIME
HAVE AN INCOME RULE AND
OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO HAVE.
CHILDREN WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE PROGRAM AND ONE OF THE OF
THE RULES THAT WE HAVE IS WE
HAVE LIMITS ON ASSETS FOR
AUTOMOBILE IN CASH RESOURCES.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD ESSENTIALLY
ELIMINATE THOSE PROPOSALS ALLOW
PERSONS WITH SMALL AMOUNTS OF
ASSETS TO BE ABLE TO COME ON TO
THE PROGRAM -- WE THINK THAT THE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE ARE
ARE BEING PUSHED OFF HIS
RELATIVELY SMALL WE DON'T THINK
THIS WOULD BE A LARGE FISCAL
IMPACT IN THE CURRENT BUDGET
YEAR.
AND WE WERE ORDERED SUPPORT OF
ELIMINATION OF THOSE ASSETS
RULES THANK YOU COMMENTS FROM
SOCIAL SERVICES THIS VERY BRIEF
YOU RECOGNIZE THAT WHAT WE DON'T
HOLD A FORMAL POSITION ON THE
PROPOSAL WE DO KNOW THE
POTENTIAL.
LIMITATION OF ASSET THRESHOLDS
TO A POINT WOULD HAVE
ADMINISTRATIVE RELIEF AND WOULD
BOTH BE IN THE SPIRIT OF THE
PROGRAM AS WELL AS AGAIN
DECREASING THE BURDEN ON
COUNTIES.
THANK YOU OKAY [inaudible]
HELLO.
JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT POINT
THIS APPEARS TO BE AN ISSUE OF
SORT OF COMPARING THE COSTS AND
BENEFITS -- WE THINK WE THERE
MIGHT BE WAYS TO LOOK AT OR
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
ADMINISTRATIVE SAVINGS FROM.
ENFORCING THE OR OR REVIEWING --
ASSET TESTS ON AND THEN IN
ADDITION TO COSTS AND BENEFITS
HE THERE MIGHT BE OTHER POLICY
QUESTIONS THAT WOULD BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOUR STAFF AND
THINKING ABOUT THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS.
OKAY THANK YOU FINANCE.
OKAY SO -- YEAH I'D HAVING HEARD
THIS ISSUE PREVIOUSLY I THINK
SOMEONE SO WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
MINISTRY OF COST STRAIGHT IT'S A
IT'S BOTH A MYSTERY BURDEN ON
THE ELIGIBILITY COUNTY WORKERS
AS WELL AS THE PERSON WHO'S
APPLYING TO TRY TO DIG UP THE
RECORDS I THINK THERE'S SOME
ISSUES ABOUT FOR EXAMPLE.
YOU HAVE A CAR AND DEPENDING ON
HOW YOU ENDED UP THE THERE --
HAVING TO SELL A CAR OF CAR CARD
IT'S OF OF OF A CERTAIN VALUE
MINIMUM VALUE WHICH MIGHT NEED
TO BY THE WAY WE WANT TO GO BACK
TO WORK RIGHT -- AND WE DON'T
HAVE -- YOU KNOW MASS TRANSIT
EVERY SINGLE POINT IN.
PLACE SO I MEAN I THINK -- THAT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE IN NINETY AT
CERTAIN POINTS IF YOUR ASSETS
WERE REALLY TRULY LARGE AND I
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE WELL WHAT
HAPPENS IF SOMEONE INHERITED HER.
SOMEONE'S HOUSE IT WAS WORTH A
MILLION DOLLARS BOB LIGHTS.
CETERA -- WELL WITH THE STATE
DID KEEP UNTIL THE FIRST
PROPERTY TAX BILL I'M SURE EVEN
NOW SO -- EVEN WITH PROP
THIRTEEN SO -- SO I MEAN IT IT
JUST DOESN'T SEEM TO MAKE A LOT
OF SENSE TO ME THAT WE USE V.
THE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDICK
SAVINGS FOR THE MINISTRY BURDEN
THAT THAT.
AND IF YOU ACTUALLY HAD THAT
MUCH CASH I MEAN IT.
I GUESS YOU COULD STICK IN THE
MATTRESS SOMEONE MAKE ANY MONEY
BUT I UNDERSTAND AS SOON AS YOU
START SPENDING DOWN ANY OF IT
THAT STARTS COUNT THAT GETS
COUNTED AS YOUR INCOME RIGHT
SELF YOU GOT.
AN INHERITANCE I'D SAY AND HE
SAID WELL I'M GOING TO PULL OUT
TEN THOUSAND OUT OF THAT RIGHT
TO SPEND ON SOMETHING.
THE MATTER WHAT NO MATTER HOW
WORTHY THAT COUNTS AGAINST YOUR
INCOME AND SO THEN THAT PUSHES
YOU ARCHAEOLOGY BILLY ANYWAY.
SO I I AM A WAITING TO FIND
SOMEONE WHO HAS A BIG WAD OF
MONEY WHO SAYS YOU KNOW WHAT
THOUGH I'M GONNA FIND A WAY TO
JUST LIVE ON CAL WORKS NOT TOUCH
THAT THING.
AND GO THROUGH ALL THE INTRUSION
THAT I MEAN LET'S BE BLUNT IT'S
AN DON'T FLYING WE WE MAKE IT
INTRUSIVE WE MAKE EVERYONE BEAR
THEIR FINANCIAL SOUL RIGHT TO TO
I WAS REALLY WORKER BEFORE WE
LET THEM SIGN ON AT THAT
SOMEONE'S REALLY YEAH I THINK
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SOME. FOR
FRAUD OR CHEATING IS SO MINIMAL --
A CERTAINLY IS AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL RECOGNIZE SOMEONE COULD
TRY TO TURN A STORY YOU KNOW
SOMEONE HAS YOU KNOW THEY HAVE A
CADILLAC OR SOMETHING AT THAT
THE OLD ONE BUT THEY HAVE ONE
THEY GOT IT THEN THERE'S SOMEONE
GAVE IT TO THEM.
AND TA GETTING HOW WORKS AND HOW
COULD YOU LET THEM DO THAT BUT I
THINK REALISTICALLY WE NEED TO
TALK REALITY.
AND SO I HOPE I A ACTUALLY BY
BECAUSE OF REALLY I MEAN I I
THINK WE MIGHT EVEN SAVE MONEY
DOING THIS.
RIGHT CELL SO WHEN WE LOOK AT
THIS I THINK YOU KNOW -- THE
ACTUAL COST.
SELL IT AT THE BE INTERESTING OF
WHAT THE ACTUAL COST OR EVEN
POTENTIAL SAVINGS WOULD BE ON
THIS BUT I'M HOPING WE CAN.
REALLY LOOK AT FIGURING THAT OUT
BECAUSE MY GUESS IS THE GAS
RIGHT NOW TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
RIGHT -- THAT IT'S IT'S GOING TO
BE OF FOR THE THRIVE. FOR ALL
THE HOUSEHOLD ELIMINATES FOR A
DE MINIMUS BUT YOU'LL LET US
KNOW NAY RIGHT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
THE OTHER COMMENTS ON THE OKAY.
SIZE OF THE SITES WE WANT LESS
REGULATION RIGHT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT ITEM NUMBER EIGHT IS
THE EMERGENCY CHILD CARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM FOR FOSTER CHILDREN.
HIS FOR SENDING THEIR KIMBERLY
DEATH.
BUT THAT'S EXACTLY OKAY SORRY.
IF ALL RIGHT THE CHILD ACTION
WELCOME.
YOU CAN ONLY HAVE ONE IN YOUR
EMAIL [inaudible]
THAT.
EMINEM FOSTER RICH AN EMERGENCY
FOSTER BRIDGE NAM AND PROGRAM.
AND HERE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE
PARTNER SACRAMENTO COUNTY DC F.
A. S..
IN IMPLEMENTING THE FOSTER CARE
BRIDGE PROGRAM -- THIS PROPOSAL
IS ASKING TO GROW THE EXISTING
PROGRAM BY PROVIDING THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION. TO EXPAND THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING AVAILABLE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL VOUCHERS FIVE
MILLION TO SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
NAVIGATORS AND FOUR MILLION FOR
ADDITIONAL TRAUMA INFORMED
TRAINING.
AN CHILD ACTION HAS RECEIVED TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE BRIDGE
PROGRAM REFERRAL SO FAR.
WE'VE CURRENTLY -- HAVE
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE CHILDREN.
AND ONE HUNDRED AND ONE FAMILIES
ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM.
EACH FAMILY IS SERVED BY A CHILD
CARE NAVIGATOR.
THE LEVEL OF SUPPORT EACH FAMILY
RECEIVES VARIES GREATLY.
BASED UPON THEIR NEED.
AND SACRAMENTO COUNTY ONE OF OUR
PRIORITY POPULATIONS IS
EXPECTING IN PARENTING YOUTH.
AND I CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR THIS
PROGRAM.
WILL HELP COUNTIES SERVE MORE
FOSTER CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
FOSTER CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM STAFF
ALONG WITH PARTNERS WILL NOT
HAVE TO MAKE TOUGH DECISIONS
ABOUT HOW TO LIMIT THE NUMBER
SERVE DUE TO LACK OF FUNDING.
AND MANY OF OUR AB TWELVE
CHILDREN ARE ENTERING INTO THE
CHILD CARE SYSTEM FOR THE VERY
FIRST TIME.
PARENTING USER OFTEN HAS A TEN
IT AKES ABOUT PHONE STRINGS
BASED APPROACH TO ASSIST THEM.
IT ALSO REQUIRES A DEEP
KNOWLEDGE OF THE LOCAL CHILD
CARE CONTINUE IN.
JUST A COUPLE OF ANTIDOTES HERE.
AND ONE EIGHTY TELL PARENTS THAT
I RECENTLY WORKED WITH NEEDED
CHILD CARE SO SHE CAN RETURN TO
SCHOOL AND WORK CHOOSE A BRIGHT
YOUNG LADY SHE WAS ALREADY
TAKING WANTED TO TAKE.
TWO AND COLLEGE COURSES AS HERE
COLLEGE.
AND SHE BUT SHE WAS EXTREMELY
HESITANT.
ABOUT LEAVING HER ONE YEAR OLD
IN CHILD CARE.
A SHE NEEDED ENCOURAGEMENT EVERY
STEP ALONG THE WAY.
HOW TO CHECK IN WITH HER
REGULARLY AND EACH TIME HE DOES
HIS MAKING STEPS?
THE MOTHER IS BUT ONE OF DOZENS
WE'VE WORKED WITH.
AND ANOTHER FAMILY.
AT FOUR SIBLINGS THEY WERE.
AT RISK OF POSSIBLY BEING SPLINT
AND THEIR GRANDPARENTS WANTED
THEM -- IN THEIR CARE.
AT BUT WITHOUT HEALTHCARE THE
THE THE FEAR THAT THEY CUT IT.
AND UPON WORKING WITH THEM THEY
WERE JUST IN TEARS.
THAT AND THEY WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS A CHILD
CARE ASSISTANCE.
AND SO NOW THIS FOR CHILDREN'S
ARE WITH THEIR GRANDPARENTS.
AND IN MOVING FORWARD WE
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO CONSIDER
INCLUDING THIS BUDGET BUDGET
ARGUMENTATION REQUEST AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION.
Q. ANY COMMENTS FROM OUR SOURCES
REALLY THINK -- BUT CHILD ACTION
AND OTHER PARTNERS WHO ARE
PROVIDING THESE RESOURCES TO
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE THIS
IS OBVIOUSLY BEEN AT A GREAT AT
LAUNCH OF THIS EFFORT AND IS THE
COMPANION TO ALL THE WORK WE'RE
DOING OUR CONTINUING CARE REFORM
TO REALLY.
SUPPORT HAVE CHILDREN GETTING
INTO UP PLACEMENTS IN HAVING
THAT CHILD CARE AVAILABILITY IS
A CRITICAL SUPPORT TO THAT SO --
I THINK THE ONLY THING WE WOULD
ADD MENTION IS THAT IT THE
BRIDGE IS STILL EARLY IN ITS AT
PROGRAMS AT IMPLEMENTATION IF WE
UNDERSTAND THE PROPOSAL PART OF
IT IS LOOKING AT AT ELIMINATING
ANY DURATION TO THE CHILD CARE
AFTER COMPONENT SO WE'D SAY.
WE'RE JUST AT THE POINT POINT OF
LEARNINGWHETHER OR NOT THE
BRIDGE ACTUALLY CONNECTS TO THAT
LONGER TERM CHILDCARE SUBSIDY
AND WANT THAT TO INFORM ANY
DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE IN TERMS
OF DURATION.
AND DISPLAY NOTE THAT I GUESS WE
SHOULD TRY HEARD THIS LAST WEEK
OR HEARING THE OTHER FOSTER CARE
PIECES BUT I APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE PRESENT HERE TODAY.
TELL YOU [inaudible]
FINANCE OKAY.
SO AGAIN NOT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR PRESENTATION I THINK IN THE
CONTEXT OF OF OUR PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION LAST WEEK ABOUT
FOSTER CARE AND BEING SURE THAT --
THAT WE HAVE THE AVAILABILITY OF
CHILD CARE FOR THESE FAMILIES
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
SO NOW WILL IT TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON AND WE HAVE EIGHT
PROPOSALS INVESTMENT SO YOU CAN
TELL ME WHICH ONES ARE YOUR
FAVORITE ONES -- OR YOU CAN SAY
YOU SUPPORT ALL LATER SOMETHING
IN BETWEEN SO WELCOME THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SYLVIA VALENCIA
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
THE COUCH POLICY SECTION.
AND WE ARE ACTUALLY CO SPONSOR
OF THE PROPOSAL TO INCREASE THE
EARNED INCOME DISREGARDS.
AND SO AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER --
THE FAMILIES AND CAL WORKS ARE
BEING ABRUPTLY DISCONTINUED FROM
THE PROGRAM AND THIS IS MORE SO
HAPPENING OF IN LA AT IN IN --
AT A FASTER RATE AND THE REASON
FOR THAT IS BECAUSE THE LOS
ANGELES WE'VE IMPLEMENTED THE
MINIMUM WAGE -- INCREASES A LOT
FASTER THAN THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WE BEGAN OUR LAST YEAR AS OF
LAST YEAR -- JULY AT OUR MINIMUM
WAGE IS THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE
IT'S GOING TO BE -- INCREASE TO
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE THIS YEAR
IN JULY AND NEXT YEAR IT'LL BE
IT'LL GO UP TO FIFTEEN DOLLARS.
SO BASED ON THAT WE'VE LOOKED AT
AT SOME OF THE DATA AND WE'RE
ANTICIPATING THERE APPROXIMATELY
FOUR THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
FAMILIES ARE GOING TO BE
DISCONTINUED DURING THIS PERIOD.
ARE WE ALSO NOTICED THAT WE'RE
DENYING FAMILIES THAT TWICE THE
RATE THAN WE USED TO OVER THE
LAST DECADE WE WERE DENYING
FAMILIES DUE TO INCOME AT 18%.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND TEN WE'RE
NOW IT'S NOW AT 31%.
SO YOU KNOW FAMILIES ARE BEING
FORCED TO REDUCE OUR WORK HOURS
AND IN ORDER TO CONTINUE
RECEIVING AID ON THE PROGRAM.
HOWEVER THIS PUTS THEM IN A
SITUATION OF NOT BEING ABLE TO
AFFORD RENT IN LA WHICH IS AT A
VERY HIGH COST.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY FAMILIES LOSE
OUR HOUSING AND BECOME HOMELESS
AND TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT OF THE
DATA THAT WAS REQUESTED OUR YEAR
WE HAVE OVER FOURTEEN THOUSAND
HOMELESS FAMILIES IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY THESE ARE FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN.
IN ADDITION IF THEY CHOOSE TO
KEEP EMPLOYMENT AND INCREASE
THEIR INCOME SO THAT THEY CAN
AFFORD HOUSING NOW TO USE OUR
CARROTS AND RAMPARTS OKAY SO WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
TRY TO ASK PEOPLE TO KEEP FOR
THE MINUTE WE PEOPLE CAN SUBMIT
THINGS IN WRITING AND SO FORTH
BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU MARTHA CARRERA'S INTO
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THAT IS UP A CO
SPONSOR PROPOSAL IS ON THAT WERE --
SUPPORTING BUT ALSO FOR THE
CHILDCARE BRIDGE PROGRAM WE ARE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT PROPOSAL
BECAUSE IS -- YOU HER THIS IS
HELPING FOSTER CARE FAMILIES --
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED FOR THE CHILDREN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA I'M GONNA GIVE YOU MY
FAVORITES THERE'S A LOT THEIR
EARNED INCOME DISREGARD TO
PROPOSE NUMBER ONE THE PROPOSAL
ON THE HOME VISITING INITIATIVE --
DEFINITELY THE RESTORATION OF
THE SIXTEEN MONTH TIME CLOCK I
THINK THAT ONE'S WAY OVERDUE --
THE HOMELESS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
REPEAL OF THE ASSETS TEST
ANOTHER ONE THAT'S WAY OVERDUE --
AND THE EMERGENCY CHILD CARE
BRIDGE PROGRAM THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
AND OUR DOCTOR PASSED ME AGAIN
CHECK A LONG FACE M..
AND HELP OUR IN CALIFORNIA DITTO
TO EVERYTHING THAT AND INSTEAD
IS SUPPORTING.
I ALSO WAS TOLD THAT A CHILD
CARE LAWCENTER IS ALSO
SUPPORTING ALL THIS THINKING
OKAY WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
WELCOME THEIR DAVIS TERROR --
TONY RICE ABOUT THE LOS ANGELES
AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE JUST
VERY QUICKLY WE ARE VERY PERCENT
OF THE LEGISLATURE TWO YEARS AGO
ON THE CHILD CARE BRIDGE FUNDING
WE ARE CO SPONSORS OF THAT
EFFORT -- WE FULLY SUPPORT --
THE LEGISLATURE LOOKING AT
AUGMENTING IT THIS YEAR THAT'S
OR ENCOURAGES EVERYONE SUPPORT
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
ALEX TO CAPPER ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE IN SUPPORT OF THE
EMERGENCY CHILD CARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM FOR FOSTER CHILDREN THIS
IMPORTANT PROGRAM THAT
CONTRIBUTES TO THE STATE'S
MISSION TO PROVIDE LOVING AND
SUPPORTIVE FOSTER HOMES FOR A
STATES MOST FORMAL BROKE
VULNERABLE CHILDREN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME IS AN
ANTIPHONAL CHILDREN NOW HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE EMERGENCY FOSTER
CARE PRIDGEN JUST WANNA SAY HUGE
THANK YOU TO THE PART AND THEN
ONE OF THE BEST ROLL OUTS OF A
PROGRAM WE'VE SEEN IN A LONG
TIME SAID THANK YOU.
AND WHEN WE SUPPORT JUST
INCREASE FUNDING OKAY THANK YOU.
WELCOME I AM DIANA DOMINGUEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILD CARE
APPLIANCE OF LOS ANGELES AND THE
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER. EIGHT
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR EMERGENCY CHILDCARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM -- OVER THE PAST SEVEN
MONTHS MY AGENCY THE CHILD CARE
RESOURCE CENTER -- HAS PROVIDED --
EMERGENCY CHILD CARE TO TWO
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE FOSTER
CHILDREN IN LOS ANGELES AND SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTIES -- AND MOVED
SIXTY FIVE OF THOSE CHILDREN TO
ONGOING CARE THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI SHANTI HAS RUN WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE AMAZING
CHILD CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GEN REXFORD WITH CALIFORNIA AT
ALLIANCE OF CARE GIVERS AND
STRONG SUPPORT AT THE EMERGENCY
CHILD CARE BRIDGE WERE ALSO VERY
GRATEFUL FOR ALL THE WORK THAT'S
GONE INTO IMPLEMENTATION AND
REALLY FEEL THAT THAT TRAUMA
INFORMED TRAINING.
HAS BEEN OF BENEFIT TO ALL
CHILDREN AND COUNTY NOT JUST
FELT CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE.
AND AM ALSO PARENTING AND AB
TWELVE YEARS HIS EIGHTEEN AND
ABOUT TO BECOME A MOTHER.
AND SHE IS AMAZING AND I'M SO
THANKFUL FOR THAT PROGRAM AND
ALL THE SUPPORT SHE'S ESTABLISH
STABILITY SHE'LL DEFINITELY NEED
THE CHILD CARE.
THANKS THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS JULIE SMITH AND
ON THE RESOURCE AND REFERRAL
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR CHILD ACTION.
I WORK WITH THE TEAM WHO
IMPLEMENT THE BRIDGE PROGRAM FOR
OUR ORGANIZATION THANK YOU CDSS.
THE STATE LEGISLATURE ARE COUNTY
PARTNERS FOR SUPPORTING THIS
VERY WORTHWHILE PROGRAM WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT MORE
FUNDING FOR NAVIGATION SERVICES.
THE TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
TRAINING AND ESPECIALLY THE NO
TIME LIMIT WOULD BE LOVELY -- IN
WORKING IN UNDER THE PROGRAM FOR
THE PAST YEAR SO I HAVE SEEN.
COUNTY BY COUNTY DIFFERENT
STRUGGLES THAT EACH COUNTY THAT
WE'VE PARTNERED WITH -- HAS HAD
TO MAKE ONE QUICK STORY IS A
CHILD FROM ANOTHER COUNTY
ORIGINATED FROM ANOTHER COUNTY
BUT PLACE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
THE COUNTY OF ORIGIN WAS NOT
THEIR ONLY FINDING VOUCHERS FOR
FAMILY PLACEMENTS AND SO THIS
POOR RESOURCE MOTHER.
WHO WAS REQUESTED BY THIS CHILD
IN PARTICULAR?
FOR I'M TAKING SUCH WONDERFUL
CARE OF HIM IN THE PAST WAS
REALLY STRUGGLING AND IT WAS A
PHONE CALL I GOT LATE ON A
FRIDAY AND I WAS TRYING TO HELP
HER AND IN THE END ONCE I
TRACKED IT DOWN I WAS LIKE I'M
SO SORRY SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SCENE NO ONE ELSE AT THE
MICROPHONE -- STATES WE WILL
HOLD -- THESE PROPOSALS WERE
INVESTMENTS OPEN AND WHAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR EVERYONE'S
PRESENTATIONS -- SO WORDS
ESSENTIALLY CONCLUDES OUR AGE
AND WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT NEXT
WEEK -- WE ARE IN RECESS SO WE
WILL NOT BE HEARING IN NEXT WEEK --
AND THEN -- WILL HAVE ANOTHER
HEARING THE WEEK AFTER AND WE'RE
GETTING CLOSE TO MAY SO ALL
THESE MAY REVISE THINGS -- AND I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THIS WE'RE
GOING TO RECESS SOMEONE THINK --
MY COLLEAGUES AND HOPEFULLY
EVERYONE HAS A WELL OF THOSE I
KNOW THEY REALLY WORKING HARD
NEXT WEEK -- BUT LITTLE TIME OFF
FROM ALL OF US BEING AROUND HERE
LEGISLATORS AND SO WITH THAT
THIS CONCLUDES THE AGENDA A AND
THIS HEARING OF THE BUDGET TO
SCHOOL SUBCOMMITTEE.
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AND
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU